GOOD AFTERNOON.
THIS WILL BEGIN TODAY'S SUB ONE
HEARING ON MAY SEVENTH.
I'D LIKE TO START BY
ESTABLISHING CORN.
ARAMBULA HERE HARPER.
MATHIS RUBIO HERE WOULD.
I'D LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
ON ISSUE ONE.
TO TAKE ACTION ON THE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL REGARDING LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
REPORT APPROPRIATION.
LOOKING FOR A SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND ON
ISSUE ONE I'D LIKE US TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA AYE
HARPER.
AND MATHIS RUBIO. WOULD.
THE US FOR VOTES AND IS NOW
MOVED AND TAKEN ACTION ON. WILL
MOVE TO ISSUE TO.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU.
MISTER WOOD AND MISTER ARE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA.
OKAY.
AS THE CHAIR OF THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES
I AM VERY EXCITED TO ANNOUNCE
THAT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY.
WE'LL BE TAKING STEPS TODAY TO
MAKE A MAJOR INVESTMENT IN
HEALTH CARE.
TODAY WE WILL BE PROPOSING TO
TAKE ACTION ON A PACKET OF
HEALTH CARE INITIATIVES.
THAT WILL RESULT AND INVESTMENT
OF JUST OVER ONE BILLION
DOLLARS.
THIS INVESTMENT IS HISTORIC AND
UNPRECEDENTED AND WILL MOVE US
FORWARD.
TODAY'S ACTION ON THESE
PROPOSALS SHOWS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY IS COMMITTED TO
IMPROVING OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS
JUST THE NEXT STEP.
I AM HONORED TO VOTERS TO BE
PRESENTING THESE PROPOSALS TODAY
ALONGSIDE.
MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM
WOOD.
AS CO CHAIRS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS AND UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE.
DOCTOR WOULDN'T I HAVE SPENT
MOST OF THE LAST SEVEN MONTHS
FOCUSED ON THIS ISSUE.
WE HOLD SEVEN HEARINGS AND OVER
THIRTY HOURS OF TESTIMONY
HEARING FROM EXPERTS FROM AROUND
THE COUNTRY ABOUT THE WAYS TO
IMPROVE OUR HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEMS.
WE IDENTIFIED BOTH SHORT AND
LONG TERM GOALS WHICH HAVE
RESULTED IN A NUMBER OF BILLS
BEING INTRODUCED THIS YEAR.
AND WE HAVE IDENTIFIED BUDGETARY
OPTIONS THAT WILL GET US CLOSER
TO UNIVERSAL COVERAGE.
TODAY WE ARE PRESENTING A
PACKAGE OF HEALTHCARE
INITIATIVES THAT WILL RESULT IN
AN INVESTMENT OF JUST OVER ONE
BILLION.
THIS PACKAGE OF ITEMS WILL
EXPAND COVERAGE.
MAKE HEALTHCARE MORE AFFORDABLE
AND PROVIDE MORE ACCESS TO CARE
GETTING US CLOSER TO UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE.
SPECIFICALLY.
WITH AN EXPANDING TO COVERAGE WE
ARE PROPOSING TO APPROVE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION. TO EXTEND
MEDI CAL TO LOW INCOME YOUNG
ADULTS
AGE NINETEEN THROUGH TWENTY
FIVE.
WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED AND INCOME
ELIGIBLE?
THIS BUILDS ON OUR EFFORTS TO
EXPAND COVERAGE AND REDUCE THE
LEVELS OF UNINSURED.
IT IS ALSO THE NEXT LOGICAL STEP
AFTER WE.
EXPANDED MEDICAL COVERAGE TO ALL
CHILDREN THROUGH THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN.
THIS WILL ALSO ALIGN WITH WHAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S DID IT
WHEN IT ENACTED THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT.
WHEN IT REQUIRED INSURANCE
COVERAGE FOR YOUNG ADULTS UNTIL
THE AGE OF TWENTY SIX.
I WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT I AM
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON
EXPANDING HEALTH CARE ACCESS TO
ALL OF OUR UNDOCUMENTED AN
INCOME ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS.
THIS IS JUST THE NEXT STEP.
BUT KNOW THAT THERE WILL BE MORE
STEPS TO COME SO WE CAN HAVE
HEALTH FOR ALL.
ALSO IN EXPANDING COVERAGE WE
ARE PROPOSING TO EXPAND MEDI CAL
ENROLLMENT
TO NINETY THOUSAND CHILDREN AND
THIRTEEN THOUSAND PREGNANT
WOMEN.
BY SPENDING TWENTY SIX MILLION
TO STREAMLINE MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY TO UNINSURED
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN AND PREGNANT
WOMEN WHO ARE ENROLLING IN THE
WOMEN INFANTS AND CHILDREN
NUTRITION PROGRAM.
FAR PROPOSED PACKAGE ALSO
INCLUDES THIRTY MILLION TO
EXPAND MEDICAL COVERAGE TO THE
TWENTY THOUSAND SENIORS AND
DISABLED PEOPLE.
WHOSE INCOME LEVELS ARE BETWEEN
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
PERCENT AND A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL.
EXPANDING COVERAGE TO THIS
POPULATION INSURERS THAT THIS
POPULATION THAT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDI CAL. DOES NOT LOSE
THEM SOLELY DUE TO THEIR AGE.
THIS WILL HELP THOUSANDS OF
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS ACCESS
THE CARE THAT THEY NEED.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
LOW INCOME SENIORS THAN ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES. AREN'T HAVING
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN PUTTING FOOD
ON THE TABLE AND GOING TO THE
DOCTOR.
LASTLY WITHIN EXPANDING ACCESS
WE WILL EXTEND TRANSITIONAL MEDI
CAL FROM SIX MONTHS TO TWELVE
MONTHS.
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
TRANSITIONING OFF OF CAL WORKS.
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT IS
FAMILY'S MOVE OUT OF POVERTY WE
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL BUFFER
PERIOD. SO THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT PAYING FOR
HEALTHCARE PREMIUMS OR OUT OF
POCKET COSTS. WHILE THEY'RE
TRYING TO BECOME FINANCIALLY
STABLE.
I AM PLEASED TO HAVE TO JOIN DR
ARAMBULA IN PRESENTING POLLS OF
THAT WE BELIEVE REPRESENTS A
MAJOR INVESTMENT IN HEALTHCARE
AND A COMMITMENT TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE WHAT I
HOPE WILL BE THE FIRST STEPS IN
BUDGETARY ACTIONS TO ACHIEVE
UNIVERSAL COVERAGE.
COVERAGE IS NOT CARE.
AND THAT IS WHY THESE MULTIPLE
POLICY INITIATIVES FOCUSED ON
OUR PURSUIT OF THE LONGER TERM
STRUCTURAL CHANGES NEEDED IN
ORDER TO ASSURE. INCREASED
ACCESS CARE AND AFFORDABILITY.
TODAY'S ACTIONS ALL TOGETHER
WILL SUPPORT ALL OF THESE GOALS
AND BY PROVING AFFORDABILITY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
AS WELL AS INCREASE WORKFORCE
CAPACITY. THIS PACKAGE INCLUDES
OVER FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO HELP FAMILIES PAY FOR
PREMIUMS THROUGH COVER
CALIFORNIA.
IT WILL PROVIDE PRINT PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE TO FAMILIES AND COVER
CALIFORNIA WHOSE WHOSE HOUSEHOLD
INCOME IS BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED TO
FOUR HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
CURRENTLY FAMILIES IN THOSE
INCOME LEVELS RECEIVE ASSISTANCE
TO COVER CALIFORNIA BUT STILL
STRUGGLE TO AFFORD HEALTH CARE
BECAUSE OF THE HIGHER PREMIUMS
AND OUT OF POCKET COSTS.
INCLUDING LARGE DEDUCTIBLES
ASSOCIATED WITH MOST COMMON
CHOICE OF A BRONZE PLAN
WHICH REQUIRES OUT OF POCKET
COSTS ABOUT MORE THAN SIX
THOUSAND PERSON. SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER PERSON PER YEAR.
LOS INCLUDE ASSISTANCE TO
FAMILIES AND COVER CALIFORNIA
WHO DON'T RECEIVE ANY FINANCIAL
SUPPORT THIS TIME.
WE'RE PROPOSING A REFUNDABLE TAX
CREDIT FOR PEOPLE WHOSE INCOME
BETWEEN FOUR HUNDRED AND SIX ON
A PERCENT OF THE FEDERATED WILL
POVERTY LEVEL.
FOUR HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE
FEDERAL FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL IS
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A MARRIED COUPLE.
IN SOME CASES THESE FAMILIES ARE
SPENDING MORE THAN TWENTY
PERCENT OF THEIR INCOME ON
PREMIUMS IN OUT OF POCKET COSTS
TO COVER CALIFORNIA.
OUR PROPOSAL ASSURES THAT
FAMILIES WON'T HAVE TO DECIDE
BETWEEN PAYING RENT OR THEIR
HEALTHCARE PREMIUMS.
TO MAKE THIS WORK WE MUST INVENT
ITS MASS INVEST IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT TO BALANCE EXPANSION
OF COVERAGE WITH AVAILABILITY OF
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS NEEDED TO
PROVIDE TREATMENT.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA HAS IT
INADEQUATE PRIMARY CARE
WORKFORCE TO MEET OUR DEMANDING
HEALTH COURT CARE NEEDS.
ARE A.
TO BOLSTER OUR MEDICAL WORKFORCE
OVER THE YEARS WE PROPOSE FIFTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE SONG
BROWN PROGRAM OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS AS WELL A THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE UC.
PROGRAMS IN MEDICAL EDUCATIONAL
CALL PRIME.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR SONG
BROWN WILL HELP INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF FAMILY PRACTICE
PHYSICIANS.
PHYSICIAN'S ASSISTANTS NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND OUR ENDS IN
MEDICALLY UNS ANNOUNCE
UNDERSERVED AREAS BY FINANCIALLY
SUPPORTING RESIDENCY PROGRAMS IN
THOSE AREAS.
EXPANDING FUNDING FOR PRIME
ALLOWS ADDITIONAL FULL TIME
STUDENT ENROLLMENT IN THESE THIS
INITIATIVE TRAINING PROGRAM
DESIGNED TO TRAIN SOCIALLY
CONSCIOUS STUDENTS. AS FUTURE
COME CLINICIANS FOCUSED ON
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS IN BOTH
RURAL AND URBAN AREAS.
AND FINALLY WE ARE REQUESTING
APPROVAL OF FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH AN ALL
PAYER PASSED PAYMENTS DATABASE
THAT IS NEEDED TO GATHER
INFORMATION ON THE ACTUAL COST
OF HEALTHCARE SERVICES.
ESPECIALLY PAYMENTS MADE A
POSITION SO THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE
TRANSPARENCY IN HEALTHCARE
PAYMENTS.
AND BEGIN TO CONTAIN COSTS
ALL TOTAL THIS GROUP THE
QUESTION MOUNTS TO JUST OVER
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
HEALTHCARE. UNNECESSARY AND
CRITICAL INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
I. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS TAMRON
AND WHAT HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA THE STATE WIDE HEALTH
CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY COALITION
WORKING FOR QUALITY AFFORDABLE
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
WE ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL PRESENTED BY DOCTORS
WHAT IT ARAMBULA.
CALIFORNIA'S UNINSURED RATE IS
AT A HISTORIC LOW THANKS TO A
ROBUST IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT AND THIS
PROPOSAL MOVES WITH. TO
UNIVERSAL COVERAGE
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU TO FURTHER REFINE AND
DEVELOP THIS PROPOSAL.
FIRST WE ARE VERY THRILLED AT
THE ASSEMBLY AS COMMITTED TO
COVERING MORE UNDOCUMENTED
ADULTS AND MEDI CAL WE HAVE
ADVOCATED FOR REMOVING MEDICAID
AS UNFAIR EXCLUSION OF
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS ENTIRELY
AND THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL. TO
COVER YOUNG ADULTS TO AGE TWENTY
SIX AND IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD. WE BELIEVE ANOTHER
PRIOR TO POPULATION.
THAT'S A BECAUSE IT WOULD BE A
OLDER ADULTS WHO HAVE MORE
MEDICAL NEEDS.
SECOND WE ARE DELIGHTED TO SEE
THE PROPOSAL TO IMPROVE
AFFORDABILITY OF PREMIUMS AND
THE INDIVIDUAL MARKETS.
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT HAS
HELPED MILLIONS TO GET AND KEEP
COVERAGE BUT IN THE HIGH COST IT
LIKE CALIFORNIA MORE FINANCIAL
HELP IS NEEDED.
PROVIDING HELP FOR PEOPLE WHO
MAKE LESS THAN FOUR HAD A
PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL OR FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
AS AN INDIVIDUAL TO AFFORD THE
PREMIUMS AS AN IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD SO THAT MORE OF THE
REMAINING UNINSURED. BECOME
INSURED AND THOSE WHO HAVE
COVERAGE NOW CAN BETTER AFFORD
IT.
PROVIDING HELP FOR PEOPLE WHO
MAKE OVER FOR HER TO PERCENT OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL WHO
CURRENTLY DO NOT QUALIFY FOR ANY
FEDERAL SUBSIDIES AT ALL IS ALSO
CRITICAL. THESE PEOPLE UP EARNED
ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
AN INDIVIDUAL OR SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR A MARRIED
COUPLE.
AND BOTH DOCTOR WHAT THE AND
BOTH ADVOCATES IT SHOULD LOOK AT
BOTH.
DOCTOR WOULD A DOCTOR ASSEMBLY
I'M DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS AMERICA WILL
YOU KNOW BOTH AGE SIXTY TWO
MAKING SOME THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR WHICH IS NOT A WHOLE LOT OF
MONEY ARTS CURRENTLY SPENDING
YOU KNOW ANYWHERE FROM LIKE
TWENTY EIGHT SO LIKE THE FORTY
PERCENT OF THEIR INCOME ON
PREMIUMS. AND DEDUCTIBLES ALONE
AND YOU KNOW THE OF THE PROPOSAL
WAS PRESENTED HERE TODAY WOULD.
HELP THESE INDIVIDUALS AND WE
BELIEVE THAT CAPITAL PREMIUMS
WOULD BE IT'LL SOMETHING THAT
WOULD.
MAKE HEALTH WILL BE THE FIRST
IN THE NATION TO.
HELP.
APPROVE AFFORDABILITY FOR THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
AND
WE THINK THAT.
HELPING LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME
PEOPLE AFFORD COVERAGE NOT ONLY
HELP PEOPLE GET AND KEEP
COVERAGE BUT ALSO MAINTAINS THE
BILLION OR INDIVIDUAL MARKET
WHICH IS. VERY IMPORTANT THIS
YEAR I'M CONSIDERING ALL THE
FEDERAL ACTIONS THAT HAVE YOU
CREATED.
ELEVEN CERTAINTY AND INDIVIDUAL
MARKETS
AND FINALLY WE ALSO SUPPORT
FUNDING FOR ALL PROCLAIMS
DATABASE WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE SUPPORTED.
PNEUMOTHORAX LATER ON THIS
ISSUE AND THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
THE LEGISLATURE'S ACTION
PROPOSED TO FUND THE EFFORTS. SO
WE.
TODAY ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
CONSUMERS WE VERY MUCH THANK DR
SO WOULD AND ARAMBULA FOR THE
PROPOSAL AND FOR THE.
YOU KNOW AMAZING EFFORT TO
BRING US CLOSER TO UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE AND A SYSTEM THAT'S
MORE AFFORDABLE FOR EVERYONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS PHYLLIS ANNA AND I
LIVING IN THE CITY OF DURHAM.
CALIFORNIA LOCATING THE
COACHELLA VALLEY.
I WORK IN THE FIELDS PICKING
BELL PEPPER.
AND I AM MONTHLY STUDENT AT
COLLEGE OF THE DESERT IN INDIO.
I AM HERE REPRESENTING MY
COMMUNITY AND MY FAMILY I AM
BLESSED TO BE PROTECTED BY
DHAKA.
AND I AM ALSO BLESSED TO BE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE MEDI CAL.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS NOT THE
CASE OF MY SISTER.
MY SISTER'S NAME. MY SISTER IS
NOT ABLE TO COME.
SO I BOUGHT BROUGHT HER ALONG
WITH THIS PICTURE.
MY SISTER HAS A SEVEN YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER.
THAT WAS BORN HERE IN THE US MY
SISTER IS ON DOCUMENTED. AND
ALSO WORKED IN THE FIELDS.%
SHE HAS BEEN FEELING SICK FOR
AWHILE.
BUT SHE COULDN'T AFFORD TO GO TO
A DOCTOR.
SO SHE HAS LET IT BE.
UNTIL LAST
YEAR SHE COULDN'T ANY LONGER.
AND WHEN SHE WENT TO A DOCTOR
SHE WAS DIAGNOSTIC WITH CANCER.
SO I AM HERE POLICE.
THANKS ON PREVIOUS COULD
SUPPORT.
HOLD FOR ALL.
THANK YOU.
OR LET. ME KNOW WHAT IS
BECOMING.
IS THAT MY MOTHER.
AND I'M CREATED ME GET ON DAY TO
DAY WAS THE PARTIES.
DE NEW CHOICES BUT SOMEONE TOLD
BUT ASSET AT IT WAS DIFFICULT
FOR THE LANDING.
GETTING A LITTLE.
WHAT FOLLOWED?
BUT I SEE NUMBER IS BECOMING
IT'S THIS LEVEL DEBATE ME MOTHER
A GADGET WILL COME ONLY GOOD AT
THAT THE PARTIES.
MY NAME IS A THIS IS A PICTURE
OF MY MOTHER WHO CAME.
AS A MIGRANT WORKER.
VOICES FOR SO MUCHO TO HOME TO
SANYO'S BUT.
POLITICALLY A THAT WHO CUTS YOU
ONLY MENTAL SEQUELS COMMODITIES
WHAT THAT ARE LIPODYSTROPHY
SEEN.
SHE WORKED VERY HARD TO SUPPORT
A FAMILY BECAUSE SHE WAS A
SINGLE MOM AND HAS ALWAYS WORKED
VERY HARD.
IT PUTS
BUT I JUST HAVE THE LOS PODEMOS.
SAID.
WE MOVE ETCETERA YATALA KISSES
WITH WHAT SO THE.
BELOW THE MOST WENT THAT CAN
PICK UP A COMPASS BUT THE UNITED
STATES WAS SALUTE.
IT IS A MATTER.
BOB THANKS TO HER AND HER.
HARD WORK WE WE WERE ABLE TO
DEVELOP AND TO BE PRODUCTIVE
CITIZENS AND ARE SLOWLY BUT
SURELY HER HEALTH BEGAN TO
DETERIORATE.
E. CUANDO.
WAYS NOTHING WAS CUENTA QUE NICE
THAT AND WE'VE BEEN AND BECAUSE%
WE MUST HAVE LOOKED ON OF THE
MOST CONTACT WITH ENIAC CONCEPT.
THAT I'M.
THE LOSSES AND OUT WHEN WHEN SHE
WASN'T FEELING WELL WE'VE
EVENTUALLY WENT TO THE DOCTOR WE
FIND OUT THAT SHE HAD.
BREAST CANCER.
I THINK THE LIMON TAPE WAY
SEEMED AND I'M OF A SAILOR PUT
CAPUS BUT I'M STILL STIMULUS
WOULD PUBLICADO WHERE THAT THE
MISSING FAMILY GOT UP WITH
SELECT UNTIL ON THE BILL. I
CONSENSUS ADVOCATE FOR THE MOST
PART ARE NOT PLEASE VISIT THAT.
E. PER SE AND NOT IN THE ALISON
BECAUSE MAYBE BECAUSE THIS IS I
JUST PUT UP WITH SECOND THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY HAVEN'T WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE MEANS TO HELP HER WE
DID WHAT WE COULD BUY CHEAP IN
OUR HAVE A PROPER MEDICAL
COVERAGE AND.
WE DIDN'T HAVE THE MEANS TO TO.
.
HELPER.
DOES THIS LASSEN A FEW NGHE
YANKEL PROPHETIC AND SAT.
I MEAN HE COULD WE LET THEM GET
SICK ON THE CITY'S YOU THE
FEDERAL KO BUT A GODLESS DEL
PEDAL WHEN UNINTELLIGENT POST
OFFICE. INTO THE SECOND IDEA.
I'M THAT THE ONLY OTHER THING
FOR HER TO DO WAS TO RETURN TO
MEXICO AND ARE. BOUGHT YOU'LL BE
BE PROVIDED ODD THE SOCIAL
SERVICES IN MEXICO AND SHE
STAYED OVER THERE. BILL SAY IT'S
A. ME ME ME.
YOU'RE KIDDING BUT YES BUT UP
IT'LL ESCAPING AND I.
CONCIENCIA DAVID.
CAPE WAS BECAUSE OF THE MOMENT
WHEN A STUDENT DISCIPLINE
ATTENDED AT THE AMPLE.
A PARTICULAR LOCATED IN THE
MORNING COMMUNITY OF THE MOTHER.
THE PLANS THAT THEN THE THAT'S A
DIMPLE BUT I QUE.
LET'S LET ME LEFT WEST MEDINA
CONSIGNMENT THING I'M FOR THAT
SOMETHING THAT'S ONLY THIS.
THERE'S A LOT OF FAMILIES IN THE
SAME SITUATION AND UNFORTUNATELY
MY MOTHER PASSED AWAY FROM OUR
BREAST CANCER BREAST CANCER IS
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE A. A
HELPED IF CAUGHT EARLY AND I'M
HERE TO ADVOCATE FOR OTHER
FAMILIES SO THAT IT DOESN'T FIT.
WHAT THEY ARE WHAT WE WENT
THROUGH DOESN'T HAPPEN TO OTHER
FAMILIES?
DRESSES
THANK YOU.
HELLO AND MANY MODELS THAT GAVE
OSAMA COMMITTEE PROSPECTOR FOR
THOUGHT IT LEGAL CENTER.
WHEREAS.
.
ORGANIZATION SERVING MEN WITH
MEMBERSHIP IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
WHICH.
IT COVERS RIVERSIDE SEVEN OF THE
NINE IMPERIAL COUNTIES.
I AM HERE TODAY REPRESENTING THE
PRIORITY OF ONE OF THE PARTIES
OF OUR ORGANIZATION AND YOU'VE
HEARD FROM A COUPLE OF OUR
MEMBERS.
.
FACE JANA.
AND BECOMING.
HOW SHOULD NOT BE A LUXURY HELP
IS A HUMAN THE SETHIAN RIGHT
PREVENTION IS KEY AND IN YOUR
POWER YOU HAVE THE KEY?
I CALL ON YOUR CONSCIOUS TO
SUPPORT HEALTH ROTH IE I DO WANT
TO SHARE A STORY.
ONE OF OUR YOUNGEST ONE OF OUR
YOUNG MEMBERS ARE NAMES THAT IS
HE BACK TWELVE YEARS OLD SHE WAS
PROTECT SHE WAS BLESSED AND
EMPOWERED. TO HAVE RECEIVED
HEALTH FRAUD KIDS THAT WE
ADVOCATED FOR AND PICKS Y. YOUR
SUPPORT. AND SHE HAS HEALTH
COVERAGE.
I FOUND OUT TWO MONTHS AGO SHE
CALLED THE ISSUE SET LOOSE.
I DON'T WANT HEALTH COVERAGE FOR
ME I WANTED FOR MY MOM.
HER MOM PASSED AWAY.
THESE ARE THE STORIES THAT WE
HEAR THE GRASSROOTS WITH HIS
WIFE THIS MYTH HEALTH PRODUCTS
SO PERSONAL FOR OUR
ORGANIZATION.
THAT WE COULD DO YOU THEME
WORKING AT THE GRASSROOTS.
IT'S A DIFFERENT REALITY
ESPECIALLY IN THIS ROLE GONE
COMMUNITY THAT WE SERVE THE
COURTS HAVE A VALUE. PROCESS I
MEAN I'VE BEEN A COUNTY AND WE
HEAR THE STORIES EVERYTHING GOLD
DAILY ABOUT ITS WHITE SO
IMPORTANT ORGANIZATION TO
ELEVATE.
BRING OUR MEMBERS.
THE CAPITAL.
AND HOLD OUR ELECTED TO
ACCOUNTABLE BECAUSE THIS IS THE
NEED WE NEED HEALTH FRAUD FOR
ALL FOR ALL THEIR FAMILIES
REGARDLESS OF THEIR STATUS.
BECAUSE HELP.
OTHERS THERE IS NO MONEY.
TO A PERSON.
SO JUST LIKE BENEFIT ALTAMONT.
SHE WISHED THAT SHE WANTED BACK
HEALTH PROBLEM BEEN FOR HER MOM
NOT FOR HER.
BUT THEY WERE VERY BLESSED THAT
WE HAVE HEALTH ON HEALTH PRO
KIDS THAT ARE COMING ARE
UNDOCUMENTED KIDS BUT NOW WE
CALL ON ALL OF YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT. HEALTH FOR ALL FAMILIES
BIG YOU.
HI EVERYONE ARMING THEM IS VERY
HOSPITABLE.
I AM ON THE COMMENT OF MY THAT
WITH THEM THE FIFTH BUT IT'S FOR
ME.
I HAVE A YOUR THE THE SEND
BOTHER BOMB THIRTY TWO YEARS OLD
YOU ADDRESS EVEN BOTHER. UNDER A
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OLD ARM
BUCKEYE THAT KIND OF.
STUDIES
I LIVE HERE IN THE UNITED STATES
FOR THIRTY YEARS.
I COME TO THE UNITED STATES
PUTTING OUR COUNTRY WHAT I
SUFFER.
I BECOME THE POLICE CORRUPTION.
A WITH AUTHORITIES HAVE YOU SEEN
WITH THEIR OWN FAR WHERE AFFECTS
ONE OF USE.
ARM A YEARS AGO AYE COVER.
I COME OUT TO MORE IN MY DIARY.
ON FROM.
THINGS SENTENCED TO ARE YOU ALSO
ARM.
WHEN LIKE I CAME FROM THE
COUNTRIES BECAUSE SOMEBODY COULD
LOVE WHEN WE VOTERS.
SO I FIND OUT THAT ARM.
THEY SAY THAT MAKE THAT IT MAYBE
THEY COULD LEAD WHAT'S FROM THAT
SONG WITHOUT OVERHEATING THEY
COULD NOT HAVE TO FIFTY POUNDS.
SO THEN I GET BY A BABY'S BY
MICHAEL THEN CUT MIGHT MIGHT
PAYLOAD LIMO BUT BECAUSE I
COULDN'T AFFORD ARM.
MEDICAL CUP.
AM I BEING THAT I'VE BEEN
WORKING THIRTY YEARS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
I WENT BILLION TEXAS ALL THE
TIME.
AND I THINK THAT NOW STARRING
FOR BOTH TO HAVE A PIECE OF.
THESE ARM.
LIKE. A HELL FOR ALL I THINK
WE'VE REALLY THIS THEY'RE BOTH.
.
IF YOU IF YOU ARE TO ME YOU KNOW
IF IF I DIDN'T SEE THE SICKENING
TO LOOK AT THE YEARS WHEN MY
THAT IT WILL GIVE ME BUT THE
CITIZENSHIP.
I JUST WANNA GET THE YEARS BACK
NOTED THIRTY YEARS.
OTHER NOBODY'S IN THE
GOVERNMENT.
SO I THINK WE THAT'S THERE TO BE
TREATED WITH ARM.
BED IT WITH RESPECT I THINK WE
DON'T NEED TO BE BEGGING.
ARE ASKING FOR ARM.
FOR BETTER TREATMENT I MIGHT
WEAR THAT ARM.
I'M AWARE THAT OF.
THAT I MEAN YOU KNOW THAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE THEY SAY THAT WITH
THEM THAT'S THEIR.
OF
THING BUT WE'VE WAITED THE SEVEN
I MEAN WE REALLY WE CONTRIBUTE
THEM THAT WE PAY TAXES THAT
WOULD IT WHERE.
SO I THINK THAT WITH THEM THIS
HAVE TO BE BEGGING FOR OUR HELP
AND IF WE COULD PREVENT IT COULD
NOT BE EASIER THREATEN OUR.
I MEAN ALL THE THINGS THAT
HAPPENED TO ME I NEED BUT I
THROUGH YOU NEED A LOT OF THINGS
UNUSUALLY COULD BE PREVENTED
BEFORE ALSO MEANT THAT FOLK WILL
HELP A LOT. IN WHATEVER IS
STATES W. ETISALAT SO YOU KNOW
WHAT IS THE PETITION MUCH IN
THAT IS RIGHT NOW. I MEAN IS
MAKING ALSO MORE SEEK MORE YOU
OR FAMILIES ARE GETTING SEEK OR
CHILDREN ARE EVERYBODY'S GIVEN
SEEK.
SO I'M I'VE REALLY. A THANK YOU
FOR. FOR THE BEES.
.
REPORT FROM MY HOPE THEY CAN
FIND SOME MONEY FOR US.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WERE PLEASED THAT THE
THE ASSEMBLY PRIORITIZE MEDI CAL
EXPANSION INCLUDING HEALTH FOR
ALL YOUNG ADULTS RAISING THE
MEDI CAL AGING DISABLED INCOME
ELIGIBILITY. AND WAKE UP EXPRESS
LANE ELIGIBILITY UP SPECIFICALLY
ROUTE RAISING THAT MEDI CAL
AGING DISABLED A INCOME LIMIT
WOULD PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
PARITY.
AS SENIORS SHOULD NOT BE SUBJECT
TO A LOWER INCOME ELIGIBILITY
JUST BECAUSE OF THEIR AGE A THIS
WOULD ALSO HELP ADDRESSING YOUR
POVERTY AS A MAJOR COSTS FOR
SENIORS IS THEIR HEALTHCARE. AND
WELFARE HAPPY TO SEE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES LEAVING
DEEP POVERTY BY EXTENDING
TRANSITIONAL MEDICAID OUT AND
MAKING COVERED CALIFORNIA MORE
AFFORDABLE AND INCREASING ACCESS
TO PROVIDERS IN UNDERSERVED
AREAS. I THIS IS. THIS PROPOSAL
IS AN IMPORTANT AND BOLD FIRST
STEP AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON
HEALTH FOR ALL PROTECTIVELY
OFFER OLDER ADULTS AS WELL AS. I
INCREASING AFFORDABILITY FOR
INDIVIDUALS UP TO TWO HUNDRED
PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LINE WHO NEEDS HELP ON
PURCHASING A COVER CALIFORNIA
PLAN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M GOV REALISTS
ART WITH THE LOS ANGELES
HEADQUARTERS OF THE NATIONAL
IMMIGRATION LAW CENTER.
WE SUPPORT THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
WHICH WILL GREATLY SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPAND ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND IN
PARTICULAR THE PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND ELIGIBILITY FOR MEDI CAL
TO UNDOCUMENTED YOUNG ADULTS.
THIS IS A RECOGNITION OF THEIR
FUNDAMENTAL HUMANITY AS WELL AS
THEIR ECONOMIC CONTRIBUTIONS.
AS A NEXT STEP TOWARD ACHIEVING
HEALTH FOR ALL WE ENCOURAGE YOU
TO CONSIDER EXPANDING MEDICAID
ELIGIBILITY TO UNDOCUMENTED
SENIORS WHO HAVE OFTEN
CONTRIBUTED A LIFETIME TO SOME
OF THE HARDEST PHYSICAL WORK. IN
THIS COUNTRY BUT REMAINS AMONG
THE COMMUNITIES MOST VULNERABLE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALISON PIECE WITH
THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I WANTED TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PROPOSALS THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND IS
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT. OF AND BUT
WE WANTED TO MENTION
SPECIFICALLY OURS SUPPORT FOR
THE WAKE EXPRESS LANE PROPOSAL
THAT WILK STREAMLINED A.
ENROLLMENT INTO MEDI CAL FOR UP
TO NINE AND NINETY THOUSAND
CHILDREN AND THIRTEEN THOUSAND
PREGNANT WOMEN.
WE TRULY APPRECIATE THE DOWN
PAYMENT ON UNIVERSAL COVERAGE.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK TOWARD
AFFORDABLE COVERAGE FOR ALL
INCLUDING CHILDREN AND PARENTS
AFFECTED BY THE FAMILY
AFFORDABILITY GLITCH. AND ALL
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS MAKE
MANY FROM OUR PARENTS AND
CAREGIVERS BUT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. THINK THANK
YOU.
WHEN A STATUS MEAN ANDRES
CRITICS SAY YES THEY SO IN A WAY
THAT COMMONLY THOUGHT EPONA
LOGAN IS SUCH AND THE SACRAMENTO
ACT REPRESENT THEM AS A SECRET
THAT IS GOING US TENNIS. IF I
MENTAL YESTERDAY AGAIN UP OR GET
ENOUGH OF IT BUT AT THE LOS.
OUR ATHLETIC ONE UP AT SOME OF
THAT EQUIPMENT THINK THAT.
COMUNA MOTHER.
DOESN'T THAT WITH US GET THAT
BOOK WILL BE ABOUT.
GONE ACCESSIBLE MEDICAL S. I SEE
THE LID ON THINGS ABOUT ASSOC.
BUT I THINK WE'LL BLOOD AT THE
STATEMENT THAT THAT MEAN US BUT
THIS ISN'T IDEA.
THIS PARTICULAR AT THE CORD
BLOOD DEMEANOR MAYBE STONE. OVER
THE ULTIMATE THE GOVERNMENT BUT
DEMAND FOR MOTHER DIFFIDENT THIS
ACROSS UNITS.
HELLO MY NAME'S LEGACY ES AND
I'M A COMMUNITY LEADER WHICH
SACRAMENTO ACT WHICH REPRESENTS
FIFTY SIX MORE THAN FIFTY SIX
CONGREGATIONS IN SACRAMENTO.
I'M A MOTHER WHO IS DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THIS ISSUE.
I'VE ONLY HAD ACCESS TO FULL
MEDICAL COVERAGE.
DURING MY PREGNANCIES.
AFTER SIXTY DAYS THAT COVERAGE
COMES TO AN END.
AND I'VE BEEN IN OCCASIONS
FORCED TO.
.
I TO MEDICATE MYSELF
ITSELF A VALUE MYSELF FOR NOT
HAVING.
MEDICAL COVERAGE.
I MEANT THAT NOTHING RUNNING
WILL NOT THEY WANT PEOPLE THE
COVERT BUT I MAY BECOME.
SIMPLE ADBLOCK ON ME SEE BECAUSE
I THOUGHT GOD THAT'S BECAUSE OF
GET PASSED ON IN THE FOCUS
SENATE OUTLANDER THAT OKAY
SIGNIFICA. IF THE PROJECT BUT
ALSO THROUGH THE SUBTLE BUT AT
THE LOS.
LIGAMENT ADVOCATES SEATTLE
SEMANAL SANFORD AMONG.
WELL YOU MUST LOOK DIRTY BUT
THEY DON'T SEE THEIR.
BUT ON THE GRASSO NOISE I THINK.
YOUR BROTHER'S GOON SHOW BUT THE
CALIFORNIA MIGHT IT THE LESS BUT
THAT'S IMMEASURABLE THING AS IN
WHICH HAS MONEY TO.
THEN WHEN I THINK ABOUT A CALL
TO SEE.
LOOK WHAT I MIGHT MAIL THAT A
CALIFORNIA.
BUT I.
I WANT THEM TO SEND YOU A YOUR
AND AGAIN PROBLEM WITH LITTLE
BUT I COULD AT LEAST GIVE US BUT
THEY CAN.
LATEST YAMI HOPE THEY ARE THIS
IS IT THE MOST AND THEN THERE
ARE THE TO THE DEPLOYMENT OF THE
HOPE THAT PUTS ON A.
BUT ALSO MENTAL THAT I WAS BORN
IN THE US IN A LETTER THEY USE.
YOKOHAMA THE MYTHICAL WHEN YOU
SEE BECAUSE.
ESTE. IF THE PROJECT IN THE LATE
SIGNIFICANT EMERALD JEWEL BUT I
MEAN A PERSON NOT BUT I MEAN BUT
I'M JUST BUT WHEN I THINK OF
MICHAEL MONEY THAT.
LOCAL BUT DON'T LOOK AT THEM AND
THE TENNESSEE DENTAL ALONE THE.
YES I WILL BENEFITTED THOMAS.
THE OTHER SUPPORT UP WITH
ANYTHING THAT OF MENTAL HEALTH
EXPERTS ON.
MATHIS.
I'M.
I ASK FOR COMPASSION.
WE NEED TO PLACE OURSELVES IN
THE POSITION OF OTHERS AND OTHER
ISSUES.
TO FEEL COMPASSION.
I SPEAK TO MY SON ABOUT THE
ISSUES THAT I THAT I ENGAGED I
GO THROUGH. AND ALTHOUGH WE ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF CALIFORNIA
ACT BECAUSE I CAN CALL
CALIFORNIA MY HOME. CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF ME
THEY'VE GIVEN ME THE LICENSE
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THE ISSUES.
BUT I'D I ALWAYS TELL MY SON
THAT.
THIS ASK THAT THIS PAST THAT WE
MAKE FOR OURSELVES IS NOT JUST
FOR OURSELVES.
BUT IT'S FOR ITS FOR THE COMMON
GOOD OF OTHERS AS WELL.
IN.
CURRENTLY I DON'T HAVE.
OUR MEDICAL COVERAGE.
AND.
I. AM HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT IN
SUPPORT OF HEALTH FOR ALL.
SO THAT YOU KNOW NOT JUST MIGHT
MYSELF. CAN HAVE COVERAGE BUT
ALSO OTHERS AND I JUST LIKE TO.
THANK EVERYBODY WHO'S HERE IN
SUPPORT OF HEALTH FOR ALL.
AND ALSO TO ASK FOR COMPASSION.
COMPASSION TO OLDER ADULTS
THINKING.
THANK YOU GOOD OFFICE.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KATE EARLY
AND I WORK WITH QUALITY
CALIFORNIA.
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF HEALTH FOR ALL.
BUT I'M HERE TO REMIND YOU THAT
OUR WORK IS FAR FROM OVER.
ADULTS WHO ARE UNINSURED FEES OF
WIDE VARIETY OF HEALTH PROBLEMS
INCLUDING MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
IS PARTICULARLY TROUBLING
TROUBLING FOR THOSE IN THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY. WHERE PEOPLE ARE SO
OF ALL AGES PARTICULARLY OLDER
ARE SUBJECT TO INCREASED AMOUNTS
OF SEXUAL AND GENDER BASED
VIOLENCE?
THAT VIOLENCE HAS WORSENED AND
FURTHER PERPETUATED WITHOUT
ACCESS TO COMPREHENSIVE IN
SUPPORT OF MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
IT IS UNJUST UNFAIR AND
UNACCEPTABLE THAT I WAS ABLE TO
RECEIVE COMPREHENSIVE TREATMENT
AND EVALUATION AFTER MY OWN RATE
BUT MEMBERS OF MY COMMUNITY WHO
ARE UNDOCUMENTED DO NOT HAVE
THAT SAME PRIVILEGE.
THERE'S NO TIME LIKE THE PRESENT
TO DO BETTER AND YOU MORE WHICH
IS WHY IT'S TIME FOR HEALTH FOR
ALL.
THANK YOU.
HI AM. I MY NAME IS NORMAN THING
YOU KNOW THE ES THAT
COMMUNICATIVE PERCENT THE RENO
AND. I THINK MANY WORKER I HAVE
BEEN.
IS RECEIVING A LOT OF ARE
COMING YEAR AS DIDN'T DROP THE
CENTRAL VALLEY ABOUT THE ISSUE
AND THE HAVING ACCESS TO
PREVENTIVE CARE.
ONE OF THE MANY STORIES THAT WE
RECEIVE ICU.
STAY RIGHT NOW IS ABOUT MY
PARENTS DON DOKKEN.
PARENTS HAVE BEEN HERE FOR MORE
THAN THIRTY YEARS.
I HAVE NO.
I SYSTEM AND A COW.
QUIRK TOLERANCE DATE IN YOUR
WORK.
WAKEUP FOUR IN THE MORNING.
AN UPRIGHT.
THAT P. M..
THEY ALWAYS
FROM.
CHIU ON NOT HAVING HOPE APSES.
OF BEING HEARD AND CLEAN THE
WORK FIELD THAT'LL HAVE ACCESS.
INSURANCE.
IN THE WORK.
AND TO SEE THAT IT'S A THICK
MATURE QUICKER.
IT'S REALLY.
VERY SAD TO.
LETTER COMING YOU KNOW THAT
THERE'S NO PROGRAM TO COVER IT.
SOME HERE SUPPORTER THAT I'M
HERE BURKE.
THANK YOU ALL FOR THIS PROPOSAL
AND. ENTERTAINERS PARTNER
COMMUNITIES THAT
BRING FOOD AND THE TABLE BOTH
EVERYDAY SO. I DID IS I AM ONE
THE LET YOU GUYS KNOW GIVE THE
MESSAGE THAT ONCE YOU'RE SITTING
IN TABLE. EATING THING ABOUT
BOTH AT WORK IT OUT.
THINKING ABOUT THOSE TO ACTUALLY
WORK IN IN THAT SON OF MY
PARENTS ARE BEING THAT PACKED IT
BY THIS NOT HAVING ACCESS TO
MIDTOWN.
IT'S A BIG DEAL FOR US
THE BILL WOULD TO PAY OUT OF
POCKET FOR THEM TO GET THIS
ACCENTS IN GOOD TO KNOW WORKING.
EVERY DAY FOR US
WITH PRESSURE FOR COUPLE FELT
ARM.
OUR OUR COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY OUR PRIDE IN
FOOD ARE WORKING HARD FOR US.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE MUST
GIVE BACK GIVE THEM ACT
PREVENTIVE CARE ACCESS TO HOW.
SOME HERE SUPPORT FOR HOW FAR I
THINK. THANK YOU.
I. IT'S HOT UP.
HI MY NAME IS A STELLAR
HERNANDEZ I ALSO WORK WITH AND
WE MUST NOT BUT ASSEMBLY OF THE
KENAI LACKEY IF.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT SUPPORT
HEALTH FOR ALL AND I'M NOT JUST
GIVE POLITICAL MY PARENTS BUT
ALL FOR. ALL UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE
WORKING HARD IN THE FILL WORK.
I HAVE AND ALSO WORK WITH THE
COMMUNITY.
AT I MEAN I SEE CLIENTS COME
EVERYDAY I JUST. TO ASK IF
THERE'S SOMETHING FOR THEM TO
HAVE THEIR BACK HURTS THEIR
LIKE.
THE LITTLE GIRL TO THE HOSPITAL
UNLESS THEY'RE REALLY REALLY
LIKE.
I DON'T KNOW LIKE
ANYONE TO SAY THAT WHAT.
UP.
IT IS REALLY HARD JUST TO TELL
THEM LIKE I'M SORRY.
WE DON'T HAVE THE ACCESS FOR
YOU.
AND ESPECIALLY ON.
SOME OF MY CLIENTS MEASURE THAT
TO OUR PARENTS EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
HELPING THE COMMUTER BUT LIKE
WHEN I BEEN HELPING OUR OWN
FAMILY.
SO I'M JUST HERE TO SAY THEM
HERE TO THE SUPPORT FOR HEALTH
FOR ALL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WHEN I WAS AT THE LOS.
WE NUMBER THAT YOU HAVE A
ZILLION.
EVEN WITH ANOTHER FRESNO.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME
IS CLEARLY OF ASSEMBLY AND MY
COMING FROM FRESNO COUNTY.
AT THE GONNA GET OUT OF THIS
ENOUGH THAT IF THE PUMP ISN'T
PERFECT YET ASSEMBLY I THEM
THAT'S A LEVEL IT IS IF I'M AT
THE CUP ONE OF THOSE ON I WOUND
UP ON THE BEEN AND I GUESS IT UP
AT THE CEILING OF THE CITY OF
OTHER. MYSTICAL MANY THAT.
ARM BEFORE ANYTHING I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE WHO IS PRESENT
HERE.
AT THESE.
HEARING AND WE WANT.
THANK YOU FOR THINKING OF THIS
REALLY POOR AND TOPIC FOR OUR
COMMUNITY.
S. THAT HAVING LOW LEVEL SO THAT
MEANT THAT FOR ME SINOP THOUGH
THAT MICHAEL MONEY THAT MAKE
THEM AND THE THAT BY SOME THAT
EVEN THAT WILL CUT. IN THIS THE
BECAUSE OF THE MOST NOTABLE
ELECTRICITY OTHERS GET DIDN'T
MEET COLONIA.
TODAY WE'RE NOT ONLY TALKING
ABOUT ME BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
EVERYONE EVERYONE FROM THE
COMMUNITY THEY CALL THEY TELL ME
THAT I'M A LOCAL LEADER BY
MUSCLE.
ES.
NATIONAL NATIONAL WILD LEADER.
S. WEEKLY FILAMENT THAT LET ME
THAT GET THE LITTLE YES OWNER
LOOKING TO GET THAT SEES THE
CORDOBA SET A SEQUEL OTHER
CRITICAL MONEY THAT WHEN THE
LOOK YOU KNOW NOT THE THRILL. IS
WITH ANYTHING HE LET ME WBLI
THEY PRETTY SILK IN A COMPANY
THAT. BALLPARK THAT THEY WON'T
BUT FAILED BUT OF THIS IT TOOK
US EVENT THIS WEEK WITHOUT ANIL
IS EITHER BUT AS SOON AS I GET
ON THE LAST THAT I LOOK WHAT
ELSE BY THE NEXT. ONE WILL SEE
IT THE GOVERNMENT THAT THE BOARD
BATTLES IF I SWIM AND PICK ME UP
DISAPPOINTED SEC RALLY.
IT'S REALLY SAD THAT NOT BEING
ARE A PROFESSIONAL PSYCHOLOGIST
WE CAN SEE THAT OUR COMMUNITY
ALL SUFFERING A GREAT DEPRESSION
FOR NOT BOURBON AND
UNDOCUMENTED.
AND AND WE KNOW THAT MANY OF OUR
PARENTS ARE ANYWAY ROOM LOSING
THEIR MIND BECAUSE THEY ARE IN
FEAR OF BEING DEPORTED.
MICHAEL WANTED US SOMEBODY IN
THE FOOT CONCEPT CONCEPT IS THAT
A LOS ITIS I DISCUSSED UNCLE
COMING UP WITH PUT BONTA SCHEME
BECAUSE IT LETS HIM BOTH THE US
ECAMPUS ARTICLE OF THE MISTER
WHY IS IT THAT.
OUR COMMUNITY ARE SUFFERING OF
CANCER.
DUE TO SO MANY CHEMICALS THAT
ARE IN THE AIR THAT ARE IN THE
AGRICULTURE AREA OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
GO MY SPECIFIC AN OPEL THAT
ALMOST THEN IN LIQUID PLUMMETED
GOT CUANDO SICK CONCEPTS SAT ON
LEVEL ABOARD SO. THAT THE
HUNDREDS OF COUPLES CUMPLE THE
CALL ME THAT THAT THERE ARE NONE
OF THEM IS THE IDEAL BOTH
CAMPESINOS ARTICLE LAST. BUT IT
IS IF I MAY LOOK AT THE
IMMACULATE HEART ALSO SEQUELS.
WE ARE WITHOUT THEM THEY WOKE UP
ITS OWN UP ON A BILL THAT THE
AUTHOR HAD WON THE BIGGEST ON W.
AND CONFIRMING OTHERS
COMPLETAMENTE.
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE THAT HOME
DISK?
ILLNESS THIS SICKNESS OF CANCER
WE ARE OPEN IN MAY DUE TO THE
HARD WORK THAT WE DO IN THE FARM
FORM AGRICULTURE AREA. AND WE
ARE ALSO.
THE ONE PROVIDING
FOOD ON THE TABLE FOR OUR FAMILY
AND WE WE HAVE TO ALSO LEGAL
CHILDREN.
UNDER CHILDCARE AND BEING AWAY
FROM HOME FOR SO LONG.
OIL IS GET UP AND YOU KNOW THE
KEY LEVEL IS CAPABLE SETTLEMENT
THAN NORMAL MENTAL WILL SAY WILL
DEPEND ON ITS UP BOTTLE THIS
THING THE COMMENT THAT ALL THIS
BILL SINGLE COMMIT THE LOOK THAT
UP AS A ME. EPS AND NOT SOME
ASSEMBLY MALICE SO MOST THAT IS
SO MONOTONOUS AT THE CHEMICAL
BUT BUT I MAYBE GOT BUT I'M
ALMOST ASLEEP WHAT THE* IS
SOMETHING THE CORPSMAN BATTLES.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU TO PLEASE ARM
PUT YOURSELF IN MY SHOES PLEASE
PUT UP PUT YOURSELF IN THE SHOES
OF. ALL THE COMMITTEES THOSE
BEHIND ME ALTHOUGH UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITIES AND TO UNDERSTAND
THAT WE ARE NOT AND WHEELS THAT
WE AREHUMAN BEINGS AND THAT WE
ARE CONTRIBUTING TO THIS
ECONOMY.
YEAH THAT'S WHAT'S ABOUT WE GOT
ALLOW YET SOMEPLACE THAT'S
WORKING I'M ONE UP WITHOUT UPPER
YET MOST YET THOUGH THE LOOK IT
UP WE ON THE PUBLIC THE SPIEGEL.
APPLE YEAH LOOKS BURKE ELEVEN AS
HE DOES IT ON THE IN A MOMENT
THE BY THE SETTLEMENT THAT MAKE
UP AGAIN YEAH ONE THE ONLY THE
COMMENT THAT OF AMERICANS YES
YES I'M GLAD NO ONE ON THE CAN
LOOK IN OF A MEDIA BUT I'M OF
YOU.
I WANT TO THANK SENATOR LARA AND
ASSEMBLY IS ARAMBULA FOR.
SUPPORTING US AND THIS TOPIC AND
PLEASE CONTINUE SUPPORTING US
BECAUSE ARM A REVIEW SMALL
ILLNESS IN THE HOSPITAL ARM
COULD BECOME REALLY BIG AND A
BIG PROBLEM AND FOR HEALTH.
NO I MEANT THAT WHAT YOU SEE
MOTHERS UP A LITTLE BIT MODEL
THAT THIS YOUNG I LOOK AT THEM
ASSOCIATE MINISTER PICK IF YOUNG
TECH IS BOGUS.
MEDI CAL BOTTLES
LAFAYETTE.
ONE MORE TIME THANK YOU EVERYONE
COOLEY SPAIN ATTENTION TO THIS
PETITION AND AND THANK YOU FOR
UNDERSTANDING THAT MEDICAL
HEALTH COVERAGE IS FOR EVERYONE
THANK YOU.
LEE WITHOUT SOUTHEAST ASIA
RESOURCE ACTION CENTER AND WE
APPLAUD ASSEMBLIES FARM
COMMITMENT TO INVESTING IN
HEALTH FOR ALL. OF HEALTH FOR
ALL THIS YEAR HOWEVER THERE
STILL A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE
ESPECIALLY WITH OUR OLDER ADULTS
AS WELL. SEA ROCK WE REPRESENT
THE LARGEST OF SOUTHEAST THE
LARGEST REFUGEES WE SETTLE HERE
IN AMERICA WITH.
REFUGEES FROM THE SOUTHEAST
ASIA.
POLITICAL WARS AND.
BECAUSE OF THAT A LOT AND THE
UNITED STATES AND IN THE
RESETTLEMENT PROGRAM IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR. LEAVING OUT ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND REFUGEES IN
SOUTHEAST ASIA TO SEEK TO FACE
PERSECUTION AND A LOT OF THEM.
TOOK IT UPON THEMSELVES TO COME
TO THE UNITED STATES AS
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS SO THAT
THEY CAN'T SEE
WEEKLY SETTLEMENT HERE. AND
ESCAPE THE PERSECUTION AND MANY
OF THEM COME WITH A LOT OF
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AND A LOT OF
WITH PTSD AND DISPLACEMENT AS
WELL. AND A LOT OF THEM ARE
UNABLE TO SEE PREVENTIVE CARE
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IF WE
DO NOT STAND UP FOR SCHOOL MEDI
CAL TO THOSE ADULTS AS WELL AND.
SIXTY TWO PERCENT OF CAMBODIAN
OLDER ADULTS EXPERIENCE PTSD
COMPARED TO THIRTY PERCENT OF
THE GENERAL PUBLIC SO I HIGHLY
RECOMMEND FOR THAT ASSEMBLY TO
ALSO CONSIDER. EXTENDING BOTH OF
HEALTH FOR ALL FOR OLDER ADULTS
ESPECIALLY SENDS. OUR OUR.
.
REFUGEES AND NOW UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS ARE UNABLE TO SEEK
THESE PREVENTIVE CARES AND
THAT'S HEALTH SERVICES THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GLEN ATROCIOUS I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
POSITIONS ALLIANCE.
WE ARE AN ORGANIZATION OF
PHYSICIANS HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS AND PRIVATE
CITIZENS. WHO WORK FOR AN
ADVOCATE UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE?
WE SUPPORT ALL OF YOUR PROPOSALS
WE THINK THEY'RE A VERY GOOD
START WE WILL WORK WITH YOU TO
SEE THAT THEY ARE IMPLEMENTED.
AND WHEN THEY ARE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING FURTHER SO
UNTIL WE ARE TO THE POINT WHERE
EVERYBODY WHO LIVES IN
CALIFORNIA HAS ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
PUBLIC UP IT'S HOW WITH
COMMITTEE HEALTH COUNCILS FROM
LOS ANGELES UP FIRST AND
FOREMOST THANK YOU FOR PUTTING
TOGETHER PROPOSAL THAT HELPS US.
GET UNIVERSAL COVERAGE IN
UPHOLDING THE PROGRESSIVE VALUES
OF CALIFORNIA PROTECTING THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF OUR
RESIDENTS.
AS YOU HEAR THE BRICK
HEARTBREAKING STORIES TODAY I
URGE YOU TO CONSIDER EXPANDING
HEALTH FOR ALL TO ALL ADULTS
MUCH AS THOSE NINETEEN TO TWENTY
FIVE.
BECAUSE HEALTH IS A HUMAN RIGHT
WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR CITIZENS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO THIS IS THAT I'M CHRISTIAN
GOLDEN TESTED WITH THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP AND I'M
PLEASED TO OFFER A REALLY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR EVERYONE OF THE
PROVISIONS IN THIS.
BUDGET INVESTMENT PACKAGE FOR
ON COVERAGE AND I TWO ITEMS IN
PARTICULAR THAT I WANTED TO
RAISE. YOUR ATTENTION AS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT IS THE WICK
EXPRESS LANE AS IT'S A AN
IMPORTANT WAY TO FIND THOSE THAT
ARE ELIGIBLE CHILDREN THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR COVERAGE IN AND
ROLL THEM IN A SMART WAY. AND
ALSO FOR HEALTH FOR ALL AND
THAT'S AND WE'VE AS YOU KNOW ARE
VERY PROUD OF.
HEALTH FOR ALL KIDS AND THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT NEXT STEP TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY DON'T GET CUT OFF
COVERAGE AS A BECOME YOUNG
ADULTS. AND OF COURSE ON THE
WORK IS NOT DONE AND WE SUPPORT
MOVING ON FOR ALL SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DOCTOR IN MILLION
DOCUMENTS.
AND YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS THE
MOTHER PLACENTA WITH THE LATINO
COALITION FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
AND I'M UNDOCUMENTED AND
UNINSURED. OUR FIRST I WANTED TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION FOR THE
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORD
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAM WOULD
OFFER PARA TAKE THE HEALTH FOR
ALL AND TO WORKING TOWARDS
REMOVING THE UNJUST BARRIER OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. TO THE.
OF SEEK HEALTH CARE ARE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES ARE
EXPERIENCING INCREASED HARDSHIP
AND FEAR THAT OUR IMMIGRATION A
DEPORTATION HAS INCREASED BY
THIRTY SEVEN PERCENT UNDER THE
NEW ADMINISTRATION. AND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ARE BEING INCREASE
FOR.
BACK AT THE BORDER AS WELL AS
ICE AGENTS ALL OF THIS IS. AS
YOU'VE HEARD INCREASING OTHER
RISK OF MENTAL HEALTH FOR ARE
DOCUMENTED COMMUNITIES AND AT
THE SAME TIME AGAIN ARE JUSTLY
LOCKED OUT OF HEALTH CARE
BECAUSE OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. ANSETT SO THANK YOU FOR
MOVING MOVING THAT'S STEP
FORWARD A WE WERE JUST HERE
YOU'RE GO FOR.
HEALTH FOR ALL YOUNG ADULTS TO
BE ABLE TO INCLUDED LAST YEAR
SINCE THEN WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND HAVE HAD VERY
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS.
REALIZING THE REALITY OF THE
SITUATION THAT NOT EVERYONE IS
GOING TO BE COVERED ON AT THE
SAME TIME I'M WE ASK THEM WHO
WOULD YOU LIKE US TO PRIORITIZE
WHEN WE COME AND SPEAK WITH YOUR
REPRESENTATIVES. AND
OVERWHELMINGLY THEY EXPRESS
SENIORS AND ON ELDERS TO BE
PRIORITIZE FOR HEALTH FOR ALL
I'M A LOT OF COMMUNITIES HAVE
LIVED HERE FOR VARIOUS YEAR SOME
TWENTY THIRTY YEARS.
BEING ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE TO
CALIFORNIA IN VARIOUS WAYS
SUSTAINING IT WITHIN OUR
AGRICULTURE ARE LABOR WORK ON
VARIOUS.
OUR VARIOUS FORMS OF HARD LABOR
ON SO COMMUNITIES REALLY EXPRESS
THE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
PRIORITIZE ELDERS SO I HOPE THAT
YOU CONSIDER THAT AS WELL AS
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD. AND THIS
ADVOCACY THANK YOU AGAIN. THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHAEL DAVID
CHILDREN NOW JUST WANT TO
REGISTER MY SUPPORT ON A
PARTICULAR THE WITH EXPRESSING
ENROLLMENT.
COMPONENT AND THE EXPANSION OF
HEALTH FRAUD IN ADULTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS LUCY QUESTION
HELLO I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
MATERNAL AND CHILD HEALTH ACCESS
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE OF OF THOSE
UNFORTUNATE COULD NOT BE HERE
TODAY BUT I'M HONORED TO BE HERE
IN HER PLACE. MC ATTACKS IS
STRONGLY SUPPORTS IS THAT THE
MASTERS IN THE REFORM PACKAGE.
WE BEGAN.
AS AN ORGANIZATION DECADES AGO
WITH EXPANSION FOR COVERAGE FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WOMEN WHEN THEY
WERE PREGNANT AND WE'VE.
STAYED WITH THESE ISSUES OF
THROUGHOUT THAT TIME ARM IT'S
FRUSTRATING THAT IT HAS BEEN
SUCH AN INCREMENTAL PROCESS BUT
I AM VERY GLAD TO BE HERE TODAY.
AND SEE THAT PROGRESS HAPPEN AND
HOPE THERE WILL BE MUCH MORE IN
TERMS OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT AYE.
OPPORTUNITY LATER IN TODAY'S
AGENDA BUT WE REALLY NEED THE
GRASS ROOTS WORKFORCE OUT THERE
DOING OUTREACH AND HELPING
PEOPLE. ACTUALLY AXIS THEIR CARE
BECAUSE WITHOUT THE ACCESS TO
THE COVERAGE.
NARROW PROVIDER NETWORKS LONG
GEOGRAPHIC DISTANCES TO CARA THE
GRASS ROOTS WORKERS ARE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOU'RE DOING AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MELODY
HOW WEINTRAUB I'M WITH THE MULTI
FAITH ACTION COALITION AND WERE
A GROUP OF CITIZENS WHO HAVE
GOTTEN TOGETHER BECAUSE OF OUR
FAITH TEACHINGS AND HOW WE ARE.
COMPELLED TO REACH OUT AND HELP
OTHERS I THANK YOU FOR THIS.
.
SAID OF BILLS AND THIS BUDGET
PRIORITY THIS IS WHAT WE ALL ARE
STRIVING FOR IS TO HELP EACH
OTHER AND THOSE OF US HAD A
BILLS WILL DO THAT WE HAVE BOTH
SUPPORTED HEALTH FOR ALL IN OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY OF CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. BUT WE HAVE A VERY SMALL
AMOUNT THE NOT A COHORT OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE GETTING CARE WHO
WOULDN'T GET THAT OTHERWISE BUT
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH FUNDS TO DO
THE WHOLE.
AMOUNT AND I THINK THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD STEP
UP AND AND PROVIDE THOSE IN THIS
COMING BUDGET WE HAVE HOPE OVER
FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS AND IN
CONTRA COSTA WHO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ACTUALLY NEVER GONE MY NAME IS
MONEY EVER MET A MORE THAT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COVERAGE IN
HEALTH INITIATIVES.
OUR FIRST OF ALL I'M WE WANT TO
THANK ON DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND
DOCTOR WOULD FOR.
MOVING THIS FOR IN THE.
SUPPORT THAT YES OF ALL
CHALLENGE FOR THE.
HEALTH COVERAGE FOR ALL IN.
AS A FORMER.
CC HIV CALIFORNIA COVERAGE AND
HEALTH INITIATIVES REPRESENTS
OVER. THIRTY ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE THAT REPRESENT
MORE THAN FORTY OVER COUNTY
SONORA CAL AND IN OUR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE WORKING WITH
FAMILIES DAY IN AND DAY OUT. IN
THE CHURCHES SCHOOLS AND SOCIAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENTS.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WAKE OFFICES AND ALL OF THE
ABOVE WORKING WITH FAMILIES TO
ENROLL THEM INTO COVERAGE
EDUCATE THEM ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
GETTING INTO. BECAUSE IT'S A
VERY COMPLICATED SYSTEM THAT WE
HAVE IN HELPING THEM NAVIGATE
THE HEALTH INSURANCE WORLD ARE
HELPING THEM SECURE A MEDICAL
HOME HELPING THEM UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN GOING.
FROM A EMERGENCY ROOM WHEN IT
HAS BECOME A SPEND THE FIRST
OPTION FOR MANY PEOPLE THAT I
HAVE NOT HAD A HISTORICALLY
HEALTH INSURANCE TO ACTUALLY
SECURING UP A MEDICAL HOME.
THROUGH THEIR PROVIDER THAT THEY
MIGHT HAVE NOW.
THE FAMILIES THAT WE WORK WITH
ARE MONOLINGUAL SPANISH SPEAKING
AMONG SPEAKING OUT YOU MENTIONED
AND THOSE ARE THE FAMILIES THAT
WE THAT WERE WORKING AND THE
PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT ANA DAY
IN DAY OUT. IN.
WE WERE SORRY TO SEE THAT THE
BUDGET THAT'S FOR THE OPERATION
WOMAN IS NOT PART OF THE PACKAGE
BUT BASS IT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER WE WILL WANT TO.
JUST.
TELL YOU WHY IS IT SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE OUTSIDE OF COVERAGE.
THERE'S A WHOLE PACKAGE OF
HELPING THE FAMILY NAVIGATE THE
HEALTH INSURANCE SO THAT THEY'RE
NOT YOU SEEN UMBELS TRADITIONAL
SERVICES IN THE EMERGENCY ROOM.
S..
WE YOU KNOW SECURING THAT
MEDICAL HOMELESS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING SO AGAIN THANK
YOU THANK YOU ALL AND.
THERE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DEBORAH WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA THANK
YOU DOCTOR WOULD. OUT WE ARE
VERY PLEASED THAT THE COMMITTEE
WILL BE CONSIDERING THIS
COMPREHENSIVE SET OF REFORMS.
THAT REALLY TAKES A BIG STEP IN
THE DIRECTION OF CLOSING ALL OF
THE PROBLEMS AND GAPS WE HAVE.
AND DOING IT IN IN A SMART
FASHION OUGHT YES THERE ARE MANY
MORE THINGS TO DO. BUT THIS IS.
MORE THAN A GOOD START AND WOULD
ESPECIALLY LIKE TO DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE TOP OF PAGE TO.
OUR DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
ALONG WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY AND JUSTICE IN
AGING.
WERE.
PROUD TO BE THE SPONSORS OF THE
REQUEST TO CLOSE THE ARE GAP ERA
IN OUR ELIGIBILITY FOR THE AGED
AND DISABLED POPULATION AND MEDI
CAL.
THAT WAS EIGHTY A REQUIREMENT
THAT.
WAS ON INFORMED. ARM ILLOGICAL
AND UNFAIR AND WE HOPE THIS GOES
THROUGH BECAUSE IT IS SO
IMPORTANT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
JOSHUA VOCAL WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING PACKAGE
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH YOU. ON WORKFORCE
CAPACITY ISSUES PARTICULARLY AS
THEY RELATE. TO MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS AND PUBLIC SERVICE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KIMBERLY CHANNEL THE CALIFORNIA
PANASONIC HEALTH NETWORK HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING PACKAGE
BEFORE YOU THE COMMITTED HERE
TODAY I WANT EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR HEALTH FOR ALL YOUNG
ADULTS AS WELL AS. THE EXPANSION
FOR THE MEDI CAL AGING DISABLED
PROGRAM AND.
WEEKS WRESTLING WE ALSO WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT SUPPORT FOR
PREMIUM ASSISTANCE FOR LOW
INCOME. FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS
ON COVERED CALIFORNIA AND ALSO
AS OTHERS HAVE NOTED BEFORE WE
ENCOURAGE THIS COMMITTEE TO
CONTINUE THE STEPS TO ENSURE
THAT ALL UNDOCUMENTED VIGILS ARE
COVERED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JERRY HEX REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR
THE PACKAGE OF PROPOSALS AND
SPECIFICALLY TALK ABOUT.
THE WORKFORCE INVESTMENT AND
THE CONTINUED INVESTMENT THAT
THAT THIS PROPOSAL.
ADDRESSES AND THE ADDITIONAL
SEVENTEEN MILLION TO SONG BROWN
SPECIFICALLY WE KNOW HOW WELL
THAT WORKS AND WE KNOW AS WE'RE
EXPANDING ACCESS THAT EXPANDING
OUR WORKFORCE IS IMPORTANT AS
WELL. AND THEN ON BEHALF OF BOTH
THE FAMILY PHYSICIANS AND
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES
CALIFORNIA.
ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE EXPANDED ELIGIBILITY FOR
UNDOCUMENTED CITIZENS IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BRENT SPENCE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OBGYN
STRYCHNINE A SPORT PACKAGE AND
GENERALLY SPECIFICALLY THE A
STREAMLINED MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY
FOR.
UNINSURED CHILDREN AND PREGNANT
WOMEN TO WAIT PROGRAM SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON RECHELBACHER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU TO DOCTOR
WHEN DOCTOR ARAMBULA FOR PUTTING
TOGETHER SUCH A. COMPREHENSIVE
PACKAGE OF INVESTMENT PROPOSALS
OUT WE WANT TO EXPRESS OUR.
IN PARTICULAR ARE A SUPPORT FOR.
THE WORKFORCE EXPANSION AND
THIS IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
GIVEN THE.
EXPANDED AKA ACCESS TO COVERAGE.
SO THOSE TWO THINGS GO HAND IN
HAND WE THINK.
THAT THAT WORK FOREST'S EYES
SHORTAGES NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
AS PART OF THE CONVERSATION.
ADDITIONALLY REGARDING THE.
PAYER UP PAYMENTS DATABASE UMPS
YOU MAY HAVE LONG STANDING STOP
POLICY SUPPORTING A THE CREATION
OF A DATABASE AND THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS GETTING
ACCURATE CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC
DATA. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE REPRESENT
TEN THOUSAND SOCIAL WORKERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ONE I
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA
AND DOCTOR WOULD.
FOR THIS PROPOSAL WERE
SUPPORTIVE I'VE.
EVERYTHING HERE WE THINK IT'S A
GREAT FIRST STEP AND WE ARE
ESPECIALLY HAPPY TO SEE THE
EXPANSION FOR YOUNG ARE
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS AND ALSO THE
PROVISION FOR SENIORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
RAINY EXIT CALIFORNIA'S
DISABILITY RIGHTS WERE NONPROFIT
MEMBERSHIP IN DRIVEN MEMBERSHIP
DRIVEN ORGANIZATION.
WE WANT TO THANK AALIYAH REALLY
HARD WORK AND WE CONCUR WITH THE
COMMENTS BY DRC THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU.
INTRADAY INNOVATION ACTIVISM
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA OF LIKE TO
THANK THE LEADERSHIP OF SUMMERS
WOULDN'T. ARAMBULA.
PARTICULARLY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF HEALTH FRAWLEY IN ADULTS
PROPOSAL AND MINUTES ONE ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES TO TERMS OF CONCERNS
AROUND OUR PARENTS AND.
A L. ELDERS AND SENIOR SEWED
ALSO ADDICTED IT'S COMPETITION
SO THEY HAVE A MUCH.
THANK YOU MY ANGER I'M A SILLY
OF CALIFORNIA IN PROPITIATE XIN
AND SUPPORT OF THE INVESTMENT
AND HEALTH FOR ALL AND ECHOING
MY CLOGS COMMENTS ABOUT
ENSURING.
OLDER ADULTS AND GRANDPARENTS
CAN GET THIS CRITICAL CARE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
BECAUSE HER SON TO THE CHAIR OF
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS REPRESENTING
OUR. IMMIGRANT FAMILIES ACROSS
THE STATE DIRECTLY ODDS ON A
ECHO THE COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUES
AND SAY WE'RE STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE PROPOSAL MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU.
AND I HAD A LOT ON WHAT THE
WIDENING GROUP ARE PLAYING NEXT
GEN AMERICAN SUPPORT OF
EXPANDING HEALTH I'M ACCESS TO
LAB LOW INCOME AND DOCUMENT
ADULTS THINK YOU. THINK YOU.
SIR FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
PACKAGE MANY THANKS TED DOCTORS
WOULDN'T ARAMBULA FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS I'M SPECIALLY IN SUPPORT
OF GETTING US CLOSER TO HEALTH
CARE FOR ALL.
FOR MAKING HEALTHCARE MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR LOW INCOME AND
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES
TRANSPARENCY ACCESS. AND JUST TO
SAY THAT THIS MAKES OF THAT THE
TASK IN THE WORK OF CONTROLLING
THE COST OF HEALTHCARE AND
GETTING OUR ARMS AROUND THE COST
DRIVERS EVEN MORE URGENT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED OR.
THANK YOU.
IT AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ALLISON
CAMINO I'M NOT WITH AN
ORGANIZATION BUT I'M HERE THE
CONCERNED CONSTITUENT OF
DISTRICT SEVEN AND HERE TOP OF
THE VOICES OF. THE ELDERLY OLDER
POPULATION WITHIN MY COMMUNITY
WHO CONTRIBUTE SO MUCH BUT ARE
UNABLE TO.
WOULD BE HERE PRESENT TO SHARE
IN THEIR STORY AND ALSO JUST
BECAUSE OF THEIR CONDITION I
ALSO WANT TO UPLIFT THEIR VOICES
AND HOW THEY ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED IN DENIED.
THE COVERAGE AT THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY LEVEL.
AND THINK YOU'D IF TODAY'S
THINK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO TAKE ACTION
I URGE YOU WITH THE HEALTH FOR
ALL COALITION TO MAKE THIS
PROPOSAL PRIORITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ON A HOUSE ABOUT WITH UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
THE UP PROPOSAL HERE TODAY I IN
PARTICULAR WANT TO CALL OUT THE
AWAKE EXPRESS LANE ELIGIBILITY
AS WELL AS EXPANDING COVERAGE
TO.
A YOUNG ADULTS UP TO AGE TWENTY
SIX THOSE ARE REALLY WONDERFUL
STARTS UP FOR I WILL BE NO IT'S
A AN ONGOING PROCESS AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DAVID
HUMANISM FROM PRESIDENT WITH
FRIENDS ABOUT DISNEY LOS. I JUST
WANTED TO SAY YOU KNOW I KEEP UP
THE GOOD WORK AND HOPEFULLY YOU
GUYS ARE STILL PUSHING ON AND
YOU KNOW THAT'S ALL I REALLY
WANTED CITY THING. THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS COMMON CORE OF
AN ORGANIZATION THAT CAN THAT
WOULD HELP ALL AND BASICALLY WE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
INCLUDE AFRICAN IMMIGRANT.
ALL IMMIGRANTS ARE SUFFERING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY
NAME'S CARTILAGES JINGLE.
CONFERENCE FRESNO CA BECAUSE
NOBODY FEELS I COME ONCE AGAIN
CUBA SUPPORT. UNDOCUMENTED
FAMILIES ALONG WITH THE WORKING.
LOWER MIDDLE CLASS TO OF WORKING
POOR. THAT FIND IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO BE ABLE TO. OBTAIN
THE HEALTH CARE THAT'S ADEQUATE
ENOUGH TO TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
AND WHICH ONE HAD TO DECIDE
WHETHER YOU GONNA TAKE CARE OF A
FEEDING A FAMILY HOUSING THEM.
OR GETTING THE MEDICATIONS OR
MEDICAL TREATMENT YOU NEED.
HUDDLED UP FROM THE DUTCH
STRUGGLES FIRSTHAND.
MYSELF WITHIN MY OWN FAMILY MY
WIFE WOULDN'T BORN RAISED
CATHOLIC HERE ALL ARE LIES AND
STRUGGLE TO GET HER MEDICAL
TECHNICIAN NEEDS YOU KNOW SHE
HAS HEALTH COVERAGE. BUT YOU
CAN'T AFFORD THE DEDUCTIBLES ARE
THE PREMIUMS.
SALAAM NOT ONLY IS IT JUST FOR
FOLKS THAT ARE UNDOCUMENTED BUT
ALSO OUR OWN YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S NOT. FOLKS HERE WE
ALL NEED THIS AN EXTRA WE ALL
THE DESERVE THIS RIGHT AND WHAT
IS THERE TO BE ABLE TO GO TO THE
DOCTORS WHEN WE NEED TO.
THANK YOU GUYS THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NO I BOTTOM ALL
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. WE
SIR FARMWORKER LOW INCOME RURAL
COMMUNITIES HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE COMPREHENSIVE PROPOSALS.
PACIFIC LEAGUE SPENDING THE
MEDICAL COVERAGE TO THE
UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH NINETEEN TO
TWENTY SIX IT ONE STEP FORWARD
FOR HEALTH FOR ALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE.
ONE OF THE START OF UP
CHRISTOPHER GOING ON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA GOOD POLICY CENTER.
WE ARE THANKFUL TO YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD ASSUME A MEMBER
ARAMBULA ARE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON AYE MOVING THIS HISTORIC AT
PACKAGE TO IMPROVE HEALTH
COVERAGE AND AFFORDABILITY. ARE
AS CO SPONSORS OF THE HEALTH FOR
ALL ACT WE ARE ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE HEALTH OF
THE HEALTH FOR ALL YOUNG ADULTS
ARE INVESTMENT. ARMENIAN
DOCUMENT COMMUNITIES ARE UNDER
INCREDIBLE DURESS A NO DOUBT
THAT THIS INVESTMENT AS WE
CONTINUE TO WITNESS THE
ATTACKS OF ALL OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES WE MUST CONTINUE TO
PEOPLE THAN CHAMPION INCLUSIVE
POLICIES.
WHICH INCLUDES MAKING SURE ARE
UNDOCUMENTED OLDER ELDERLY
ADULTS.
HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH COVERAGE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON FELIX THE WITH
LUCIA CALIFORNIA HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE MEDIC CAL
ASIAN IS ABLE PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR.
HI A CURLING A CAMARO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER I'M I WANTED TO EXPRESS
MY THANK YOU FOR.
YOU KNOW THIS HISTORIC STEP
FORWARD TO INVEST AND HEALTH FOR
ALL. EVERYDAY COMMUNITIES SO
TOWARD DECISION MAKERS TO TAKE
BOLD AND INCLUSIVE ACTION THAT
WILL TAKE US CLOSER TO
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. THIS BUDGET
PACKAGE SHOWS THAT CALIFORNIA
HOW COULD IT TAKES TO TAKE US IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO TREAT ALL
ALL COMMUNITIES WITH DIGNITY AND
ENSURE THAT NO ONE SUFFERS OR
DIES FROM A TREATABLE CONDITION.
NO MATTER WHERE THEY WERE BORN
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I AM TRYING TO FIND WITH JUSTICE
AN AGING NONPROFIT FIGHTING
SENIOR POVERTY THROUGH LAW. WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S.
BUDGET PACKAGE TODAY EXPANDING
ACCESS TO SO MANY CALIFORNIANS
ARE AND WHERE WE'RE CO SPONSORS
OF AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA SPELL TO
EXPAND MEDICARE AGED AND
DISABLED ELIGIBILITY. AND WOULD
PARTICULARLY LIKE TO VOICE OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR EXPANDING
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE MEDICAL AGED
AND DISABLED PROGRAM. BY WHICH
WILL HELP INSURE LOW INCOME
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES CAN GET THE MEDICAL
CARE THEY NEED. THANK YOU.
THE UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY HAS
BEEN NEGLECTED FOR MANY YEARS
AND.
MY NAME IS EMMY HILLARY'S AND
I'M HERE WITH THE THICK LEGAL
CENTER.
AND I'M I'M HERE URGING YOU.
PLEASE SUPPORT PLEASE SUPPORT
HEALTH WELL ON BUT THE POINT
THAT I WAS GONNA MAKE WITH THE
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY IS THEY
HAVE SUPPORTED CALIFORNIA IF
SUPPORTERS CALIFORNIA SINCE THE
DAY THAT THEY STEPPED. ON THIS
GROUND THEY'VE THEY'VE HELPED US
WORK THEY PAY TAXES
THEIR STUDENTS THEIR TEACHERS.
THEY'RE THE FUTURE
AND.
AND
FOR CALIFORNIA NOT TO SUPPORT
THEM BACK I THINK THAT'S ON JUST
I DON'T THINK THAT'S FAIR
OLYMPIC BETSY. IF THE DOCUMENT
COMMUNITY IS HOPING CALIFORNIA I
THINK I PERSONALLY BELIEVE
CALIFORNIA SHOULD ALSO HELP THE
DOCUMENT COMMITTEE ALSO WANT TO
THANK MISTER WOODS AND MISERABLE
THANK YOU FOR FOR PROPELLING US.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
DON'T THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
TALK.
NEGATIVELY ABOUT US AND.
YOU DON'T.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
SUPPORTING US.
THANK YOU MANAGED TO MAKE IT
WORSE I'M HERE WITH THE LIQUIDS
AND.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER OUR MEMBERS IN
SUPPORT.
K. ANY OF.
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
WELL OPEN MONDAY BECAUSE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTWITHSTANDING THE MERITS OF
THE PROPOSALS THAT MINISTRATION
DOES NOT SUPPORT THE PROPOSALS
GIVEN THAT THEY ARE THEY ARE
OUTSIDE OF THE ADMINISTRATION
SPENDING PLAN.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
HEARING NO OTHER COMMENTS.
BACK UP TO THE DIE IF.
MR MATHIS.
MEMBERS.
LOVE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
SUPPORT THIS.
TWO PAGES DOESN'T GIVE ME
ENOUGH.
TODAY TO GET BEHIND IT A I LOVE
THE DIRECTION WE'RE GOING HERE.
I I KNOW.
WE WE TALK.
ALL THE TIME ABOUT GETTING.
HEALTH CARE FOR FOR EVERYONE.
IN IN DOING THE RIGHT THINGS BUT
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE. ONE ON ON MY
SIDE WE GOT OUT MORE TO LOOK AT
THAN WHAT WE GOT IN FRONT OF US
TODAY.
ARM.
AND AND WITH THAT I'D ACTUALLY
MAKE A MOTION TO LEAVE THE ITEM
OPEN SO WE CAN LOOK MORE INTO
IT.
AS WE GO INTO THE REVISED.
I'M HAVE JUST COULD I QUICKLY I
JUST SAY THAT EVERYTHING THAT'S
OUTLINED HERE IS IS IN PRINT IN
EXISTING AND BILLS THAT ARE
GOING TO THE LEGISLATURE NOW SO
THAT THAT AND THAT BACK UP
INFORMATION LOOKING FOR MR
MATHIS IS IS IS AVAILABLE. AND
IT'S OUT THERE AND I KNOW AND
WILL TALK MORE ON A.
OKAY MISTER HARPER.
THE BILL TO YOUR.
WE DIDN'T EVEN.
IS OBVIOUSLY AN ISSUE.
MONEY A FULL.
DIFFERENT PAYING
THIS ISSUE.
BORN A PUBLIC.
THE OPTION.
MORE HIS STYLE.
ONE PERSON FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE THAT.
OBJECTS TO THIS ITEM AND WOULD
LIKE ARTICULATE. AYE THE
ARGUMENTS FOR HAVING A DIFFERENT
POINT OF VIEW. AND I THINK WE
OWE IT TO THE PUBLIC.
TO LISTEN TO ALL CALIFORNIA
VIEWPOINTS.
BEFORE WE PROCEED WITH A VOTE.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND TO LEAVE THE ITEM OPEN
CAN CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
ARAMBULA THOUGH
HARPER.
MATHIS.
RUBIO.
WOULD KNOW.
THANK YOU.
I MOVE THAT WE TAKE AN ACTION ON
THE ITEM THAT'S BEEN.
SEC
THINK YOU HAVE A MOTION THE
SECOND UMPTEEN CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
YES.
SO WE'RE GONNA CRAM THIS THROUGH
TODAY WHEN IS THE TIME FOR THE
PUBLIC TO BE ABLE HAVE THEIR
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO SAY
YES.
FOR I THE LEGISLATURE GETS TO
MONOPOLIZE THE CONVERSATION.
HOPE.
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS MISTER HARPER OF THESE
BILLS HAVE ALREADY BEEN THROUGH
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE. EVERYTHING
IT'S OUTLINED HERE HAS GONE
THROUGH COMMITTEE NOW.
THIS IS A BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT
MIRRORS THE BILLS THAT ARE GOING
THROUGH COMMITTEE THOSE BILLS
HAVE BEEN HEARD IN MY COMMITTEE.
AND.
THEY'VE BEEN OUT THERE FOR THE
BEEN MANY THESE HAVE BEEN PRINT
FOR FOR A COUPLE MONTHS NOW.
THANK YOU.
CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
ARAMBULA ARE HARPER.
MATHIS.
VOTING.
RUBIO I WOULD BUY.
MOTION PASSES THREE.
ONE ONE.
THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW HEAR ISSUE THREE
IT'S A GOOD AFTERNOON TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US TODAY. UP MY NAME IS
LYNN MORRIS AND I'M THE SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT OF CLINICAL
OPERATIONS AT DE HIRSCH MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
AND ON BEHALF OF THE ELEVEN
CALIFORNIA LIFELINE CENTERS WE
ARE HERE TODAY. TO ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO INCLUDE AN ONGOING
ALLOCATION OF FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
FOR FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. AND FUTURE YEARS TO
FIND CALIFORNIA'S ELEVEN SUICIDE
PREVENTION. LIFELINES.
THIS IS NEEDED. TO HELP COVER
THE RAPID INCREASE IN CALLS THAT
THE NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE IS EXPERIENCING. THERE
ARE MORE CALIFORNIA OWNS AND
SUICIDAL DISTRESS THAN EVER INC.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ALONE
CALIFORNIA LIFELINE MEMBERS
ANSWERED OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND CALLS.
CALLS THAT.
REPRESENT PEOPLE REPRESENT
PEOPLE IN SUICIDAL DISTRESS
AND PEOPLE WHO ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT LOVED ONES WHO ARE IN
SUICIDAL DISTRESS.
JUST THE OTHER DAY WE RECEIVED A
CALL FROM A GROUP OF FOURTEEN
YEAR OLDS WHO WERE ON A SOCCER
TEAM AND THEY WERE WORRIED ABOUT
THEIR FOURTEEN YEAR OLD FRIEND.
THEY KNEW SHE HAD NOT BEEN
TALKING YOUR PARENTS OR TEACHERS
AND SHE WAS TALKING ABOUT
SUICIDE IN THE COLD TO HELP HER.
WE NO THAT THE INCREASING CALLS
IS NOT SURPRISING.
BASED ON WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA SOME OF WHICH WE JUST
HEARD ABOUT.
SUICIDE THE SUICIDE RATE IS THE
HIGHEST IT'S BEEN IN OVER THIRTY
YEARS.
AND FOR TEENS AND YOUNG ADULTS
SUICIDE IS THE SECOND LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH.
AND TEENS HAVE THE HIGHEST
SUICIDE ATTEMPT RATE.
WHICH WE KNOW THAT EVERY ATTEMPT
INCREASES WOULD A DEATH BY
SUICIDE.
AND MEN CAUCASIAN MEN IN
PARTICULAR BETWEEN FORTY FIVE
AND FIFTY FOUR ARE A HIGH RISK
GROUP.
ARE CALLS ON THE NATIONAL
SUICIDE PREVENTION LIFELINE HAVE
QUADRUPLED IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS.
AND THE LAST TWO YEARS ALONE
THEY'VE INCREASED BY FIFTY
PERCENT.
THERE ARE MORE CALIFORNIA'S IN
NEED. THEN WE CAN MEET THE
DEMAND AT TIMES AND WE NEED
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
USE THE NATIONAL SUICIDE
PREVENTION LIFELINE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH THE
REST OF THE NATION COUNTS ON THE
LIFELINE TO BE THE SAFETY NET.
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE IN SUICIDAL
DISTRESS.
THE NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE WAS LAUNCHED IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE IT'S MADE UP OF
OVER A HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE.
CRISIS CENTERS CURRENTLY.
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES THEY'D
HERE TO BEST PRACTICES THEY ARE
CREDITED.
AND THEY RECEIVE.
VERY LITTLE SUPPORT.
FROM THE LIFELINE.
EACH CENTER RECEIVES ROUGHLY
ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A
YEAR.
SUPPORT THEIR OPERATIONS.
SO WE.
NO THE CALIFORNIA IS LUCKY IN
THE SENSE THAT.
THE LARGEST.
LIFELINE CENTER IN CALIFORNIA WE
ARE ONE OF TWO SPANISH SPEAKING
CRISIS CENTERS ACROSS THE
NATION.
OR ONE OF THREE.
DISASTER DISTRESS HELPLINES
ACROSS THE NATION WE HAVE.
THE PASSION AND THE DEDICATION
TO SERVE ALL OF THOSE IN NEED
BUT WE. NEED MORE HELP TO MEET
THE DEMAND.
KIDO WILL DR KING A CAREER
PRESIDENCY.
DE HIRSCH MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WILL CONTINUE TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE NEED.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US HERE.
WHAT IS A SUICIDE CRISIS LINE?
BUT PREVENTIVE HEALTH CARE.
I WISH THAT KIND OF PREVENTIVE
HEALTH CARE. HAD BEEN THERE WHEN
I WAS FOURTEEN AND I ATTEMPTED
SUICIDE. AND MY MOTHER SAID.
YOU'RE JUST ASKING FOR
ATTENTION.
NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT SHE WAS
ASHAMED.
BUT I BECAME ASHAMED TO AND I
DID NOT FIND HELP.
FOR OVER A DECADE AFTER THAT.
CALIFORNIA HAS INVESTED MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN ADVERTISING THE
CRISIS LINE.
THE COUNTIES.
HAVE IT INVESTED IT WITH VIDEOS
FOR SCHOOLS AND BILLBOARDS AND.
.
COUNTLESS OTHER TYPES OF
ADVERTISING.
THE.
STATE HOUSING PENDING BILL
WHAT'S ACTUALLY IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO THE ASSEMBLY THAT
WOULD ADVERTISE A CRISIS LINE.
ON STUDENT ID CARDS.
THE NATION ADVERTISES THE CRISIS
LINE.
IF YOU GOOGLE SOMETHING THAT
SEEMS TO INDICATE SUICIDE IF YOU
PUT SOMETHING ON FACEBOOK THAT
SEEMS TO INDICATE SUICIDE. IF
YOU ASK SERIES SOMETHING THAT'S.
RELATED TO SUICIDE.
THEY ALL GIVE YOU.
THE CRISIS LINE
ONE EIGHT HUNDRED TWO SEVEN
THREE. EIGHT TWO FIVE FIVE.
THAT'S ALSO THE TITLE OF A VERY
VERY SUCCESSFUL SONG.
IT WAS WRITTEN BY AND SUNG BY A
MUSICIAN CALLED LOGIC HIS. FANS
IT SAID THAT.
HE DONE SO MUCH TO SAVE THEIR
LIVES ANY THOUGHT BUT I HAVEN'T
EVEN TRIED.
HELP WHAT CAN I DO THAT WILL
REALLY MAKE AN IMPACT.
HE PERFORMED ON MTV AT THE VIDEO
MUSIC AWARDS.
THE BEEN TWENTY TWO MILLION
VIEWS OF IT.
SO THE NUMBER IS OUT THERE AND
PEOPLE CALL IT PEOPLE WHAT HELP
THEY WANT TO KNOW HOW TO HELP
PEOPLE THAT THEY LOVE.
BUT WE HAVE NOT MADE THE SAME
INVESTMENT.
IN THE CRISIS LINE THAT WERE
ADVERTISING WE HAVE NOT MADE THE
SAME INVESTED INVESTMENT IN THE
NINE ONE ONE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION.
THERE ARE HOLES THAT ARE GOING
TO DEVELOP IN OUR SAFETY NET IF
WE DON'T SUPPORT. THIS
INCREDIBLE NETWORK.
OF NATIONAL LIFE MY MEMBERS THAT
WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND.
OUR NEED YOU KNOW IS.
SEATING IN OUR CAPACITY.
WE NEED SUPPORT AND IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT WHEN SUPPORT IS YEAR
TO YEAR CAN YOU IMAGINE HAVING
HEALTH INSURANCE THAT YOU HAVE
TO RENEW INCOME AND. LIKE ASK
SOMEBODY EVERY YEAR PLEASE
WOULD YOU.
SUPPORT THIS AGAIN BUT I HAVE
INSURANCE AGAIN.
AND ALSO THE BUDGET WILL DO
THINGS TO MAKE HER SAFETY NET
STRONGER NOT ONLY WILL WE
INCREASE COUNSELORS WHO ANSWER
THE CALLS. THAT ARE SO
IMPORTANT.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO BUY TOOLS
LIKE SOFTWARE THAT ENABLE US TO
TRACK AND DO A BETTER JOB OF THE
IN HELPING THE INDIVIDUAL AND
CREATING A BETTER SYSTEM.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO HIRE DATA
ANALYSTS THAT WILL BE SHARED
AMONG ALL THE LINES.
WE WERE ABLE TO DO RURAL
OUTREACH THAT IS IN THE CONTRACT
THAT WE HAVE SUBMITTED.
SO THAT CUT CONTRACT RIGHT NOW
IS ON THE DESK OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
SO WHY ARE WE ASKING THAT.
THIS FUNDING
IF YOU SHOULD CONTINUE IT.
BEAT.
TRANSFERRED TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSEE OUT SITE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION ONE
THE LEGISLATURE.
DIRECTED THEM
TO DRAFT THE STATE SUICIDE
PREVENTION PLAN. AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAS GIVEN THEM THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF OVERSIGHT AND
OVERSEEN OTHER STATEWIDE.
PROJECTS.
LIKE THE.
.
ADVOCACY AND SOMETHING THAT I'M
FORGETTING DON'T TREAT HUSH.
SO.
ALSO IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSIONS AUTHORITY AND LAST
BUT NOT LEAST.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES HAS NOT YET IN THE
THREE YEARS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON THIS. BEEN ABLE TO FINALIZE A
CONTRACT WITH US.
A MENTAL HEALTH HEALTH SYSTEM.
WHERE YOU GET?
YOUR COVERAGE YEAR TO YEAR IS
NOT A GOOD SYSTEM.
AND EVERY CALL WE TAKE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE A LIFE SO
WE.
APPRECIATE THAT ALL THAT YOU
HAVE DONE IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
AND WE HOPE WE CAN COUNT ON YOU
TO BE CONTINUE TO BE ADVOCATES
FOR SUICIDE PREVENTION.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE THREE.
HI
IDLY SANDWICK I WORK FOR WELL
SPACE HEALTH AS A DIRECTOR.
OF THIS IS THAT PREVENTION
CRISIS LINE.
WE RESPOND TO CALLS TIME ALL
OVER NORTHERN AND CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA.
AND I CERTAINLY SUPPORT.
THIS PROPOSAL WHEN REALLY
APPRECIATE THE TIME THAT YOU'RE
GIVING US TO TALK ABOUT IT ELSE
HAVE A LETTER FROM DOCTOR JOHN
DRAPER THE HEAD OF THE.
BOB FOUNDER OF THE NATIONAL
SUICIDE PREVENTION LIFELINE THAT
HE WANTED TO SHARE HIS THOUGHTS
ON THE ISSUE AS WELL.
SATIRIST SOMEONE MEMBER. AND
COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE.
AND IT'S ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
PLUS CALL CENTERS.
AROUND THE U. S.
I WISH TO EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT
FOR OUR ELEVEN AFFILIATED
CENTERS. IN CALIFORNIA WHO SEEK
DEDICATED STATE FUNDS.
PER MISSION CRITICAL OPERATIONS.
WHEN CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS STYLE
THE ONE EIGHT HUNDRED TWO SEVEN
THREE EIGHT TWO FIVE FIVE
NUMBER.
WE ROUTE CALLS BACK TO THESE
ELEVEN CENTERS.
THIS PROCESS MEANS CALIFORNIANS
IN CRISIS
RECEIVING FISSION LOCALIZE CARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE HIGHEST
STANDARDS FOR SUICIDE
INTERVENTION.
OUR CALL CENTERS PRIORITIZE DE
ESCALATION OF CRISIS.
THE LEAST INVASIVE CARE THAT'S
VIABLE.
AND THE COLORS ABILITY TO STAY
SAFE FOR NOW AND IN THE NEAR
FUTURE.
AS A RESULT THESE CENTERS
REDUCE PRESSURE CUFF PRESSURE
AND COSTS FOR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT EMS.
HOSPITALS IN EMERGENCY CLINICS.
IN FACT RECENT STUDIES FROM RAND
INCLUDE INDICATE THE USE
CALIFORNIA CALL CENTERS DO A
BETTER JOB THAN NON LIFE PLAYING
CALL CENTERS. IN ASSESSING
PURSUES I'D RISK AND REDUCING
DISTRESS IN COLORS.
INVESTMENT IN THESE ELEVEN
CRISIS CENTERS IS A FORCE
MULTIPLIER INVESTMENT. IN THE
WELL BEING OF YOUR ENTIRE STATE.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
LIFELINE CALIFORNIA CENTERS
ANSWERED MORE CALLS THAN ANY
OTHER STATE.
IN THE NATIONAL NETWORK
AN IMPRESSIVE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR CALLS.
EACH ONE OF THESE CALLS
REPRESENTS A DEEP PERSONAL.
DESPERATE AND LIFE CHANGING
MOMENT.
HOWEVER EACH YEAR CALL VOLUME TO
THE NATIONAL LIFELINE INCREASES
AND THIS SEVERELY STRAINED
CENTERS.
NATIONWIDE OUR CALL VOLUME
INCREASED THIRTY TWO PERCENT
FROM TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. A RECORD
PUSHING US TO OVER TWO MILLION
CALLS ANSWERED ACTION WIDE.
WITHOUT PREDICTABLE STATE
SUPPORT CENTERS INCREASINGLY
STRUGGLE TO MANAGE ALL OTHER
CALLS FOR EXAMPLE ELEVEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED FORTY ONE
CALLS FROM CALIFORNIA.
HAD TO BE ANSWERED OUT OF STATE
WHEN WHEN THE CENTERS WERE
UNABLE TO ANSWER TO CAPACITY OR
CALL COVERAGE ISSUES.
STILL WITHIN THE NETWORK BUT I
HAD TO BE REROUTED.
IN SUCH INSTANCES COLORS WAIT
LONGER FOR HELP AND THE
ABANDONED THEIR CALLS MORE
FREQUENTLY.
YOUR AGENCY SUPPORT OF THESE
ELEVEN CENTERS IS ESSENTIAL TO
ENSURING A MENTAL HEALTH SAFETY
NET FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THE CENTERS NEED YOUR SUPPORT
NOW MORE THAN EVER.
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S NEED
SUPPORTING GREATER NUMBERS THAN
EVER.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT YOU'VE
DONE.
AND FOR ALL THAT YOU'LL
HOPEFULLY CONTINUE TO DO ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS IN
EMOTIONAL DISTRESS IN SUICIDAL
CRISIS.
DOCTOR JOHN DRAPER.
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS JAY KOKANEE ON
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
PAYROLL HEALTH AGENCIES. ARM
DIDI HIRSCH IS A MEMBER OF OUR
ORGANIZATION AND WE DO THIS
FULLY SUPPORT THE CONTINUED
WORK.
AS LEADERS IN SUICIDE PREVENTION
THEY PROVIDE A CRITICAL SERVICE
TO THE COMMUNITY THEY SERVE AND
WE STAND BEHIND THEIR EFFORTS TO
RECOVER STATE FUNDING FOR THE
SERVICES THEY PROVIDE THANK YOU.
THINK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NANCY
SALAMEH'S AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY. I
REPRESENT THE BAY AREA AND
CRISIS INTERVENTION ALLIANCE
BHASHA WE ARE SIX OF THE ELEVEN
CALIFORNIA. ACCREDITED CRISIS
CENTERS TO ANSWER THE NATIONAL
SUICIDE PREVENTION LIFELINE
BECAUSE.
WE INCLUDE SAN FRANCISCO SUICIDE
PREVENTION
STAR VISTA CRISIS INTERVENTION
AND SUICIDE PREVENTION IN SAN
MATEO COUNTY.
SUICIDE AND CRISIS SERVICES OF
SANTA CLARA COUNTY CONTRA COSTA
CRISIS CENTER BUCKLE LIEU
PROGRAMS COVERING MORAN. SAID NO
MOM MENDOCINO LAKE AND NAPA
COUNTIES AND CRISIS SUPPORT
SERVICES OF ALAMEDA COUNTY WHERE
I SERVIZI EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
CALIFORNIA'S CRISIS CENTERS ARE
ON THE FRONTLINE OF PREVENTION.
SUPPORT AND CRISIS INTERVENTION
ARE VOLUNTEERS ANSWER CALLS
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN. OFFERING
CALLERS IN CRISIS EVERYTHING
FROM A SUPPORT OF LISTENING TO
ACTIVE REFERRALS TO EMERGENCY
LINKS TO FIRST RESPONDERS.
ALTHOUGH HELPING COLLARS AND
SUICIDAL TO STRESS IS REWARDING
IT'S OFTEN UNRECOGNIZED HOW
CHALLENGING IT CAN BE. THAT IT
ALSO REQUIRES PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES TO RECRUIT TO TRAIN AND
TO SUPERVISE VOLUNTEERS THAT'S
WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR
YOUR HELP.
WE HAVE BEEN SAVING LIVES FOR
OVER FIFTY YEARS AND WE ARE NOW
CAUGHT IN A FOR TAX.
IT'S A PERFECT STORM OF
INCREASING CALLS FOR HELP AND
RISING COSTS.
QUITE SIMPLY OUR CALL VOLUME OF
CONTINUES TO GO UP WHILE THE
COST OF PAYING A COMPETITIVE
LIVING WAGE IS INCREASING BEYOND
OUR MEANS. AND THIS THREATENS
BOTH OUR FUTURE AND THE FUTURE
OF PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES WE WE SAY.
AGAINST THIS FINANCIAL PRESSURE
OUR STAFF AND VOLUNTEERS ARE
EXPERIENCING A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF STRESS MANAGING SHIPS WITH
BOTH HIGH CALL VOLUME AND HIGH
INTENSITY. OR IMMEDIATELY
SUICIDAL CALLS THE INCREASE WE
SEE AS A RESULT OF SEVERAL
FACTORS THESE INCLUDING
INCREASING MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS ALONG WITH A SHARP
RISE IN CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION.
GREATER AWARENESS OF THE
LIFELINE NUMBERED DUE TO
STATEWIDE PROMOTION REGIONAL
CAMPAIGNS AND RECENT PROMOTED.
VOLUNTEERED BY HIP POP AND
COUNTRY WESTERN ARTISTS.
ALSO MORE CALLS FROM THE YOUNGER
POPULATION WITH MORE SEVERE
PROBLEMS AND ADDITIONAL STRESS
IN THE POPULATION TRIGGERED BY
NATURAL DISASTERS. AND
POPULATION AREAS OF BOTH
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
FRANKLY THIS INCREASE IS A AND
CALLS IS A GOOD THING. PEOPLE
ARE REACHING OUT FOR HELP THIS
IS THE WORK WE WANT TO DO BUT WE
NEED YOUR HELP TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN RESPOND. WE NEED YOUR HELP
SO THAT WE CAN PAY OUR STAFF A
LIVING WAGE AND INCREASE OUR
CAPACITY TO MANAGE THE INCREASED
DEMAND. OUR SERVICES AND PAY
STRUCTURE ARE VERY COST
EFFECTIVE BUT WE NEED
SUSTAINABILITY OUR FINANCIAL
RESOURCES HAVE REMAIN STATIC.
AND ALTHOUGH WE ARE PART OF THE
NATIONAL SUICIDE LIFELINE
SERVICE WE ARE NOT REIMBURSED
FROM THE NATIONAL SERVICE WE
NEED YOUR PARTNERSHIP TO HELP US
THROUGH THIS DO THIS INCREDIBLE
WORK. AND WITH YOUR SUPPORT WE
COULD DO MUCH BETTER MEETING THE
NEEDS OF OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
AND HELPING TO RETAIN OUR STAFF.
FINALLY I ASK YOU TO KEEP PLEASE
KEEP IN MIND THAT PREVENTION IS
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE APPROACH
TO MAINTAINING A HEALTHY
COMMUNITY AND STATE. AND OUR
CRISIS CENTERS ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THAT EFFORT IN MENTAL
HEALTH AND I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WE GIVE HIM.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE THREE OPENING UP TO THE
DYESS FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS YOU MAY HAVE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HARPER I WANTED TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
THIS IS A BUT I THINK A VERY
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE THAT DOES SEEM
TO BE GROWING IN CONCERN HERE
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I IN I'M A SUPPORTER OF THE
BILLS THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE
NINETY IN AB TWENTY FIVE THREE
NINETY ONE. UP BUT THOSE ONLY
WORK.
GETTING THOSE AYE NUMBERS ON TO
WEST TO NINETIES FOR BOTH THE.
JUNIOR HIGH HIGH SCHOOL AS WELL
AS CAUGHT A COLLEGE LEVELS AYE
BUT THOSE NUMBERS ONLY WORK AYE
IF THERE'S SOMEONE THERE TO BE
ABLE TO HANDLE IT ON THE OTHER
SIDE AND YOU'RE ABLE TO OF. A
QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY BE ABLE
TO CONNECT A A CARING AYE
INDIVIDUAL FOR SOMEONE WHO'S IN
NEED
SO I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOU
BRING THIS FORWARD AND.
WILL BE SUPPORTING IT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
YES THANK YOU I ALSO APPRECIATE
THOUGHT YOU COMING TO US BUT
ALSO WANT TO I REITERATE THAT.
I WANT TO BE A PARTNER WITH YOU
ON THIS IS ABA. IN ISSUE THAT'S
PLAGUING OUR COMMUNITIES AND
I'VE EXPRESSED ARM LAST TIME
THAT I WANTED TO BE INVOLVED IN
IN YOU KNOW AT LEAST GIVE ME
SOME UPDATES BECAUSE.
IT'S IMPORTANT HER FOR HERE FOR
ME TO HEAR YOUR SIDE. AYE AND SO
PLEASE I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
THE ISSUE ARE THE MEASURE BUT.
PLEASE UP WE TALKED MY OFFICE SO
THAT I CAN BE AN ACTIVE
PARTICIPANT IN THE PROCESS.
THANK YOU APPLICABLE DEATHLY DO
THAT WE CAN EVEN INVITE YOU WILL
YOU ARE NOT THAT FAR AWAY FROM
WHERE WE'RE. LOCATED.
TIM KNOW FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENTS
WE ARE COMMENTS AT THE DYESS WE
WILL HOLD ISSUE THREE OPEN FOR
NOW AND APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I REQUEST THIS COMMITTEE ADOPT
THIS PROPOSAL WHICH WOULD DIRECT
TWENTY TWO MILLION AND ONE TIME
EMERGENCY FUNDING TO THE TULARE
REGIONAL MEDICAL CENTER.
THE TULARE LOCAL HOSPITAL
DISTRICT OPERATES.
THE TULARE REGIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER
LOCATED WITHIN THE CITY OF
TULARE CALIFORNIA.
IN ONE OF THE POOREST COUNTIES.
IN OUR STATE.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY OVER SEVENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
AND IT SERVICE AREA WITH NO
ACCESS.
TWO LOCAL HOSPITAL SERVICES.
AXES ACTIONS CONDUCTED BY
PREVIOUS BOARDS ULTIMATELY LED
TO ITS REMOVAL.
AND THE EVENTUAL CLOSURE OF THE
HOSPITAL ITSELF.
SINCE THEN.
A NEW BOARD OF DIRECTORS HAS
TAKEN OVER MANAGEMENT OF THE
HOSPITAL.
SEEKS TO RE OPEN THE DOORS
SERVICE THE PEOPLE OF TULARE.
WHILE AUDITS ARE CURRENTLY BEING
CONDUCTED BY BOTH THE STATE
AUDITOR AND THE TULARE COUNTY.
DA'S OFFICE.
ON POSSIBLE WRONGDOINGS THAT LED
TO THE HOSPITAL'S CLOSURE.
THE CURRENT BOARD OF DIRECTORS
HAS TAKEN.
ON THE OUR DOORS TASK OF
SETTLING PAST DEBTS.
PRESERVING THE HOSPITAL ITSELF.
THIS NEW BOARD IT'S TAKEN.
IT'S NEW BOARD HAS WORKED
DILIGENTLY.
TO ADDRESS THE MISMANAGEMENT OF
FUNDS BY PREVIOUS
BOARDS.
AND HAS WORKED TO RE OPEN THE
DOORS
TO THE MEDICAL CENTER.
DESPITE BEST EFFORTS.
THE BOARD HAS ENTERED CHAPTER
NINE BANKRUPTCY AND NEED YOUR
HELP.
THE PRESSURE TO REOPEN THE
MEDICAL CENTER IS MOUNTING AT A
RAPID PACE BECAUSE THE EXTREME
HEALTH CARE NEEDS.
HE SAID UPON THE COMMUNITY.
TULARE RESIDENTS ARE SUFFERING
GREATLY WITHOUT ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE.
TO RESIDENTS OF ALREADY DIED IN
THE STREETS
YOU TO LACK OF ACCESS.
NEARBY EMERGENCY ROOMS
HAVE WAIT LISTS
THAT GO DAIS.
PEOPLE SITTING OUT INSIDE TENTS.
SAYS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
IN THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY.
THE COUNTRY.
WELL THE USE OF PREVIOUS FUNDS
ARE DELIBERATED AND INVESTIGATED
I MUST TAKE A PROACTIVE APPROACH
TO REOPEN THE MEDICAL CENTER.
AND ENSURE THAT IT CONTINUES
PROVIDING VITAL HEALTH.
CARE SERVICES.
AS SUCH I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THIS COMMITTEE ADOPT MY PROPOSAL
TO DIRECT TWENTY TWO MILLION AND
ONE TIME FUNDING.
THE TULARE REGIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER.
I RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENT SEE.
SHOULD THESE FUNDS BE APPROVED.
I AM OPEN AND WILLING TO WORK
OUT ANY CONCERNS.
OF THE COMMITTEE AND RECOGNIZE
THE NEED TO ANSWER. MECHANISMS
WHICH REQUIRE THE BOARD. TO
ACCOUNT
FOR HOW THESE FUNDS WILL BE
SPENT.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONTINUING.
THIS CONVERSATION AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST SUPPORT.
FOR THIS VITAL PER FALL. WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE BOARD MEMBER
EXECUTOR AFTER.
MR HAVEL.
HELLO MY NAME IS XAVIER AVALON A
TERRY FARMER.
FROM TULARE I DON'T LET NO
LET'S ABOUT HEALTH CARE I'M
LEARNING A LOT.
I GOT INVOLVED WITH THE CITIZENS
GROUP A FEW YEARS AGO WE SAW A
LOT OF CORRUPTION WITH OUR.
LOCAL BOARD. AND A LOT OF BAD
THINGS
DEALS HAPPENING BAD MANAGEMENT.
SO WE DECIDED TO RISE UP ABOUT
FORTY OR FIFTY OF US WARMER
CITIZENS FOR HOSPITAL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND WE HELD A FEW ELECTIONS WHEN
WE TOOK OVER THE BOARD. SINCE
THEN ALL BILLBOARD IS NO LONGER
THERE.
FIVE NEW BOARD MEMBERS ALL LINED
ON ALL COMMITTED.
TULARE IS A BIG PLACE.
AS A.
SIMILAR MEN SAID IT IS ONE OF
THE LOOK POOREST COUNTIES IN THE
STATE IF NOT THE UNITED STATES
LOW INCOME FARMWORKERS
DISADVANTAGED PEOPLE.
AND.
BUT WE ARE NOT A LITTLE HOSPITAL
IN A LITTLE NICHE OF THE VALLEY
THAT CAN'T SUPPORT.
IT'S POPULATION.
WE ARE AT A THRIVING COMMUNITY
WITHOUT A HOSPITAL AND WE CAN'T
THRIVE
IF WE DON'T HAVE A HOSPITAL WE
NEED A JUMP START. WE NEED A WAY
TO GET GOING TO ONCE WE'RE GOING
ONE WILL. DO VERY WELL. AND WE
WERE VERY SURE THAT.
BUT I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO HELP
US REDUCE UNNECESSARY SUFFERING.
ANYBODY CAN GO TO THE COOLEY
ADULT THE HOSPITAL IN BY
CELLULAR AND SEE THE TWO TENTS
THAT ARE PITCHED AND SEE.
SO MANY PEOPLE AND I RECOGNIZE
THOSE PEOPLE AND THEY'RE HURTING
THEIR SICK THEY'RE IN PAIN THEY
HAD BEAVERS THEY HAVE INJURIES.
AND THEY DON'T KNOW WHEN THEY'RE
GONNA BE SAW.
BY A DOCTOR.
AND AIDS HORRIFYING TO SEE THAT.
AND.
YOU KNOW WE CAN PUT BLAME ON A
HAVE WHOEVER WE WANT TO PUT
BLAME ON BUT IT'S NOT THESE
PEOPLE'S FALL THEY TRUSTED
SOMEBODY ELSE.
AND NOW THEY'RE THE ONES
SUFFERING.
A LOT OF THE PEOPLE THAT CAN
AFFORD TO GO OUTSIDE THE AREA
DO.
BUT BE AND THAT TULARE COUNTY IS
ONE OF THE POOREST MOST DON'T SO
THEY'RE STUCK WITH TWELVE
FIFTEEN TWENTY HOUR WAITS.
AND.
IT'S IT'S IT'S VERY SAD AND
UPSETTING TO SEE THAT.
AND SO TULARE OUR TOWN
IS DEDICATED TO GET IN THIS
HOSPITAL OPEN.
BUT WE WE HAVE THE GAP THAT WE
NEED TO FILL THAT GAP WE'RE
LOOKING TO YOU TO HELP FILL
THAT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS RICH IN ALOE A
PARTNER WITH WITH LEE HFS
CONSULTANTS.
WE WERE BROUGHT IN.
BACK IN OCTOBER.
WHEN NOT.
CURRENT BOARD WAS IN THE PROCESS
OF FILING FOR BANKRUPTCY.
A LOT WITH THE IDEA OF TRYING TO
LOOK AT PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT
FOR THE HOSPITAL IN WORKING WITH
THE PER MANAGEMENT COMPANY.
A UPON THE REJECTION WE'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN THERE WORKING WITH
THE CURRENT BOARD CANNOT WHOLE
EFFORT TO TRY TO REOPEN THE
HOSPITAL IN ADDITION.
TO DOING DETAILED FINANCIAL
PROJECTIONS ARE MONTH BY MONTH
PROJECTIONS LOOKING AT THE CASH
NEEDS.
OF TO REOPEN THE HOSPITAL. I
WANT TO STATE THAT ARE AND WE
HAVE THOSE TO SHARE WITH YOU IF
YOU HAVEN'T SEEN THOSE. AND
GOING FOR IT.
FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE WE'VE
ALSO BEEN TRYING TO HELP THE
PLOT LINE UP SOME INTRAPARTY
ANSWERING.
THAT MIGHT SERVE SOME OF THE.
LITTLE BEAST INITIAL NEEDS TO
KEEP THIS GOING IN AND START
BACK.
AS YOU KNOW THAT.
IT TAKES.
AND WHEN YOU'RE SPLIT THE CLOSED
HOSPITAL IN TRYING TO REOPEN IT
TAKES AWHILE TO GET IT GOING AND
THEN. YOU KNOW BILLING AND IN
COLLECTING THOSE THOSE FUNDS THE
OTHER ISSUES THAT WE'VE RUN UP
AGAINST IS THAT WE HAVE SEVERAL.
AHA OF THE STATE SUPPLEMENTAL
PROGRAMS TO FIND.
.
BASICALLY EITHER IGT FUNDED
PROGRAMS OR OTHER TYPES OF LIKE.
.
PROGRAMS THAT ARE USED TOOK TO
OFFSET SOME OF THE MEDIC HELP
OUR SERVICES THAT THEY PROVIDE
TO THE PATIENTS. THOSE SEEM TO
BE HUNG UP RIGHT NOW.
WITH THE STATE AGENCIES IN
TRYING TO DETERMINE.
IF WE ARE ELIGIBLE SINCE THE
HOSPITAL'S CLOSE TO RECEIVE
THOSE FUNDS EVEN THOUGH SOME OF
THEM DATE BACK TO THE FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN FISCAL YEARS WHEN
SERVICES WERE BEING PROVIDED.
AND THINGS LIKE THAT THIS IS
KIND OF A UNIQUE SITUATION I
BELIEVE WHERE THE HOSPITAL'S
BEEN CLOSED.
AND THINGS LIKE THAT. OF
BACKDOOR PROJECTIONS THAT DETAIL
PROJECTIONS THAT WE'VE DONE SHOW
THAT WE NEED SOMEWHERE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS. TO
REOPEN WE BELIEVE SOME OF THAT
MAY BE ABLE TO BE FUNDED
THROUGH.
AFFILIATION WITH SOME OF THE A
LARGE HEALTH SYSTEM IN THE
FRESNO AREA THAT IS VERY
INTERESTED IN A LONG TERM
ARRANGEMENT.
WITH THE DISTRICT OPERA
OPERATIONS THE PROBLEM WITH THAT
IS THAT IT'S HUNG UP RIGHT NOW.
IN THE BANKRUPTCY WHERE THE
PRIOR MANAGEMENT COMPANY HAS
PLACED A LIEN ON SOME OF THE
ASSETS THAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
USE AS COLLATERAL FOR THAT LOAN.
AND.
WE BELIEVE THAT LEAN RELEASED
OUR ATTORNEYS BELIEVE THAT THAT
LEAN IS NOT VALID BUT IT WILL
TAKE QUITE AWHILE. TO WORK THAT
THROUGH THE COURTS.
IN EFFORT TO GET TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS SOME OF THOSE FUNDS.
IN DOING THAT.
OF THE.
THEY HOW THE OTHER ISSUE IS WE
ALSO AT FROM A FINANCING
PERSPECTIVE.
HAS SPENT A LOT OF TIME TALKING
TO SEVERAL LENDERS.
A LOOKING AT BOTH ACCOUNT FUTURE
ACCOUNTS RECEIVABLE FINANCING
OTHER TYPES OF.
IT DI THIRD POSSESSION FINANCING
AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
OUT LOOKING FOR IT THAT HAS NOT.
HA DOT NEXT
NOT AT LEAST SUCCESSFUL BID AT
THIS TIME AND PRIMARILY I
BELIEVE BECAUSE OF THE
BANKRUPTCY AND SOME THE TERMS.
LET ARE TIED WITH THAT I BELIEVE
IN THE FUTURE SOME OF THOSE
LENDERS WILL DEFINITELY LOOK. AT
THE FUTURE.
A AND FUNDING THAT'S.
ARE THE OTHER THE OTHER ISSUE TO
BRING UP IS THAT YOU KNOW THE
CURRENT FUNDING THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR RIGHT NOW IS NOT.
BE USED IN ANY WAY TOWARDS.
PRIOR TO BANKRUPTCY ACCOUNTS
PAYABLE IT'S REALLY JUST TO GET
THE HOSPITAL UP AND RUNNING AND
BRING IT BACK.
OF FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE I
BELIEVE ALL THE.
THE OF PRE BANKRUPTCY PAYABLES
WILL BE TO ADDRESS THROUGH THE
COURT FUNCTION AT SOME POINT.
LATER DOWN THE ROAD SO HOME
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ANY OF YOU MAY HAVE.
.
AND ALSO.
PASS OUT THOSE LINES THOSE
PROJECTIONS TO YOU FOR YOUR
REVIEW THINK YOU.
I WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE FOR.
OR.
HONOR AND I ALSO SERVED ON THE
HOSPITAL BOARD OF IN THE YEAR
TWO THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT FOR EIGHT YEARS. IN
OCTOBER OFTWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN T. ARM SEE SERVICES
WERE VOLUNTARILY SUSPENDED THE
PUBLIC HOSPITAL DISTRICT BOARD
HAD NO OTHER CHOICE IT WAS
EITHER THAT OR A PERMANENT
CLOSURE. THIS EVENT MARKED
ACCUMULATION OF SERIES OF EVENTS
LEADING TO THE CURRENT CRISIS IN
RECENT YEARS THINGS HAVE GONE
FROM BAD TO WORSE CITY ARE MC.
DOCTOR PART MODE KUMAR SURFER
TWENTY TWO YEARS ON THE HOSPITAL
BOARD AND MANIPULATED THAT
POSITION FOR PERSONAL POWER AND
MONETARY GAIN. IN TWO THOUSAND
AND FOURTEEN HD CA INDUCTOR
BENNY BEEN CB WERE CONTRACTED TO
MANAGE THE HOSPITAL AFTER
ENGAGING IN NEGOTIATIONS WITH DR
KUMAR. NEITHER DOCTOR BEEN CV
NOR H. CCA HAD ANY PRIOR
EXPERIENCE MANAGING HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES OF ANY SIZE LET ALONE
HOSPITAL.
EIGHT CCA WAS FORMS THE COMPANY
AFTER BEING SELECTED TO MANAGING
CAME ON SCENE AFTER THE REQUEST
OF FOR PROPOSAL PROCESS BIDS HAD
ALREADY BEEN CLOSED. DR KUMAR
NOT ONLY GAIN THE FAVOR FROM AND
OTHER BOARD MEMBERS TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS HE MADE SURE
THAT ALL LECTIN OFFICIALS VIS
VSI. SIZEABLE CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS DID NOT PURSUE ANY
INVESTIGATION INTO SUSPICIOUS
ACTIVITY AT TRNC WHILE IT'S TRUE
THAT PROBLEMS ATTY ARE MC HAD
BEEN BREWING FOR SOMETIME. THE
ROOT OF THESE PROBLEMS LEAD
CONSISTENTLY BACK TO DR KUMAR.
BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN PROBLEMS ESCALATED
DURING H. CCA'S TENURE THE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES AGREEMENT
BETWEEN HDCAM HOSPITAL DISTRICT
WAS ARGUABLY THE MOST ONE SIDED
CONTRACT. BENEFITING THEM THAT
HAD EVER BEEN EXECUTED
FINANCIALS WERE PURPOSELY
MISLEADING FABRICATED OR
WITHHELD FROM THE HOSPITAL
BOARD.
H. CCA'S PRIVATE ATTORNEY SERVE
TIES SIMULTANEOUSLY AS A
DISTRICTS PRIMERICA COUNCIL AND
REGULARLY DENIED RECRUITS ALL IN
OBVIOUS CASES OF CONFLICT OF
INTEREST.
THE DULY ELECTED INDEPENDENT
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT MEMBER
MEDICAL EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE WAS
SOME MALARIA LEE FIRED DUE TO
DOCTOR KUMAR'S NEED FOR ULTIMATE
POWER. AND THEN IT WAS REPLACED
BY A SEVEN MEMBER SELF SELECTED
PHYSICIAN FRIENDS WHICH INCLUDED
HIMSELF.
AND FIRST AND FOREMOST BECAUSE
OF AGE CCA'S GREED AND LACK OF
CAPITAL FUNDING THE HOSPITAL
SERVICES AND CONSEQUENTLY THE
CARROT THE HOSPITAL DECLINED.
AND BECAME VERY DANGEROUS OUR
RESIDENTS HAVE BECOME MARTYRS
WHO HAVE DIED NEEDLESSLY OR WERE
SEVERELY MAIMED REQUIRED
RECONSTRUCTIVE SURGERY AND
DECREASED QUALITY OF LIFE. THIS
LED TO THE FORMATION OF OUR
CITIZENS FOR HOSPITAL
ACCOUNTABILITY GROUP OUT OF
CONCERN OF ALL OF THESE ISSUES.
LITTLE DID WE KNOW THE EXTENT OF
THE CORRUPTION OUR GROUP HAS
ACCOMPLISHED QUITE A BIT IN TWO
AND A HALF YEARS WE HAD A STEP
BY STEP PLAN WHICH ENCOMPASSED.
DEFEATING A PROPOSED FIFTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR ADDITIONAL BOND
BY A TWO TO ONE MARGIN. WE
SUCCESSFULLY ELECTED TO BOARD
MEMBERS COMMITTED TO ROOTING OUT
THE CORRUPTION WITH THEY WERE
ELECTED WITH OVER SIXTY PERCENT
OF THE VOTES CAST WE RECALL
DOCTOR KUMAR FROM THE BOARD WITH
OVER AN EIGHTY PERCENT VOTE. WE
ELECTED SYNOVIUM GET TERRACE
WITH SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
VOTE TO REPLACE DR KUMAR HOWEVER
SHE WAS DENIED HER RIGHTFUL
PLACE ON THE AND IS ON THE BOARD
AS AN ELECTED MEMBER FOR TWO
MONTHS.
BY THE LEGAL COUNSEL IN AUGUST
OF TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN A
SMALL GROUP OF US ASKED FOR AND
RECEIVED AN AUDIENCE WITH THE
TULARE COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
WE EXPOSE POTENTIAL CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY BY H. CCA THREE MISSION
NEW USE OF OUR DISTRICTS FUNDS
AT ANOTHER DISTRICT HOSPITAL
SOUTHERN INYO HOSPITAL WHICH
ALSO WAS MANAGED BY EACH THE CA.
THIS MEETING WAS THE BEGINNING
OF AN INVESTIGATION THAT THE
DISTRICT HAS DIRT TOURNEY HAS
DETERMINED TO BE THE SINGLE
LARGEST INVESTIGATION IN THE
HISTORY OF TULARE COUNTY. THIS
INVESTIGATION RESULTED IN A RAID
ON DOCTOR BEEN SEABEES RESIDENTS
AND NOW IS GOING ACROSS STATE
LINES AND INTERNATIONALLY. OUR
OLD SUMMIT GOAL HAS ALWAYS BEEN
TO HAVE A STRONG AND VITAL
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL WE HAVE
NEARLY ACHIEVED OUR GOAL
COMMUNITY MEDICAL CENTER IS
BASED IN FRESNO HAS COMMITTED TO
ASSISTING OUR HOSPITAL THROUGH
MANAGEMENT OF THE FACILITY. THEY
WILL INVEST IN OUR HOSPITAL ONCE
WE CAN OBTAIN ADEQUATE FUNDING
TO REOPEN IT HAS BEEN ESTIMATED
TO COST FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
MILLION TO RE OPEN AND BEING
UNDER CAPITALIZE IS EXTREMELY
ILL ADVISED. THIS DIFFICULT STEP
TO ATTAIN FINANCING IS THE LAST
REMAINING ROADBLOCK TO RE
OPENING EIGHT CCA HAS BLED OUR
RESERVES BLATTER ASSETS AND AND
LET OUR COMMUNITY DRY.
OUR RESIDENTS ARE VICTIMS AND
CAUGHT IN THE CROSS HAIRS OF A
DEVASTATING SITUATION THROUGH NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN. OUR DISTRICT
TAXPAYERS HAVE SUPPORTED THE
HOSPITAL. ART BUT ASSUME WHO
SUPPORT HOSPITAL ARE WITHOUT
WHEN OUR RESIDENTS ARE WITHOUT
VITAL EMERGENCY CARE WHILE SOME
RESIDENTS LIVE IN REMOTE AND
RURAL AREAS TRAVELING MORE THAN
THIRTY MINUTES TO RECEIVE
EMERGENCY CARE. THERE WILL BE
MORE EMERGENCIES BECAUSE WITH
THE HOSPITAL'S CLOSURE DISTRICT
RUN RURAL CLINICS ARE ALSO CLOSE
TO RETURN ROUTINE CARE CREATING
ESPECIALLY DIRE SITUATION FOR
THE ELDERLY AND CHILDREN WITHOUT
TRANSPORTATION. THIS HOUSE TO
SEIZE WE NEED OUR HOSPITAL FOR
SEVENTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS TO
FEEL SECURE IN THEIR HEALTHCARE.
OUR COMMUNITIES IN A HEALTHCARE
CRISIS AND WERE IN CRITICAL NEED
OF YOUR SUPPORT. WE'RE GRATEFUL
TO ASSEMBLYMAN MATHIS FOR
PUTTING FORTH ITS PROPOSAL TO
YOU TODAY AND WE THANK YOU FOR
HEARING US AND FOR YOUR FUTURE
SUPPORT. AND THIS IS SIGNED BY
OUR REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
CITIZENS HOSPITAL COUNT
AVAILABILITY MYSELF DOCTOR
PATRICIA DRILLING PHELPS WHO
COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY IS A
DENTIST HERE IN OUR COMMUNITY.
JOSEPH SOROS IS AN ATTORNEY AND
CAN UNISYS CPI THANK YOU MEDINA.
GOOD EVENING.
.
CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA I SEE YOU.
A MEMBER RUBIO MEMBER HARPER OUR
OWN REPRESENTATIVE MR MATHIS.
SO YES WE HAVE GONE THROUGH A
TUMULTUOUS TIME.
BUT BEING HERE I SEE A GREAT
LIGHT AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL.
SO MY NAME'S ALEX BE TEARS I I
AM A WORKER BEE I LOVE POLITICS
I LIKE TO DO ANYTHING THAT ROLLS
AROUND POLITICS THAT'S HOW I GOT
INVOLVED IN MY COMMUNITY.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE CITIZENS
WERE HOSPITAL KIND ABILITY.
I HAVE A PERSONAL STAKE IN THIS
AS WELL NOT BECAUSE ONLY THE
HOSPITALS IN MY COMMUNITY. UP
BECAUSE MY MOM IS ENOVIA GOOD
CHAIRS THE ONE AT THE MENTION.
NOW A WOULD THE AND JUST TOLD
YOU ABOUT HER BEING DENIED HER
SEE. THE TOURNEY GENERAL HOW TO
GET INVOLVED IN THAT TOO AND I
WAS ALSO VERY MOVING BECAUSE IT
SHOWED. HOW OF?
PEOPLE WHO DO BAD THINGS THEN DO
EVEN WORSE THINGS TO POTENTIALLY
A COVER UP WHATEVER IT IS THAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO BECAUSE SHE
WAS THE THIRD VOTE SWITCH THE
POWER OVER.
A AND TRAVEL ABOVE BOARD MEMBER
EXAM FOR APPLE THE SENATE WE
HAVE DONE A LOT OF WORK
COMMUNITY WELL WELL ORGANIZED.
I WE HAVE MET WITH MANY PEOPLE
ME MYSELF PERSONALLY I I AM A
DELEGATE.
TO OUR CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
I I AM ALSO.
DELEGATE TO THE CALIFORNIA'S
BANK CHAMBER COMMERCE WHERE I
HAVE MET MANY ELECTED OFFICIALS
THERE AND ALL OUR DEMOCRATIC
CONVENTIONS AND WHAT NOT. AND
YOU SPOKE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO COUPLE TIMES ABOUT THE
SAME ISSUE WE GIVEN HOW THE
BISHOP OF FRESNO.
COME DOWN TO THAT THAT'S WORKED
LOCAL CATHOLIC CHURCH
SPEAK TO HIM ABOUT THIS SPECIFIC
ISSUE ABOUT HEALTHCARE IT'S A
RULE AREA WITH FARMWORKERS
IMMIGRANT FARMWORKERS. AND OF
PEOPLE AND I COUNTY THAT'S
GEOGRAPHICALLY VERY LARGE.
S. HIS RULE AREA.
SO NOW TODAY WE HAVE PROUDLY O.
TROUBLE THE PEER.
TO SACRAMENTO TO PUT FACES
BEFORE YOU ALL ON WHAT IS ON A
PIECE OF PAPER AS AN ITEM FOR
AGENDA.
OF THIS IS OUR COMMUNITY.
WE ARE ORGANIZED OUR COMMUNITY
HAS FOUGHT HARD.
IN OUR COMMUNITY NOW IS PROUD TO
SAY THAT WE ARE TULARE STRONG.
AND.
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW THIS
FUNDING THAT YOU ARE CONSIDERING
WOULD BE VERY SIGNIFICANT
HOPPERS OPEN UP OUR HOSPITAL SO
WE CAN SHOW YOU AND EVERYBODY
THE WEEKEND FLORES AND THAT.
CRICKET PEOPLE CANNOT PUT DOWN A
WHOLE ORGANIZE COMMUNITY BECAUSE
WE WON BACK THROUGH VOTES AND
WE'VE COME APPEARED TO SHOW YOU
THAT. AND I REALLY DO HOPE THAT
YOU CAN HELP US IN ANY WAY THAT
YOU CAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU SIR.
YES.
.
GOOD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A
MICHAEL JAMAICA AND I AM ALSO
WE.
BOARD MEMBER OF THE TULARE LOCAL
HEALTH CARE DISTRICT AND I AM
ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT OF.
THE ASSEMBLY MATHIS'S.
BILL TO THE COMMITTEE HERE
ASKING FOR. TWENTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT OUR HOSPITAL
WHICH WE DESPERATELY NEED.
WE ARE IN DIRE NEEDS OF.
FINANCIAL HELP AS YOU'VE HEARD
IN TESTIMONY HERE THAT.
.
WE'VE BEEN PUT IN A VERY BAD
SITUATION AND WE'RE DOING THE
BEST THAT WE CAN WITH. WHAT HAS
BEEN GIVEN TO US ARE LEFT TO US
AND AND WE'RE TRYING TO COME OUT
OF THIS HOLE THAT? TRIED BE VERY
PRODUCTIVE HERE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY AND OUR SURROUNDING
AREAS.
SO WELL WITH THAT I I HOPE THAT.
YOU GENTLEMEN AND.
CAN TAKE A REAL GOOD LOOK AT
THIS AND AND.
AND WE NEED YOUR HELP.
WE DESPERATELY NEED YOUR HELP.
THANK YOU.
YOU SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE FOR A BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS MANY COMMENTS THAT WE
MAY HAVE.
SEEING NONE I DO HAVE A QUESTION
THERE WAS A REFERENCE ABOUT A
BOND BEING REJECTED I WAS.
HOPING YOU COULD TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT IN IT.
WHAT THAT?
SPOKE ABOUT FOR THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND SUPPORT. YET SO.
NUMBER YEARS AGO THERE IS A THE
SEISMIC REGULATIONS WE NEED TO
THE.
YOU KNOW CORRECT THAT.
THE BOND WE HAD EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR BOND AND THAT'S
WHAT THE STATE ASSEMBLIES.
IS I'D INVESTIGATING HOW THAT
BOND WITH SPENT. BY THE SAME
PEOPLE THAT YOU'VE HEARD THESE
WITNESSES TALK ABOUT.
.
THEY RAN SHORT.
AND THEN THE SAME PEOPLE.
DR KUMAR AND BENNY BEEN ZIEVE
OPPOSE THE FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR BOND.
AND REALLY.
.
THEY SAID IF WE DON'T HAVE THAT
WHEN YOU FINISHED THE. THE THE
THE EXPANSION BECAUSE IT WAS WAS
RAN SHORT OF MONEY.
BUT REALLY WHAT WE THINK WAS
DONE WITHOUT LOOKING AT THE
FINANCES AND RICH CAN SPEAK TO
THIS WAS IT WAS REALLY JUST TO
COVER. THE LOSSES AND PROBABLY
SO SHUFFLE MORE MONEY INTO THEIR
POCKETS.
AND SO ALREADY SEEING THEIR
THEIR GAME PLAN THAT'S WHY THE
CITIZEN GROUP BUT WE WE FORMED
TO DEFEAT THAT BOND BECAUSE WE
KNEW IF IT PASSED.
BUT THAT HOSPITAL ALL THE MONEY
WOULD GO DOWN THE DRAIN AND WE'D
END UP WITH A BIGGER HOLE. AND
PROBABLY NEVER HOPE IN THE
HOSPITAL AGAIN SO WE SAW IT AS
WE NEED TO KEEP THE BOND. AND
MATTER OF FACT WE HAD A SLOGAN.
THE VOTE NO ON MEASURE AYE AND
SAVE OUR PUBLIC HOSPITAL ON AND
THEY HAD VOTE YES.
MY MEASURE AYE AND SAVE THE
HOSPITAL.
AND WE BELIEVE WE WERE RIGHT IN.
SINCE IT'S THE BIGGEST
INVESTIGATION INTO LARRY COUNTY
HISTORY I THINK THAT PROVES OUR
CITIZEN GROUP WAS RIGHT TO
DEFEAT THAT BOND. IT INTO
FURTHER ANSWER YOUR QUESTION I
THAT BOND WAS PROPOSED TO FINISH
AN EXPANSION.
OF THAT THE PRIOR MANAGEMENT WAS
PLANNING THEY ACTUALLY HAVE A
TOWER THAT'S PARTLY CONSTRUCTED
RIGHT NOW THAT WAS USED FOR
INITIAL BOND ISSUE. THAT IS BY
THE WAY BACK BY TAX REVENUES.
COMING INTO SUPPORT THE DEBT
SERVICE ON THAT EXISTING BOND
ISSUE.
THIS PROPOSAL ON THIS NEW BOND
ISSUE WAS TO COMPLETE THAT
TOWER.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT THE
CURRENT HOSPITAL IS SEISMIC.
LEE COMPLIANT THAT'S NOT THE
ISSUE OF THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH LARGE POD TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT MEETS ALL THE STANDARDS.
TO REOPEN THE HOSPITAL'S THAT'S
NOT THE ISSUE IS REALLY FOR
THIS.
FINISH THIS ADDITION
I THOUGHT THAT WAS BEING
PLANNED.
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS WILL
HOLD ISSUE FOR OPEN. HE WOULD
ELECT CLOSES MY MEMORY MATHIS
YES I'D I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
CLOSE LATE AGAIN.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
YOU KNOW TULARE COUNTY.
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGE
OF MEDI CAL IN THE ENTIRE STATE
OF FIFTY SIX PERCENT.
WE HAVE A TWENTY FOUR PERCENT
POVERTY RATE.
IN AN EXTREMELY HIGH
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION THAT
TRULY NEEDS THE HELP.
AS YOU'VE HEARD IN THE TESTIMONY
TODAY.
THIS NEW BOARD.
BY ES DECIDED TO REACH OUT TO
GET HELP.
AND THEY'VE GOTTEN THEIR DUCKS
IN A ROW WE'VE BEEN IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH EVERY SINGLE
STATE AGENCY.
ENSURE THAT THE DUCKS ARE IN A
ROW.
THEY'VE HAD PEOPLE AND TO TEST
EQUIPMENT TO TEST EVERYTHING
ELSE MISTER CHAIRS THE.
HE OUR DOCTOR I'M SURE YOU'RE
QUITE AWARE OF THE DETRIMENT TO
A COMMUNITY THAT.
IF YOU LOSE THE ARE YOU LOSE THE
CLINICS.
THE DEVASTATION THAT HAS.
TULARE COUNTIES THE HOME OF THE
WORLD AG EXPO.
A.
RIGHT BEHIND YOU ON THE PICTURE
MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT THE FIFTH
ANNUAL TULARE COUNTY CITRUS
FAIR.
WE WE HAVE AN EXTREMELY RICH
HERITAGE.
AND THE MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
OR SIMPLY JUST ASKING FOR YOUR
HELP.
ASKING FOR THE STATE'S HELP.
THEY'VE GOT EVERYTHING LINED UP
THE NEED THIS CRITICAL FUNDING
HOSPITAL YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE STAFF.
AND ONCE THEY'RE ABLE TO DO THAT
THE BE ABLE TO IT AS TESTIFIED
BEFORE YOU GET TRACK AND.
AND BE UP AND RUNNING.
AND.
I MEAN EVERYTHING IS LOOKING
REALLY GOOD THIS IS JUST THAT
ONE.
AS SADDAM.
MR ALBULA SAID THIS IS THE JUMP
START THIS COMMUNITY NEEDS.
TWO.
GET OFF A LIFE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE FOR
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE FIVE.
I GAVE.
SWITCHING GEARS HERE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHAIRMAN HARPER.
MEMBERS.
GET AFTERNOON.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT A
REQUEST BEFORE YOU WHICH WOULD
FURTHER FAWN THE FRIDAY NIGHT
LIFE PARTNERSHIP.
THIS PROGRAM.
WHICH IS RUN THROUGH THE TULARE.
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR.
IT WAS CREATED AS A HIGH SCHOOL
PROGRAM DESIGNED TO REDUCE
UNDERAGE DRINKING AND DRIVING
AND TO PROMOTE A TEENAGE
LIFESTYLE FREE OF ALCOHOL AND
OTHER DRUGS.
IT IS THE MISSION OF FRIDAY
NIGHT LIVE.
TO BUILD POSITIVE AND HEALTHY
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT.
THAT ENGAGE OTHER YOUTH
AS ACTIVELY HERS AND RESOURCES
IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
THE FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE PROGRAM
GREW FROM A PILOT PROGRAM IN
THREE COUNTIES TO A STATEWIDE
MOVEMENT.
THAT AT ITS PEAK.
OPERATED IN FIFTY FIVE OF OUR
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
AND HAD JUST OVER ONE THOUSAND
CHAPTERS.
AT SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY SITES
ACROSS THE STATE.
HOWEVER SINCE THE DOWNTURN OF
THE ECONOMY.
THE FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE PROGRAM.
THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVELS.
HAVE SEEN DRAMATIC REDUCTIONS IN
FUNDING RESULTING IN LESS
CAPABILITY TO SERVE YOUNG
PEOPLE.
WHEN THEY NEED
INTO NEWS
TO GROW.
TODAY THE FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE
PROGRAM.
A TEAM USED TO OPERATE IN FIFTY
OF THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
WITH JUST OVER FIVE HUNDRED
CHAPTERS.
ONE PROGRAM THAT WAS.
DISSEMINATED.
THE ELIMINATION OF FUNDING WAS
THE FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE.
MENTORING PROGRAM.
THE FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE MENTORING
PROGRAM.
IS A CROSS SAGE MENTORING
PROGRAM THAT CONNECTS HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS.
POSITIVE ROLE MODELS FOR MIDDLE
REPAIR THEM FOR A SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION TO HIGH SCHOOL.
WHY THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN ABLE TO
RETAIN SOME OF ITS ORIGINAL
SERVICES?
THE BENEFITS OFFERED TO THE
STUDENT SHOULD BE.
SPAN DID.
TO THEIR ORIGINAL LEVELS.
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN PROVEN.
HAVE A PROVEN TRACK RECORD.
OF BENEFITING THEIR PARTICIPANTS
ESPECIALLY WITH REGARDS TWO
REDUCING ABUSE OF ALCOHOL
TOBACCO DRUGS
AND VIOLENCE.
IT'S PROGRAM HELPS YOUNG PEOPLE
STAY IN SCHOOL.
INCREASING SCHOOLS.
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE
AND HELPS PROMOTE A SAFE SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT.
AS SUCH.
WE SHOULD EXPAND THE CAPACITY OF
FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE SYSTEM.
IN THE FIFTY COUNTIES BY
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT AND ENHANCE THE
QUALITY OF LOCAL PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION.
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE THIS.
I AM REQUESTING.
SIX MILLION ANNUALLY WE TRANSFER
FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FOR THE PURPOSES OF
FUNDING THE CALIFORNIA FRIDAY
NIGHT LIFE PARTNERSHIP. AT
TULARE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE ONE GOOD
ONE.
FRIDAY NIGHT LIFE.
AND STANDING AND TODAY FEELING
GOOD ONE IS DR JIM FULLER.
THEN MISTER RADU THAT THEIR
WORRIES AT ALL THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE. TALKED
ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS.
WE HAVE HAD THE PLEASURE OF
ENGAGING YOUNG PEOPLE IN MAKING
THEIR COMMUNITIES BETTER PLACES
TO LIVE SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR.
WITH THE RECESSION THAT WE HAD
IT TEN YEARS AGO WE'VE SEEN A
DRAMATIC DECREASE IN OUR
CAPACITY OF OUR LOCAL COUNTIES.
SERVE YOUNG PEOPLE.
IT'S OUR HOPE AS MR MATHIS
DESCRIBED THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO REINVEST TO SEE MORE YOUNG
PEOPLE PARTICIPATING IN OUR
PROGRAMS.
AND JUST THE COUNTIES IN WHICH
USE REPRESENTS WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
NINETY CHAPTERS THOSE ARE IN
YOUR COUNTIES NOT THAT'S WIENER
DISTRICTS SO.
OUR DATA SYSTEM ISN'T GOOD
ENOUGH TO BREAK DOWN EXACTLY TO
DISTRICT LINES.
BUT WE KNOW IS THAT WHEN YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE ENGAGED AND
PARTICIPATING CIVIC KLAY
POSITIVELY.
THEY AVOID MANY OF THE PROBLEMS
WHICH YOU'RE ADDRESSING ON THE
OTHER TWENTY EIGHT ISSUES THAT
BEFORE YOU TODAY.
I APPLAUD YOUR STAMINA. AND YOUR
ABILITY TO TAKE A LOOK AT A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS A REQUEST BEFORE YOU
TODAY. AND ALLOWING ALL WHO COME
TO SPEAK THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SO.
WE HAVE SOME AMAZING YOUNG
PEOPLE FROM SEVERAL OF OUR
COUNTIES WHO WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS YOU TODAY. AND SOME HAVE
MET WITH YOU OR YOUR LOCAL
STAFF.
THE FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE PROGRAM
BEGAN BECAUSE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR WE WERE LOSING A YOUNG
PERSON TO DRINKING AND DRIVING.
INCIDENTS EVERY FIFTEEN MINUTES.
IN THE TIME SINCE THEN WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO REDUCE THAT DOWN TO
ONE YOUNG PERSON EVERY FORTY
FIVE MINUTES.
SO IN THE TIME THAT THIS SESSION
HAS BEEN GOING ON WE'VE HAD
THREE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN INTO AN EMERGENCY ROOM.
OR HAVE DIED BECAUSE OF THE
COMBINATION OF ALCOHOL AND
AUTOMOBILES.
WE'RE PLEASED WITH THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT IS ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT PREVENTABLE.
AND THE ONLY WAY IT'S
PREVENTABLE WE BELIEVE IS BY
ENGAGING YOUNG PEOPLE IN FINDING
SOLUTIONS.
SO THE KEY TO THE FRIDAY NIGHT
LIVE PROGRAM WE BELIEVE IS THAT
WE DON'T DO FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE TO
YOUNG PEOPLE OR FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE.
BUT WE DO FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE WITH
THEM.
AND WE ENGAGE THEM THEY LOOK
LIKE THEIR COMMUNITY AND THEY
FIND SOLUTIONS. THAT WORK IN
THEIR COMMUNITY.
SO I'D BE PLEASED TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS WE HAVE PACKETS FOR
YOU. AND I WOULD MOST ENJOY IDLY
LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU TO SOME OF
THE YOUNG PEOPLE IN OUR PROGRAM.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU WILL NOW
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
FIVE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY I'M
MY NAME IS KOREAN AUDIO AND I'M
HEALTH EDUCATOR FOR PLUS A
COUNTY. I AM ALSO THE ADVISER
FOR PASTA COUNTY COMMISSION AND
COORDINATE A PASSER COUNTY WIDE
ACTIVITIES IN FRONT I LIVE.
.
TO.
BREAKDOWN THE DYNAMIC IN HOW
PROFOUND FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE IS IN
ITS IMPORTANCE LOTS OF THE
COUNTY.
WOULD TAKE.
UNFORTUNATE LOT LONGER THAN ONE
MINUTE AND UP IF I COULD SAY ONE
THING.
OBVIOUSLY IN MY SUPPORT FOR
THAT THE FUNDING INCREASE.
IS.
AND A LAST
YEAR AND A HALF TO TWO YEARS
I'VE BEEN DIRECTLY INVOLVED WITH
TRYING I LIVE.
IN PLASTER COUNTY ANTECEDENT
PACKED DADS THE EDUCATION IN THE
RESOURCES PROVIDED FROM THE
PARTNERSHIP DOT TO PLASTER
COUNTY. HAS HAD ON THE YOUTH
I PLACER COUNTY HAS BEEN.
QUITE AMAZING.
.
F. NL IS IS A PIONEER THEY ARE
THE LEADER I IN MY OPINION AND
AND YOUTH EMPOWERMENT YOU TO
VOICE.
.
AND TO SEE.
THE YOUTH.
INCREASE THEIR SKILL SET TO GIVE
THEMSELVES OF VOICE ARE NOT
WHICH ISN'T IT WITHIN THEMSELVES
BACK THROUGH A THEIR SCHOOLS AND
IN OUR COMMUNITY.
.
IS.
RESOUNDING
SO.
WITHOUT THEM.
I HOPE THAT YOU WOULD SUPPORT
THIS INCREASE IN FUNDING.
.
INTO.
LIKE THE REST OF US HERE A.
GIVE THAT THUMBS UP SIR THANK
YOU APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK
YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS EMILY AND I AM A
MEMBER OF THE GOING COUNTY
FRIEND I'VE YOUTH COUNCIL.
THE FRIGHTENED LIVE PROGRAM IS
CONSTANTLY PUSHING AND
ENCOURAGING STUDENTS AND EVEN
ADULTS. TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF
MY COMMUNITY SOME OF THE THINGS
WE FOCUS ON ARE. UNDERAGE
DRINKING PROBLEM GAMBLING
DISTRACTED DRIVING AND OTHER
THINGS.
THROUGH FRIDAY LIVE YOUTH AND
ADULTS WORK TOGETHER AND WE GET
TO.
PLAN EVENTS AND CARRY THEM OUT.
AND REALLY JUST EDUCATE PEOPLE
IN OUR COMMUNITY ABOUT THE.
ISSUES IN OUR COMMUNITY.
.
I THINK THE WORKER DOING IS
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR EXAMPLE
ANGLER COUNTY WE PRESENT
INFORMATIVE POWER POINTS TO THE
PUBLIC. WE.
HOLD EVENTS THAT ALLOW THAT
GIVE YOUNG PEOPLE.
SOMETHING TO DO INSTEAD OF
USING ALCOHOL OR DRINKING.
AND WE.
PLAN EVENTS.
FOR ON SCHOOL LUNCHES AIRED WE
ARE JUST REALLY.
EDUCATE OF NOT ONLY STUDENTS BUT
ALSO THE ADULTS IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND I JUST THINK THE WORK WE'RE
DOING IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT AND
YOUR SUPPORT WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATED.
I COMMEND.
HELLO AND MY NAME'S APRIL HIGH
AND I AND THE GLENN COUNTY
FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE AND
COORDINATOR AND I HAVE BEEN THE
COORDINATOR FOR FIFTEEN YEARS.
AND I HAVE BEEN BLESSED TO WORK
WITH THESE AMAZING YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT YOU ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM
TODAY.
WE ARE AND WE TAKE ACT AND DATA
AND WE PUT IT INTO ACTION. AND
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT OF ALL OF MY
YOUNG PEOPLE. AND SAID THAT THEY
FELT SAFE IN MY PROGRAM AND I
CANNOT TELL YOU THAT THAT IS
THAT HUGE THAT THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE CAN BE WHO THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE. AND BUILD UPON
THEIR EXCELLENCE IN THE PROGRAM.
SO WE REALLY LOOK FORWARD YOU
THAT FOR YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND AND SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAROLINE
HAMMOND AND I REPRESENT GLENN
COUNTY FRIDAY NIGHT LIFE YOUTH.
ETHANOL PROVIDES YOUNG PEOPLE
WITH OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INTERESTING AND RELEVANT SKILL
DEVELOPMENT SUCH AS LEADERSHIP
AND ADVOCACY.
I KNOW THAT BEFORE I STARTED FNL
I COULD JUST BARELY ADDRESS A
ROOM FULL OF PEOPLE MUCH LESS A
HANDFUL.
ETHANOL PROVIDED ME LEADERSHIP
SKILLS AND EVENTUALLY I
PRESENTED A HUGE CONFERENCE
ROOMS FULL OF PEOPLE.
WITHOUT FNL I WOULD NEVER HAVE
GONE TO SO MANY GREAT TRIPS
LEARN HOW TO BE A LEADER OR MEET
SO MANY GOOD FRIENDS.
DURING STATEWIDE ETHANOL
CONFERENCES STUDENTS AND
PARTICIPANTS LEARN TO WORK WITH
EACH OTHER TO MAKE IMPORTANT
DECISIONS ETHANOL MEMBERS ARE
CONSTANTLY WORKING WITH NEW
PEOPLE AND EXPANDING THEIR
COMFORT ZONES.
ETHANOL IS THE REASON I CAN
ADDRESS YOU ALL TODAY AND I
THINK IT'S A VERY VALUABLE CLUB
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO BE INVOLVED
IN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
HI GOOD HI MY NAME'S ALONDRA
BOMBA IN THEM I REPRESENT GLENN
COUNTY FOR A NIGHTLY.
ENOUGH AND NO WE YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITIES TO
INTERACT WITH OUR COMMUNITIES
DURING THE SUMMER GLENN COUNTY
FRIDAY NIGHT LIGHTS HOLDS THREE
SUMMER MOVIES IN THE PARK. AS AN
OPTION FOR. FAMILIES AND THEIR
KIDS AND TEENAGERS TO COME AND
ENJOY FREE MOVIE.
INSTEAD OF GOING OUT PARTYING. I
WISH YOU WOULD HOPE SUPPORTERS.
THANK YOU.
ACUMEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS TARKHAN I'M
FROM AYE REPRESENTS ON COUNTY
FNL AND CALIFORNIA'S COALITION.
I WAS IN EIGHTH GRADE WHEN I
FIRST I WALKED INTO MY FOR STAFF
AND I'M EATING AND BEING THE
YOUNGEST THERE. IT WAS VERY
NERVE WRACKING FOR ME AT FIRST
BUT.
WHEN I WALKED OUT OF THOSE
STORIES I REALIZED THAT THIS WAS
SOMETHING I WAS GONNA BE IN FOR
THE LONG TERM.
AND.
I'VE BEEN GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
WITH OFTEN NOW TO MEET NEW
PEOPLE CREATE PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
I DID VALLABH SPEAKING AND
COMMUNICATION SKILLS.
BUT MOST IMPORTANT IMPORTANTLY
TO SPEAK OUT AN ADVOCATE.
FOR SOMETHING IN MY COMMUNITY.
FOR A CHANGE IN MY COMMUNITY
THIS YEAR I WAS ACTUALLY
ACCEPTED INTO CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
WHICH IS THE NEXT LEVEL FOR
FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE.
AND.
PREVIOUS CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
ALLOWS ME TO USE THE SKILLS ON
AN EVEN HIGHER PLATFORM.
I GET TO BE A PART OF ORGANIZING
A CONFERENCE ON THIS YEAR AND I
GOT TO SPEAK IN FRONT OF SEVEN
HUNDRED DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
TO INSPIRE AND MOTIVATE THEM TO
DO BETTER AND MAKE A CHANGE IN
THEIR COMMUNITY.
BUT FOR ME WHAT WAS THE BEST
PART OF THOUGHT.
WAS SEEING SMILES ON THE FACES
SEEING HOW READY THEY WERE TO GO
BACK AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
THEIR COMMUNITY.
IF YOU TOLD ME THREE YEARS AGO.
THAT I WOULD BE OUTSPOKEN I
WOULD WANT TO VOLUNTEER I WOULD
WANT TO MAKE A CHANGE.
AND MY COMMUNITY I ONE OF
BELIEVED HIM BUT HERE I AM
TODAY.
AND SEEING ALL THESE KIDS SEEING
THE CHANGES MADE IN ME A FINAL
SUCH A GREAT PROGRAM.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND
CAME.
HI MY NAME IS JENNY AND PART OF
THE SOLANO USE COALITION I'M
ORIGINALLY FROM VALLEJO. I
JOINED ETHANOL SIX YEARS AGO
WHEN I WAS A SOPHOMORE IN HIGH
SCHOOL BOTH MY PARENTS ARE OAK
HOLIK'S AND FOR THE MAJORITY OF
MY LIFE.
I FELT LIKE I WHICH IS GOING TO
END UP LIKE THEM ESPECIALLY
WHERE I COME FROM THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES TO GET BACK
TO THE COMMUNITY AND TO HELP THE
COMMUNITY. AND TO SPREAD
AWARENESS TO MY PEERS THAT
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO
TO HELP RATHER THAN TO HER
OURSELVES.
AND.
WHEN I FOUND OUT ABOUT FRIDAY
NIGHT LIFE THEY BECAME A SAFE
SPACE THEY GENERALLY ARE MY
SECOND FAMILY AND.
I'VE CHANGED AND GROWN SO MUCH
SINCE I FIRST THERE SINCE I
FIRST JOINED FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE
AND IT WOULDN'T BE. WITHOUT THEM
THANK YOU ACUMEN.
OKAY.
AND HOW MY NAME IS NICHOLAS FASO
ARE FROM BELOW CALIFORNIAN I
REPRESENT THE FIGHT I LIVE IN
SOLANO COUNTY.
I'VE BEEN AFRAID MANY LIVE FOR
FIVE YEARS AND I HAVE BEEN
REWARDED WITH NOTHING BUT
OPPORTUNITY TO BETTER MYSELF.
I'VE LEARNED HOW TO SPEAK IN
PUBLIC WITHOUT MAKING COMPLETE
FOOL MYSELF I'VE LEARNED HOW TO
BE A BETTER LEADER TO THE YOUTH
AROUND ME. AND I'VE LEARNED HOW
TO MAKE CHANGE.
OF THE MOST IMPORTANTLY I FOUND
MYSELF.
COMING FROM A LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITY IT'S REALLY HARD TO
FIND THINGS THAT.
.
HELP ME BE A BETTER PERSON.
ARM.
I AM WITH UP THE OPPORTUNITIES
PRESENTS ME BY THIS ORGANIZATION
I HONESTLY DON'T KNOW WHO IT
WOULD BE OR WHERE WOULD BE.
I THINK ETHANOL EVERYDAY FOR
GIVING ME A VOICE NOT ONLY IN MY
COMMUNITY TO IMPACT CHANGE THAT
MATTERS TO ME. BUT.
A VOICE ANYWHERE THAT I GO SO
THAT I CAN HELP LIKE MINDED USE
LIKE MYSELF BECOME BETTER
PEOPLE.
THINK FOR A TIME
IF YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS REBECCA FLOYD
AND I'M FROM DIXON CALIFORNIA I
AM. A ADVISER FOR THE SOLANO USE
IT OFTEN NOW. AND I'VE BEEN A
PART OF OF NO NOW FOR.
THREE YEARS.
AND I WATCH SHOULDN'T COME IN
NERVOUS AND SHY AND QUIET AND
LEAVE ASSERTIVE AND IT WANTS TO
MAKE A CHANGE AND CONFIDENT IN
WHO THEY ARE.
ETHANOL RAISES LIFELONG.
ADVOCATES AND SO WITH AN
INCREASE IN FUNDING IF THERE IS
NO TELLING HOW MUCH MORE. WE CAN
DO.
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT OUR
YOUTH FOCUS ON OUR MENTAL HEALTH
TEEN DATING VIOLENCE IN SCHOOL
VIOLENCE
SO THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT
THEY'RE WORKING ON NOW. THANK
YOU BECAME.
HI THERE MY NAME IS THE HONEY
NOVAK PALMER I'M FROM SOLANO
COUNTY FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE FROM
THE PROGRAM MANAGER FROM THE
SOLANO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
AND I'M ALSO AN ADVISOR TO
MULTIPLE FRIDAY NIGHT FIVE
CHAPTERS.
I'VE BEEN WITH FRIDAY NIGHT
LIVE NOW FOR SIX YEARS.
I BROUGHT YOUTH WITH ME THAT
THE FIRST THREE THAT YOU JUST
HEARD FROM.
THAT THEY STARTED WITH ME SO
WHEN THEY SAY THAT THIS IS MORE
LIKE A FAMILY THIS REALLY IS
LIKE A FAMILY FOR US.
THIS IS MORE THAN JUST BUILDING
YOUTH ADVOCATES THIS IS BUILDING
A FAMILY ABOUT IT TAKES
THAT'LL BRING GENERATIONS OF
CHANGE. ON.
I'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO GROW
WITH THEM.
I GOT TO SEE THE IMPACT OF HOW
THE ETHANOL PROGRAM MAKES THEM
LIFELONG LEARNERS AS WELL AS
IMPASSIONED IN MAKING CHANGE AT
A HIGHER LEVEL OF NOT JUST
WITHIN THEMSELVES BUT WITHIN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. AND EVEN AT
THE STATEWIDE LEVEL AND.
THERE IS THAT I ACTUALLY PICKED
A CARD THAT SAYS YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO LEAVE A FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE
PROGRAM ARE BETTER EQUIPPED TO
BE CYNICALLY ENGAGE
CALIFORNIANS.
BUT I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT WE
NEVER LEAVE THE FRIDAY NIGHT
LIVE PROGRAM ONCE WE JOIN.
THANK YOU. MEANT.
HI MY NAME IS.
ARIANNA GOOD OAK CREEK JUNIOR
SENIOR HIGH SCHOOL. OAK CREEK
POPULATION IS VERY SMALL AND WE
HAVE THE SMALLEST PUBLIC HIGH
SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS MY FIRST YEAR NFL NOW
HANNAH HAS BEEN VERY FUN THIS IS
THE ONLY CLUB IN OUR SCHOOL THAT
HAS IS OFFERED. ETHANOL GIVES
OUR STUDENTS KNOW OPPORTUNITY.
TO GO NEW PLACES AND MEET NEW
PEOPLE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS EARL JOHNSON I'M
FROM STUDY FOR THIS IS MY SECOND
YEAR FNL.
IT'S BEEN A GREAT EXPERIENCE I
FEEL SAFE WHEN WE GO TO OUR
MEETINGS IT'S REALLY FUN. AND
OUR FINAL CHAPTER WE DO MANY
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS OUR ANTI DRUG
ACTIVITIES AROUND OUR SCHOOL
CAMPUS AND COMMUNITY WE ARE ALL
CURRENTLY WORKING ON OUR
GAMBLING PREVENTION. CAMPAIGN
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS LINDA BARRAS IN
I AM I GO TO LOOK REDUCING
HASKELL.
A I AM FROM GRANDSON INTO
MANCHURIA.
THE. THE GUYS IN YOUR ENTRY ONLY
HAS HAD SIX TWO PEOPLE OF.
THE MAJORITY OF STUDENTS GOING
TO A CREEK HIGH SCHOOL.
IN THEM ELEMENTARY. ARE ON.
BUT.
RICK.
OUR THE YET.
ARE FROM THE ARMED RANCHERIA.
OF INFERNO I'VE HAS.
.
HAS OPENED OUR EYES TO A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HIGHER MCKENNA TIRED I'M FROM
TULARE COUNTY AND PART OF THE
TULARE COUNTY YOUTH COUNCIL IN
GROWING UP I REALLY DIDN'T HAVE
A VOICE. AND I'VE BEEN A PART OF
FRIDAY NIGHT LIFE FOR THE PAST
EIGHT YEARS AND THAT'S REALLY
TRULY SHOWN ME. WHO I AM AS
PERSON AND IT'S GIVEN ME A VOICE
IN ITS
SHOW ME WHAT I CAN DO TO BETTER
MY COMMUNITY IN ITS OVERALL?
BEEN ONE OF THE BEST EXPERIENCES
I'VE HAD.
BEING PART OF THE PART I CHAPTER
INTO COUNTY.
I MY NAME IS JEAN MAN THE SOME
WITH PLAY COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. BEEN I'M WITH FRIDAY
NIGHT LIFE FOR TWENTY YEARS.
AND THE COUNTY COORDINATOR NOW.
I LOOK BACK AT THE YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT WERE HERE AND THEY PRETTY
MUCH SAID EVERYTHING THAT MEAN
SOMETHING.
WHAT THEY ITS FROM THE MOUTH OF
BABES RIGHT THERE?
THEY HAVE EVERYTHING WE WANT
HERE BUT I'M GIVE YOU A LITTLE
BACKGROUND WE HAVE OUR OUR
YOUTH.
.
ARE YOU CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES OF UNDERAGE DRINKING
DISTRACTED THAN IMPAIRED
DRIVING.
AND TRAFFIC SAFETY.
THE YOUTH IN FRIGHT NIGHT LIVE
ALSO LOOK AT THE WHOLE RANGE OF
ISSUES FACING YOUTH TODAY.
SUCH AS BOWLING SOCIAL MEDIA
INFLUENCES ALCOHOL TOBACCO AND
GAINES.
AND EVEN PROBLEM GAMBLING.
OUR MISSION OF THE FRONT NOT
LIVES TO BUILD PLAZA
PARTNERSHIPS AND HEALTHY YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT. THAT ENGAGE YOUTH.
AS LEADERS AND RESOURCES INTO
COMMUNITIES.
DOCTOR COLOR MENTIONED EARLIER
ABOUT OUR FINAL LIVE MENTORING.
THE YOUNG LADY WHO'S GOING TO
SPEAK.
RIGHT HERE BEHIND ME.
SHE'S BEEN PART OF FIND AT LIKE
PROGRAMS AND SHE WAS.
HOW OLD WERE YOU?
SIX.
HIDDEN PART PROGRAM FOREVER.
OUR FRIEND ALIVE MENTORING
PROGRAM I CAN GIVE YOU ONE QUICK
EXAMPLE.
WE HAVE.
VERY REPUTABLE.
EDUCATORS ARE COUNTY.
WHO WAS INVOLVING GANGS NOW
CALL?
I TRIED TO GET THIS PERSON COME
TO OUR MEETINGS
FINALLY DECIDE TO COME.
HE.
CAME THAT NIGHT BECAUSE HE'S
GOING TO BE PART OF A DRIVE BY
SHOOTING.
IN ONE OF THE SMALL TOWNS RUN
OUR.
RABBI CELAYA.
UP WE MADE A DIFFERENCE IN HIS
LIFE.
AND THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE HIS
DELEGATES AT A REPUTABLE.
REPUTABLE EDUCATOR COUNTY MAKES
ME PROUD TO KNOW THAT YOU KNOW.
WE CHANGED HIS LIFE AND ALL
THESE PEOPLE THAT YOU CAME HERE
BEFORE ME THEY MADE AN IMPACT ON
PEOPLE'S LIVES SUFFERING THAT
LIVE MENTORING IS SOMETHING VERY
IMPORTANT TO US.
ALONG WITH THE REST OF OUR
PROGRAMS
SO.
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION YOUR TIME.
HI MY NAME IS KELLY GOING AS A
PROGRAMMING ANALYST FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FRIDAY I PARTNERSHIP
I HAVE THE PLEASURE OF
SUPPORTING FRIDAY NIGHT PROGRAM
STATEWIDE.
NOT ONLY DO I GET TO WORK FOR
THIS GREAT ORGANIZATION BUT I
GREW UP THE DAUGHTER OF A
CHAPTER ADVISER THAT WENT ON TO
WORK FOR THE COUNTY AND STATE
ETHANOL OFFICES.
FURTHERMORE I WAS CHAPTER MEMBER
MYSELF TAKING PART OF ITS LAKE
COUNTY YOUTH COUNCIL AS WELL THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH COUNCIL.
IT WAS FIRST INTRODUCED F.
KNOWLEDGE THE LITTLE GIRL THEY
WITNESSED FIRSTHAND THE IMPACT
THIS PROGRAM HAD ON YOUNG
PEOPLE.
I WATCHED AS MY MOM BUILDS
MEANINGFUL RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THE STUDENTS IN HER CHAPTERS IN
RURAL TULARE COUNTY I THOUGHT
OPPORTUNITIES THAT SHE WAS ABLE
TO PROVIDE THEM OPPORTUNITIES
THAT THEY OTHERWISE NEVER WOULD
HAVE HAD.
I THOUGHT THE STUDENTS AS ALL
THE STUDENTS WITH THE SUPPORT OF
THEIR ADVISER AND THE ENTIRE
FIGHT IN THE HIVE NETWORK
REALIZE BRING YOU POTENTIALS
THAT THEY NEVER THOUGHT.
POSSIBLE BEFORE.
I SAW HOW MUCH THEIR ADVISER
CAME TO MEAN TO THEM AS THEY
WOULD CONSTANTLY LEAN ON HER FOR
ADVICE GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT.
I KNOW FOR A FACT THAT MORE THAN
ONE OF MY MOM'S STUDENTS FOUND
FREEDOM FROM THE GANG ACTIVITY
THAT SURROUNDED THEIR HOME
LIVES.
I KNOW THAT SHE WAS ABLE TO GIVE
HER STUDENTS A SAFE PLACE TO
GROW INTO SUCCESSFUL YOUNG
ADULTS FREE OF NEGATIVE
INFLUENCES TO USE ALCOHOL AND
DRUGS.
SHE EVEN HELPED AND NAVIGATE
PROCESS IS NECESSARY TO CONTINUE
THEIR EDUCATION.
I KNOW FOR A FACT THERE'D
CHAPTER ADVISER BECAME MORE THAN
ADVISERS SHE WITH THEIR FAMILY
AND THEY WERE HERS.
NOT ONLY DID I WATCH THIS YOU
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM CHANGE LIVES
AT THE LITTLE GIRL IN A RURAL
COUNTY BUT I CONTINUE TO SEE THE
IMPACT IT HAS ON OUR COMMUNITY
STATEWIDE.
FRED AND I LIVE IS A PROGRAM
THAT ALL YOUNG PEOPLE THAT THEIR
CHANCE TO EXPERIENCE WITH
INVESTMENT YOU HAVE AN AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CHANGE LIVES IN COMMUNITIES FOR
THE BETTER FOR YEARS TO COME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS PAULA
WILL HOME AND REPRESENTING THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND M.. AS YOU'VE
HEARD FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY PROGRAM IT'S
REALLY A CORNERSTONE OF THE THEM
YOUTH SUBSTANCE MISUSE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
HAPPENING ALL ACROSS COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I AM VERY
INSPIRED TO HAVE GOTTEN TO
FOLLOW. ALL THE YOUTH TO THE
MIKE TODAY AND HEAR THEM
DEMONSTRATE THAT US CITIZENSHIP
AND LEADERSHIP THAT THEY'RE
DEVELOPING IN THE PROGRAM SO AND
WE AT SEA BEACH TNT'S YES
STICKLEY SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL.
YOU
HE CAME.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE FIVE I'LL BRING IT UP
TO THE DYESS FOR ANY COMMENTS
THAT WE MAY HAVE.
THINK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND IT'S A
VERY IMPRESSIVE FIVE. UP LOOKING
AT THE YOUNG PEOPLE AND INFORM
ACCUTANE I AM A FORMER TEACHER
AND JUST TO SEE YOU COME UP. I
KNOW WHY WHEN I WAS THAT AGE IT
WAS JUST ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE WOULD
NEVER KNOW IT NOW BY.
AT THE TIME.
WAS VERY DIFFICULT FOR ME TO
SPEAK IN PUBLIC SO I APPRECIATE
YOU AYE DEVELOPING THAT THE. YOU
KNOW THE FUTURE LEADERS TOLD
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
PROPOSAL.
AND DOCTOR SANCHEZ ARE
FRIGHTENED I POURED IN FROM LOS
ANGELES WAS HERE BUT HAD TO
CATCH A PLANE WHICH IS MEETING
WITH THEIR STAFF TOMORROW WITH
YOUNG PEOPLE.
I WANTED TO ADD THAT I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF SITTING DOWN WITH
SOME. MEMBERS OF FRIDAY NIGHT
LIVE THIS PAST FRIDAY WHILE I
WAS IN THE DISTRICT AND.
I WAS MOVED BY THEIR TESTIMONY
PARTICULARLY FROM SOME OF OUR
MORE RURAL PARTS.
OF OUR COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND HOW IT PROVIDED AN
OUTLET FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
ENJOY AND TO RELATE.
AND SHARE THE SENTIMENTS THAT.
ONE OF THE BEST SKILLS WE CAN
HAVE FOR OUR YOUTH IS HOW TO
GIVE THEM A VOICE AND ALLOW THEM
TO BE ADVOCATES FOR THEMSELVES.
THIS PROPOSAL WAS VERY WELL
RECEIVED.
WE WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN.
MR MATHIS WE LIKE TO CLOSE.
ABSOLUTELY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
AGAIN.
YOU KNOW THAT THIS PROGRAM.
CHANGES.
THAT IS THE LIVES OF OUR YOUTH
THAT ARE IN IT BUT IT CHANGES
THE OUTCOMES OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
.
THIS GOES TO WHAT WE ALL TALK
ABOUT YOU KNOW AS AS WE
DETERMINE BUDGET DOLLARS.
AND I KNOW ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CONVERSATIONS WE WE ALL HAVE IS
HOW DO WE BREAK THE CYCLE.
IN THIS PROGRAM TAKES OUR YOUTH
IN IT DOES THAT.
IT BREAKS THE CYCLE THAT GETS
THEM INVOLVED THE GETS THEM
ENGAGED.
AND PROVIDES THAT SECOND FAMILY
THAT MANY OF THEM NEED.
IMAGES HELPS THEM BLOSSOM AND
THE FANTASTIC ADULTS
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
SOCIETY.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD WILL HOLD ISSUE FIVE
OPEN IN THE BOND ISSUE SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANGELA
BLANCHARD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AFFILIATES IS SUSAN
G. KOMEN FOR THE CURE. THE
WORLD'S LARGEST BREAST CANCER
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION HERE TODAY
TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST EIGHT
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT. AND
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE LANGUAGE
TO REMOVE THE BREAST CANCER
TREATMENT CAPS
UNDER THE BREAST AND CERVICAL
CANCER TREATMENT PROGRAM. AS YOU
KNOW THIS PROGRAM IS OUR STATE
SAFETY NET FOR WOMEN WHO ARE
DIAGNOSED WITH BREAST CANCER AND
CERVICAL CANCER. AND CURRENTLY
THERE IS NO OTHER PROVISION IN
STATE LOT THAT INCLUDES
TREATMENT CAPS HERE TODAY TO
REMOVE THOSE TREATMENT CAPS IN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KELLY MAC MILLAN
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR SUSAN
G. KOMEN FOR ALL NORTHERN AND
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. AND PART OF
OUR MISSION IS OBVIOUSLY TO FIND
THE MOST CRITICAL NEED AND SAVE
LIVES FROM BREAST CANCER AND FOR
RESEARCH. AND ONE OF THE MAJOR
COMPONENTS OF HOW WE SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES AND MEET THAT
CRITICAL NEED IS THE BREAST AND
CERVICAL TREAT TREATMENT CANCER
PROGRAM.
THROUGH THE EVERYONE COUNTS
WE DEPEND ON THAT PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO HARM THE
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA ALONE THAT
THE TWENTY NINE THOUSAND WOMEN
WILL BE DIAGNOSED WITH BREAST
CANCER.
AND TO BE TOLD YOU HAVE BREAST
CANCER IS DEVASTATING ENOUGH BUT
THEN TO BE TOLD THAT YOUR
TREATMENTS GOING TO BE CUT OFF.
IT EIGHTEEN MONTHS MAKES NO
SENSE IT'S OVERWHELMING AND IT
DOESN'T IT. IT IT'S JUST.
.
IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT FOR
PATIENTS THAT DON'T HAVE ACCESS
THAT CAN'T TRAVEL THAT HAVE
LANGUAGE BARRIERS THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO FINISH THEIR TREATMENT
IN EIGHTEEN MONTHS OR TWO
HUNDRED DIFFERENT TYPES OF
BREAST CANCER. AND THEY'RE ALL
DIFFERENT AND TREATMENT IS
NEEDED THERE IS NO OTHER
INSURANCE PROGRAM THAT CUTS OFF
TREATMENT. FOR BREAST CANCER.
SO WE WE KINDLY ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT.
THIS BUDGET PLAY FOR US AND AN
* THAT.
YOU PROPOSE WE REMOVE THE FUNDS
FOR TREATMENT CAPS FOR BREAST
CANCER SO THAT WE CAN SAVE MORE
LIVES AND CAL.
THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE SIX.
TIM MADDEN REPRESENT CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY PLASTIC SURGEONS WERE
STRONG SUPPORT ARE MEMBERS OF A
FELT FOR A LONG TIME THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMOVE THESE CAPS.
CANCER DOES NOT RECOGNIZE TIME
LIMITS NOR PAYER SO WE THINK
THAT THE COMMONSENSE APPROACH
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
YES SIR.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY FOR THE REASONS
STATED.
SUPPORT.
HUMAN.
MICHELLE GIVENS OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
AGAIN FOR THE REASONS STATED
BEFORE ALSO IN SUPPORT THE
COMMAND.
LUCY QUESTIONED ALARM BEHALF OF
MATERNAL AND CHILD HEALTH ACCESS
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT WE WORK A
LOT WITH THIS PROGRAM AND IT'S
JUST DEVASTATING TO THE WOMEN WE
HELPED TO.
NO THAT THERE'S NO THERE'S NO
MORE COVERAGE.
THE COMMAND.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE SIX ALL BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS.
I'M I WILL COMMENT THAT I WAS
PLEASED TO JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW MOAN AND CERVANTES ON THEIR
BILL WHICH MARRIES THIS
PROPOSAL.
AND HAVING A MOTHER WHO I WENT
THROUGH BREAST CANCER TREATMENT
HERSELF.
I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY TO KNOW
THAT THERE ARE NO TREATMENT
CAPS.
WITH THAT WILL HOLD ISSUE SIX
OPEN IN THE BOND ISSUE SEVEN.
THANK YOU
.
GOOD EVENING I'M OUT LUCY
QUESTION ELLA I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF. MATERNAL AND CHILD
HEALTH ACCESS.
ALONG WITH APPROXIMATELY FORTY
FIVE OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS FROM EVERY PART OF
THE STATE. BUT WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING THAT
CURRENT FUNDING.
FOR CONSUMER HEALTH ASSISTANCE
BE CONTINUED.
THE FUNDING IS DUE TO EXPIRE
JUNE THIRTIETH.
AND OUR REQUEST MIRRORS THE WAY
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN. A
IMPLEMENTED IN THE PAST WHICH
IS.
TWO YEARS OF FUNDING OF FOR A
TOTAL OF TWENTY SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND SO ABOUT
HALF OF THAT. A A YEAR OVER TWO
YEARS.
THIS TYPE OF ASSISTANCE
IS NOW AVAILABLE THROUGH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AS I MENTIONED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE'S OF BATS RURAL CALIFORNIA
THAT'S URBAN CALIFORNIA. THAT'S
THE COAST THAT'S INLAND BUT BIG
COUNTIES THAT'S LITTLE COUNTIES
NORTH AND SOUTH.
COMMUNITIES DEPEND ON THESE
HEALTHCARE ASSIST ERRORS NOT
ONLY TO.
COMPLETE THEIR APPLICATIONS FOR
COVERAGE PROGRAM SUCCESSFULLY
BUT ALSO TO HELP THEM WITH A
VERY DIFFICULT PROCESS IN MANY
SITUATIONS OF NAVIGATING THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
I COULD NOT HAVE T. THIS UP
BETTER MYSELF
WOMEN WHOSE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE.
IS ENDING WHAT DO YOU DO.
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
SMALL RURAL COUNTIES WITH VERY
NARROW NETWORKS OF PROVIDERS IN
EITHER THEIR. MEDI CAL PLAN OR
THEY'RE COVERED CALIFORNIA PLAN
SOMETIMES EVEN PRIVATE
INSURANCE.
HOW DO YOU GET HELP
FOR?
SEEING A SPECIALIST FOR GETTING
TRANSPORTATION FOR ACCESSING
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
SO THIS REQUEST IS
STATEWIDE. AND ITS FOUR OUT
REGION ENROLLMENT BUT ALSO FOR
RETAINING COVERAGE AND FOR
HELPING PEOPLE ACTUALLY USE
COVERAGE.
OHM THE AMAZING AND HISTORIC
PRESENTATION THAT OPENED TODAY'S
HEARING. IS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED.
AND WE KNOW HOWEVER THAT WITHOUT
MAINTAINING THIS WORK FORCE OF
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO ACTUALLY REACH THE PEOPLE WHO
WILL BE COVERED BY THE NEW
PROGRAMS.
THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH THAT CAN BE
DONE IN OTHER WORDS THE
COVERAGE.
AND
POTENTIAL ACCESS
ISN'T REALLY MEANINGFUL TO AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO DOESN'T KNOW
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO ENROLL.
WHO FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO USE THE SYSTEM ON
THEIR OWN? LANGUAGE ACCESS BEING
A SENIOR HAVING A MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUE THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF
REASONS WHY PEOPLE EXPERIENCE
BARRIERS TO ENROLLMENT.
AND ADDING TO THAT THE CURRENT
CLIMATE OF FEAR WE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT THAT EARLIER TODAY AMONGST
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
TO THE POINT WHERE WE'RE WORKING
WITH FAMILIES
WITH CITIZEN CHILDREN. WHO ARE
ACTIVELY AVOIDING HEALTH CARE
BECAUSE THEY ARE AFRAID? THAT A
FAMILY MEMBER.
WHO IS A CITIZEN?
COULD BE SUBJECTED TO SOME KIND
OF HARM.
AND ALSO BECAUSE THEY FEAR THE
DEPORTATION OF A PARENT OR
SIBLING
SO THESE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WORK WITH
COMMUNITIES TO GIVE THEM
INFORMATION. TO TRY AND ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS TO HELP THEM GET
INTO PROGRAMS TO HELP THEM KEEP
THAT COVERAGE INTO LARRY FOR
EXAMPLE WHERE WE HEARD TODAY
FIFTY SIX PERCENT OF. THE
RESIDENTS OR ON THE MEDI CAL
PROGRAM A BIG PART OF BEING ON
THEIR PROGRAM INVOLVES.
GOING THROUGH PERIODIC REVIEWS
AND STATEWIDE IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
ONLY.
SIXTY FIVE PERCENT OF
INDIVIDUALS MADE IT THROUGH THAT
PROCESS WHEREAS WITH AND A
SISTER.
OF THE TYPE OF PROGRAM THAT I'M
REFERRING TO OF WE HAVE
RETENTION RATES IN THE EIGHTY TO
NINETY PERCENT RANGE
SO HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS DEPEND ON
THIS. THE CONSUMERS DEPEND ON IT
AND IT'S VERY EFFECTIVE ARM AND.
RETENTION I SHOULD ALSO MENTION
ARM IS CRITICAL BECAUSE IT
PREVENTS CHURNING IN THE SYSTEM
OF ELIGIBLE PEOPLE. A A A STUDY
FROM QUITE A FEW YEARS AGO SO
THE NUMBERS NOW WOULD BE MUCH
HIGHER EVERY TIME WE LOSE
SOMEONE TO A COVERAGE PROGRAM.
IT COSTS IN THE IN THE CASE OF
MEDI CAL IT COSTS ABOUT A
HUNDRED EIGHTY.
DOLLARS TO GET THAT PERSON BACK
GOD SO THESE ARE ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE DIFFICULTY
MAINTAINING THE COVERAGE IN
USING THE COVERAGE.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT HOME FOR THIS REALLY
CRITICAL PART OF OUR HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE REALLY WEEKEND.
OF BUILD OUT YOU KNOW THE
MEDICAL WORKFORCE WE CAN BUILD
OUT THE HOSPITAL'S A WE CAN.
INCREASE AND EXPAND THE TYPES OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE BUT
IF WE DON'T GET THE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES THE
ASSISTANCE THEY NEED TO ACTUALLY
KNOW ABOUT THE PROGRAMS AND
ROLAND THEM.
IF THERE COVERAGE AND BE ABLE TO
USE A DOCTOR A WHEN THEY NEED IT
THEN. OBVIOUSLY THAT IS COUNTER
PRODUCTIVE AUM I WOULD JUST NOTE
I I DID MENTION THAT NEARLY
EVERY COUNTY IN THE STATE HAS
BEEN AVAILABLE FOR THESE FUNDS.
INTO LARRY AT RISK IS FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN ORANGE COUNTY AT RISK IS TWO
MILLION DOLLARS. IN FRESNO IT'S
ONE MILLION AND SO NO MY THREE
HUNDRED SIX.
THOUSAND DOLLARS SO THERE ARE
BROAD IMPACTS HOME FOR THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM THROUGHOUT.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE SEVEN.
HI UM MY NAME IS BOBBY CAPITAL I
AM REPRESENTING COMMITTEE HEALTH
COUNCILS A HEALTH POLICY AND
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING A STATEWIDE
COALITION IN ACCOUNTING WIDE
COALITION COMPRISED OF OVER
FIFTY AGENCIES THAT ARE
COMMITTED TO INCREASING ACCESS
TO. HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
UTILIZATION OF THOSE SERVICES.
WE ARE ALSO IN ROME ENTITY AND
I SIT RIGHT NEXT TO OUR
ENROLLMENT TEAM AND THEY'RE
CONSTANTLY TROUBLESHOOTING
APPLICATIONS THEY'RE. CALLING
THEIR CLIENTS AT EVERY HOUR OF
THE WORK DAY AND EVEN AFTER THE
WORK DAY AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR CLIENTS ARE. FILLING OUT
APPLICATIONS PROPERLY THEY HAVE
ALL THE MATERIALS THAT THEY NEED
TO FILL OUT THESE APPLICATIONS.
AND THEN WHEN THERE ARE. ISSUES
IN THE SYSTEM AND WITH THE
APPLICATIONS THEMSELVES THEY ARE
CALLING EVERYBODY THAT THEY
KNOW.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
APPLICATIONS ARE PROCESSED AND
THAT THE COVERAGE IS BEING
UTILIZED AFTER APPLICATIONS ARE
ACCEPTED.
I URGE YOU TO CONSIDER
PRIORITIZING FUNDING TO SUSTAIN
THESE COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES
ESPECIALLY AS WE EXPLORE OPTIONS
TO ACHIEVE UNIVERSAL COVERAGE.
IN ADDITION TO INCREASING ACCESS
TO COVERAGE WHICH IS GREAT AND
VERY IMPORTANT WE NEED TO
SIMULTANEOUSLY ENSURE THAT
THERE'S ALWAYS SOMEONE ON THE
OTHER AND. THAT CAN HELP OUR
RESIDENTS NAVIGATE ARE COMPLEX
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
MAINTENANCE MANY OTHER MIDDLE
MODOC WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COVERAGE OF HEALTH INITIATIVES
IN THE END WE REPRESENT OVER
THIRTY MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE
THAT WORK WITH FAMILIES DAY IN
AND DAY OUT.
I BEEN. ME MYSELF I BEEN IN A
SISTER FOR OVER A DECADE AND
HELPING NOT JUST WITH LOW INCOME
FAMILIES BUT MIDDLE INCOME
FAMILIES CITIZENS NON CITIZENS.
ACROSS THE STATE THAT NEED BE IN
PERSON ASSISTANCE.
WE USE TO DESCRIBE IT ALMOST AS
AND YOU KNOW WHEN YOU GO AND BUY
A HOUSE IN YOUR GIVEN THIS
PACKAGE. TO GO OVER ALL THESE
TERMINOLOGY THAT YOU HAVE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE AND YOU NEED TO SIGN
OUT EVERY SINGLE PIECE OF
DOCUMENT.
THAT'S THE SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE
UNDER OUR OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
IS PACKAGES AND FORUMS THAT.
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAD NEVER BEEN
ON MEDI CAL OR COVER CAL FORGET
NEED ASSISTANCE TO TO COMPLETE.
WE WORK FROM DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO
WE HAD PEOPLE FROM THE CAPITAL
AND OTHER ENTITIES VERY HIGHLY
EDUCATED NEEDING ASSISTANCE TO
COMPLETE THEIR APPLICATIONS FOR
COVER CALIFORNIA AND OTHER
PROGRAMS.
IN HELPING NAVIGATE THAT THE
HEALTH INSURANCE SYSTEM THAT WE
HAVE.
.
WHAT CAN I TELL YOU THAT THIS IS
A VERY CLOSE TO MY HEART BECAUSE
FAMILIES INDIVIDUALS ACROSS THE
STATE NEED ASSISTANCE? AND WE'RE
SORRY TO SEE THAT IT WAS NOT
PART OF THE CAMP PACKAGE BUT
WE'RE HAPPY TO TO CONNECT YOU
WITH FAMILIES INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE PERSONALLY IMPACTED.
BY. BY THE ASSISTANCE THAT THEY
RECEIVE IN PERSON WE ALL LIKE TO
RECEIVE THAT IN PERSON AT THE
FENCE.
INSTEAD OF GOING INTO A
TECHNICAL YOU KNOW LIKE PROCESS
AND ALL OF THAT THAT WE HAVE.
BUT.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT
THAT BE ASSISTANCE FOR?
?
FORGET NAVIGATING OUR OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IS VERY MUCH
NEEDED AND PEOPLE OF COURSE OUT
OF LOW INCOME.
BACKGROUNDS AND IN DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES AND ALL OF THAT OF
CRAZY NEED IT THE MOST.
BECAUSE OUR SYSTEMS ARE CREATED
AND ENGLISHMEN.
ANYWAYS BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT
HAVE WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE AND I
WE NEED WE NEED THE SUPPORT.
TO ACT CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
OPERATION ENROLLMENT AND THE
COVERAGE THAT THAT IS VERY MUCH
NEEDED. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM.
LINDA AWAY WITH WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL TO HELP PEOPLE.
I GET MAINTAIN IN USE HEALTH
COVERAGE
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MICHELLE STILL PREVENTS HE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL AND ALIGN MYSELF
WITH THE COMMENTS OF CCH I. AM
WE THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT THING TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO FAMILIES
AND TO GET ENROLLED IN THAN TO
NAVIGATE THEIR HEALTH COVERAGE
SO THAT THEY CAN STAY HEALTHY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
HIGHER WITH THE AND I'M
CHRISTIAN GOLDEN TESTED WITH THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP AND ONLY
STAND STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL.
BECAUSE MOST CHILDREN ON IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICAL THIS IS THEIR GATEWAY TO
GETTING COVERAGE IS HAVING THAT
HELP THEY'RE THE GLUE THAT MAKES
OUR HEALTH SYSTEM WORKS SO THAT
WE ARE MERGER SUPPORT. BECAME.
MARY VALDEZ OF HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THIS PROPOSAL AND WE ARE SO
EXCITED ABOUT.
THE PROPOSAL THAT WAS AT GIVEN
TODAY BY IT WOULD IN ARAMBULA
AND ALSO THIS TYPE OF FUNDING
WILL HELP IMPLEMENT THE TYPE OF.
EXPANSIONS OF COVERAGE THAT
THAT PROPOSAL BRING SO IN FULL
SUPPORT.
WE COMMEND.
ON I HAVE SUPPLIED WITH UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL I ONE
OF THE THINGS I WANTED TO
QUICKLY HIGHLIGHT IS THAT.
.
AT COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE UNITED WAYS THAT DO
ENROLLMENT ACTIVITIES NOT ONLY
DID THEY DO THE ENROLLMENT OF
THAT IS SO CRUCIAL TO GETTING
FOLKS INTO COVERAGE BUT THEY
ALSO BECOME THAT KNOWN ENTITY
WHERE FAMILIES CAN GO TO TO.
ADDRESS QUESTIONS AND
UNDERSTAND HOW TO ACTUALLY
UTILIZE APPROPRIATELY THEIR
COVERAGE.
AND AND THAT REALLY DOES HAVE A
BIG EFFECT ON ON OUR STATE
BUDGET.
AS WELL AS THE.
HEALTH AND WELLNESS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM.
MICHAEL DAY WITH CHILDREN ALLEN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
REALLY BORN REP REPRESENTING
AMERICAN CAMMY PEDIATRICS AND
SUPPORT THE COMMAND.
SINGLE FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE ISSUE SEVEN I'LL BRING IT
BACK UP TO THE DYESS.
I'M.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
PROPOSAL AND FOR MANY OF THE
ADVOCATES WHO HAVE SAID THAT
THIS WAS COMPLIMENTARY. ON THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE WILL TAKE A
LOOK AT BALLOU HOLD ISSUE SEVEN
OPEN FOR NOW THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ISSUING
.
THAT AFTERNOON SIMPLY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MOLLY BIAS IN AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR STEPPING
STONE ADULT DAY HEALTH IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
WE SERVE APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED PEOPLE PER DAY ROUGHLY
THREE HUNDRED THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY PER YEAR.
AND ARE FOR NON PROFITS AND SAN
FRANCISCO ARE HERE TODAY.
BAYVIEW SENIOR CENTERS JEWISH
FAMILY CHILDREN'S SERVICES AND
SELF HELP FOR THE ELDERLY. OUR
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE SENT A JOINT
LETTER EXPLAINING THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
REQUESTING A MEDI CAL RATE
INCREASE.
FOR ADULT DAY HEALTHCARE
SERVICES BY TWENTY PERCENT WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE A BUDGET
ALLOCATION OF FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS.
WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION BECAUSE THE MEDI
CAL RATE FOR ADULT THEY HOUSE
HAS NOT CHANGED IN ALMOST TWELVE
YEARS.
I'D LIKE TO TELL YOU ABOUT TWO
OF OUR PARTICIPANTS.
THE FIRST ONE MRS CHAN WHO IS
NINETY TWO YEARS OLD SHE IS
LEGALLY BLIND LIVES ON HER OWN
IS ISOLATED. SHE COMES TO OUR
CENTER.
AND THAT SHE IS.
REVIEWED BY OUR NURSES SHE HAS
SHE'S TAKING FOURTEEN DIFFERENT
MEDICATIONS SHE IS A VERY
COMPLEX MEDICAL CONDITION.
AND.
WHEN SHE ATTENDS OUR PROGRAM IT
IS THE ONE HOT MEAL BUT SHE
RECEIVES.
PER DAY SHE RELIES ON STEPPING
STONE TO CALL ON HER EVERY
MORNING TO MAKE SURE SHE'S OK
AND TO LET HER KNOW THAT THE
BAND'S DOWNSTAIRS WAITING FOR
HER. TO TAKE HER TO OUR CENTER.
ONE DAY SHE DID NOT PICK UP THE
PHONE WHEN OUR FRONT DESK CALLED
AND WE SENT A NURSE OR HOME. AND
FOUND OUT THAT SHE HAD FALLEN
THE NIGHT BEFORE.
THE NURSE CALLED NINE ONE ONE
SHE WAS TAKEN TO THE HOSPITAL
AND AFTER BEING HOSPITALIZED SHE
REFUSED TO GO INTO SKILLED
NURSING SHE DIDN'T WANT TO BE
AND NOT. FACILITY SHE WANTED TO
GO HOME
AND.
FROM HOME SHE THEN STARTED GOING
BACK TO ADULT THEY HEALTH. ON
BACK TO STEPPING STONE ARE INTER
DID DISCIPLINARY TEAM CONSISTS
OF A PHYSICAL THERAPIST
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS NURSE.
OUR DIETITIAN SOCIAL WORKERS.
.
AND IT'S AS PSYCHIATRISTS
AND IT
SHE DIDN'T HAVE THIS WRAPAROUND
CARE SHE WOULD HAVE DIED AT HOME
A FARCE THAT PARTNERS HAD NOT
GONE TO HER HOME TO CHECK ON
HER.
.
SHE HAS SLOWLY REGAINED
STRENGTH.
AND IT'S NICE TO SEE THAT SHE IS
ABLE TO I'M CONTINUE TO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY.
THE SECOND PURCHASE BUT I'D
LIKE TO TELL YOU ABOUT IS HIS
NAME IS LARRY HE IS.
AND IS MID FIFTIES IS AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE.
AND HE HAS HAD SEVEN STROKES
HE'S CONFINED TO A WHEELCHAIR
DUE TO DEGENERATIVE JOINT
DISEASE. AND HAS HE'S DIAGNOSED
WITH THEM SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
DIABETES AND HIS TWENTY YEAR OLD
SON WHO LIVES WITH HIM.
HIS SON GOES TO COLLEGE AND IS
HIS FULL TIME CAREGIVER.
THE HELP SAM WITH.
SHOPPING DRESSING BATHING
MEDICATION MANAGEMENT.
BEFORE LARRY ATTENDED OUR
PROGRAM HE WOULD CALL NINE ONE
ONE FOR ANY MEDICAL NEED.
AND ONCE HE GOT INVOLVED IN THE
PROGRAM.
OUR MEDICAL TEAM WAS ABLE TO
CARE FOR HIM AND HELP HIM.
SO HE HAS NOW EDUCATED AND
REALIZE THAT HE CAN COME TO US
WHEN THERE ARE MEDICAL NEEDS.
AND NOW HE DOESN'T CALL NINE ONE
ONE IT'S OFTEN HERE.
UTILIZES THE TEAM THAT IS THERE
TO SUPPORT HIM AND HE'S ABLE HE
AND HIS SON ARE MORE EDUCATED.
THIS IS JUST A SNAPSHOT OF TWO
OF OUR MANY VULNERABLE
PARTICIPANTS WITH COMPLEX CASES.
AND THE NEED FOR ADULT DAY
HEALTH TO STAY OUT OF HIRE. ON
COST FACILITIES IS AVAILABLE
THROUGH ADULT DAY HEALTH.
BY TWENTY THIRTY.
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF SAN
FRANCISCO'S POPULATION ONE IN
FOUR WILL BE SENIORS.
AND THE FASTEST GROWING SEGMENT
WILL BE OVER EIGHTY FIVE YEARS
OLD.
NINETY FIVE PERCENT OF OUR
POPULATION ARE LOW INCOME MEDI
CAL CLIENTS WITH NO OUT OF
POCKET EXPENSES.
A STUDY FROM THE TO THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN GENWORTH FINANCIAL COST
OF CARE SHOWS THAT ADULT DAY
HEALTHCARE IS APPROXIMATELY ONE
FIFTH.
OF SKILLED NURSING COSTS.
SAN FRANCISCO IS THE SECOND MOST
EXPENSIVE CITY. IN THE UNITED
STATES
AND THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES.
ADULT DAY HEALTH IS BEING
STARVED.
WE ARE REQUESTING A BUDGET
ALLOCATION TO INCREASE ADULT DAY
HEALTH.
AND THE MEDI CAL FEE BY TWENTY
PERCENT.
THE VETERANS AFFAIR A VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION IS PAYING FOR THE
SAME SERVICE WITH THAT AMOUNT.
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND WE'D
LIKE TO WORK WITH STAFF AND
OTHERS TO REFINE ESTIMATES. OF
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY.
ADULT DAY HEALTH IS AN EFFECTIVE
AND COST EFFICIENT AND IT'S AN
EXTREMELY GOOD INVESTMENT.
IT SIMPLY MAKES SENSE FOR THE
TAXPAYERS FOR FRAIL THE FRAIL
POPULATION AND FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE.
LET'S BE PRO ACTIVE LET'S HELP
PEOPLE STAY IN THEIR HOMES
LIVING COMMUNITY AND STAY OUT OF
EXPENSIVE FACILITIES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I AM KATHY DAVIS ON
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF BABY
SENIOR SERVICES AND I'VE BEEN
WITH OUR DON'T THEY HEALTH
CENTER SINCE IT OPENED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR.
IT KIND OF MAKES ME A DINOSAUR A
BEEN THERE FORTY YEARS.
BUT JUST SEEING THE ADULT THEY
HEALTH CARE AND THE IMPACT THAT
IT MAKES AND REALIZING THAT FOR
THE LAST TWELVE YEARS THERE
HASN'T BEEN AN INCREASE. IN OUR
RATE HOWEVER WE'VE HAD TO DEAL
WITH ALL THE INCREASES IN SAN
FRANCISCO IT'S GETTING REALLY
DIFFICULT TO KEEP OUR DOORS
OPEN.
AND IN SAN FRANCISCO YOU HAVE TO
REALIZE WE JUST DON'T HAVE A LOT
OF NURSING HOMES THEY'RE JUST
NOT THERE EVEN IF YOU WANTED TO
PAY FIVE TIMES MORE TO TAKE CARE
OF THE POPULATION WITH SARAH. WE
DON'T EVEN HAVE THAT.
AVAILABLE SO PEOPLE HAVE TO GO
OUT OF COUNTY OR DIE OF IF THEY
DON'T GET THE KIND OF SERVICES
THAT WE OFFER SO I JUST WANT TO
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS REQUEST
FOR SAN FRANCISCO BECAUSE IT IS
KIND OF UNIQUE. IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR EVERY PART OF THE STATE BUT
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT SAN
FRANCISCO BECAUSE WE REALLY ARE
TRYING TO KEEP THE POPULATION.
IN THE COMMUNITY THANK YOU THANK
HIM.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD EVENING
I'M TRACY DOBRA NOVEL WITH
JEWISH FAMILY AND CHILDREN'S
SERVICES.
WE OPERATE THE LEHIGH MIDDLE
THEY CENTER IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
I'M REPLY THE YOUNGEST ADULT
THEY CENTER AT NINETEEN YEARS.
OF OPERATION.
WE SERVE OVER A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY PEOPLE EVERYDAY AT OUR
CENTER.
AND REALLY WE ARE HERE TO
SUPPORT AS YOU'VE HEARD MY
COLLEAGUES OF THE NEED FOR A
RATE INCREASE IN SAN FRANCISCO
WERE OPERATING ON RATES THAT
WERE SENT BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVEN.
.
WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED AN INCREASE
THERE HAVE BEEN OTHER COUNTIES
THAT HAVE GONE INCREASES THAT
THERE IS A PRECEDENT.
.
YOU KNOW THIS IS OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION.
IT IS A COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
KEEP PEOPLE AT HOME IN PART OF
THE COMMUNITY.
AND ALL SHARE JUST ONE OF OUR
ONE OF OUR CLIENTS RECENTLY WAS
ASKED WHY SHE DIDN'T ARE BY AN
OUTSIDE FUNDER. AND SHE SAID
BECAUSE IF SHE DIDN'T COME TO
THE CENTER SHE WOULD SIT AT HOME
ALL DAY LONG BY HERSELF. NO
FAMILY
SHE WOULD NOT BE GOING OUT
SHOULD NOT BE GETTING MEDICAL
CARE.
AND MOST LIKELY SHE WOULD DIE
IN THAT SITUATION AND SHE SAID
THIS OF KNOWING HOW LUCKY SHE IS
ABLE TO CONDUCT CENTER.
AND SHE EVEN SAID THAT THE LIKE
OF THE SENATE PASSED AWAY
BECAUSE SHE HAD BEEN THERE SO
LONG.
SO WE REALLY SUPPORT THE NEED
FOR THE FEE INCREASE IT'S
BECOMING MORE AND MORE DIFFICULT
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO OPERATE
HIGH QUALITY SERVICES AND PEOPLE
KEEP THESE.
MOST VULNERABLE.
PEOPLE OF OUR POPULATION SAY
THANK YOU
YOU CAN.
AND I'M ANY COME FROM SELF HELP
FOR THE ELDERLY SIMILARLY SELF
HELP OPEN DAHLE ADULT DAY HEALTH
CARE CENTER BACK IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX SO DISHES LIKE OUT
TWENTY THIRD YEAR IN OPERATION.
AND FOR MANY YEARS OF SENIORS
REALLY FIND IT.
MOST COST EFFECTIVE AS WELL AS
SERVING THE FAMILIES WITH A SIX
HOUR SIX AND A HALF HOURS OF
RESPITE. AT OUR CENTER AND AS
MARTY SAID MANY OF OUR VERY
FRAIL SENIORS TICKET LEASH EIGHT
TO TEN SOMETIMES FOURTEEN
MEDICATIONS.
BUT BECAUSE THEY ARE KEPT AT THE
CENTER AND THE FAMILIES COULD.
GO OFF AND WORK A FEW HOURS AND
THEN FEEL THAT YOU KNOW THE
ELDERLY ARE WELL TAKEN CARE OFF
AN ADULT DAY HEALTH CARE CENTER.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE RECENTLY WE
HAVE ONE SENIOR THAT WAS
HOSPITALIZED FOR TWO NIGHTS
INTO.
IN THE EMERGENCY HOSPITAL AND
THEN CENTER INTENSIVE CARE FOR
ONE NIGHT AND THE BILL CAME BACK
AS THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND AN ADULT DAY HEALTH CARE
CENTER LIKE OURS RECEIVE ROUGHLY
THE SAME AMOUNT SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR THIS IS FALL
EACH TYPE OF THE TWO NIGHTS OF
HOSPITAL STAY. BUT YET AN ADULT
DAY HEALTH CARE CENTER RECEIVE
ABOUT EIGHTEEN THOUSAND DOLLAR A
YEAR FALL TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DAYS OF CARE AT ONE OF OUR
CENTERS WE PROVIDE. THREE MEALS
A DAY.
NURSING P. T. O. T. HOME
HEALTHCARE SPEECH THERAPY. AND
AND YET THE STATE REIMBURSE US
UP AT ABOUT SEVENTY SIX DOLLARS
A DAY PER PARTICIPANT.
AND THAT RATE HAS NOT GOTTEN UP
AS YOU HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUES
SO WE URGE YOU TO BRENDA'S THIS
TWENTY PERCENT INCREASE SO WE'LL
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
THESE. REALLY COMMUNITY BASED
BUT VERY VERY EFFECTIVE COST
EFFECTIVE HEALTH CARE AND KEEP
OUR SENIORS IN THE COMMUNITY AND
IN THEIR OWN HOMES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BECAME.
BRUNO TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON IS
YOU A.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M LYDIA MISSILE EDS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR ADULT DAY
SERVICES AND I'M JUST HERE TO
SUPPORT.
ON MY COLLEAGUES IN THIS REQUEST
FROM THERE REALLY ASKING FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. FULFILL THE
STATE'S POLICY OF MAP BETTER
MATCHING RATES WITH THE
COMMUNITY.
OUR THAT CHANGED IN TWENTY
ELEVEN.
AND.
THEIR THEIR REMARKS TODAY ARE
REMINDED ME OF THE FAMOUS SANE.
NO MARGIN NO MISSION.
WE HAVE HAD OVER THE LAST NOW
SEVEN TO EIGHT YEARS SINCE
TWENTY ELEVEN FIFTY SIX CENTERS
CLOSE STATEWIDE.
SOME OF THEM I DIDN'T DO THE
LOOK UP RIGHT BEFORE I CAME HERE
BUT SOME OF THEM I KNOW ON SOME
OF YOUR COMMUNITIES.
AND A WE ONLY HAVE CENTERS AND
THIRTY TWO COUNTIES IN THIS
WHOLE STATE.
AND OF THOSE THIRTY TWO THIRTEEN
COUNTIES HAVE FIVE OR FEWER
CENTERS.
SO WE'VE.
LOST INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE SAME
TIME THAT THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF
AGING AND OUR STATE AS MOLLY
DEPRIVE JUST FOR HER. OF CITY
ARE GROWING WHILE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS BEEN
CRUMBLING FOR THE PAST OF DECADE
OR MORE SO. I'M JUST HERE TO
SUPPORT MY COLLEAGUES AND TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS VERY MODEST
PROPOSAL THAT WILL GO A LONG
WAY.
SUPPORTING FRAIL SENIORS AND
PERSONS WITH COMPLEX MEDICAL
CONDITIONS IN THE COMMUNITY
THANK YOU BECAME.
GOOD AFTERNOON LISA COLEMAN WITH
CALCUTTA FOR YOUR LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION.
I'M ARE OUR PROGRAMS ARE HEARING
MORE AND MORE. OF FAMILY MEMBERS
NOT ABLE TO TO LOVE.
TRANSITION I LOVE ONE OUT OF A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY BACK
INTO OF THE COMMUNITY BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE A DAY PROGRAM
AND THEY CAN'T TAKE CARE OF
THEIR LOVED ONE AT HOME.
I TWENTY FOUR SEVEN.
SO THIS IS THE KIND OF PROGRAM
THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO LIVE IN
THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT. WHILE STILL
RESPECTING THE FAMILIES NEED TO
WORKING FAMILIES CAN'T DO ALL OF
IT.
AND THAT THESE ARE DAY PROGRAMS
PROVIDE.
JUST AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
SAFETY NET
SO AS AN OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION
WE DO ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
STATE PROGRAMS.
I COMMEND.
MANY EX CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
RIGHTS.
WE CONCUR WITH SHE JUST SAID.
THANK YOU SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE A DON'T BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS FOR ANY COMMENTS.
SEEING NINE AM I WOULD ASK MR
BIAS IF YOU COULD WORK WITH OUR%
COMMITTEE STAFF TO.
SEE IF IT'S POSSIBLE TO LOOK AT
PROP FIFTY SIX FUNDS AS A
POTENTIAL.
FOR A SOURCE OF FUNDS TO.
ADDRESS THE MEDI CAL RATE
THAT'S BEFORE US.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
EIGHT OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
.
I.
I'M SEAN ITEM ON HERE.
WITH SUN VALLEY SPECIALLY
HEALTH CARE AND RIGHT NOW I WISH
THAT I HAD TAKEN AS OF FRIDAY
NIGHT LIKE CLASS FOR.
A TWO.
TO GET SOME
SPEAKING SKILLS GOING.
.
AND SO.
WILL BE BRIEF BECAUSE YOU GUYS
ARE HAVE ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE
MORE.
ALRIGHT.
BOTH.
.
SO WHERE PEDIATRIC SUB ACUTE AND
I.
HAD BEEN ADMINISTRATOR THERE
FOR ABOUT TEN YEARS. AND THEN MY
HUSBAND I ACTUALLY PURCHASED NON
THEIST ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO.
AND WHAT IT IS IS.
.
I WAS SO PEOPLE LIKE.
HE DON'T KNOW ABOUT US INTO A
YOU NEED US AND SO WE ARE.
ALL PEEVES ALL OF OUR DOCTORS
OUR INTENSIVE IT'S FROM UCLA.
.
INSOMUCH OUR CLIENTELE ARE
THEY'LL HAVE TO BE ON A.
EVENT
RG TO WE TAKE A DIALYSIS
PATIENTS
AND WE ARE KIDS COME FROM THE
NICK UNITS SO WERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE TAKE KIDS FROM ALL
OVER. BECAUSE THERE'S ONLY FOR
FREE STANDING PEDIATRIC SUB
ACUTE.
I WERE AT NINETY NINE PERCENT
CAPACITY.
AND AGAIN A TAKE KIDS FROM UP
NORTH DOWN SOUTH.
ALL OVER AND WERE IN LA SOURCE
CENTRALLY LOCATED WE WORK ON A
CLOSE WITH UCLA CHILDREN'S HONEY
TURN BUT THEN ALL THE SMALL
HOSPITALS APPEARS WELL. AND WE
TAKE KIDS FROM OUR YOUNG THIS IS
ABOUT TWO MONTHS OLD THERE A LOT
OF KIDS WHO ARE PREMATURE.
.
WITH SUCH APLOMB BIRTH DEFECTS
ARE HARD ISSUES LONG ISSUES
MAYBE THE YOUNGER ONE OF A TWIN
THAT DOESN'T QUITE.
.
IS IT PULL IT FULLY DEVELOPED
AND WE WORK VERY HARD TO GET
THESE KIDS OFFENSE AND HOME. RUN
OUR STAFF IS HIGHLY EDUCATED WE
HAVE ALL KINDS RE HAVE WE HAVE
OUR RIGHTS RIGHT THERE THIS
AGAIN OUR DOCTORS ARE NOT
INTENSE VISIT UCLA. NURSES.
AND WE TAKE IS VERY FRAGILE
KIDS AND TRY TO MAKE THEM AS
WHOLE AS POSSIBLE. AND OUR GOAL
IS TO GET THEM OFF THE VAN AND
GET THEM HOME.
GIFT IF POSSIBLE BOUNCE RESERVE
THESE KIDS WE ALSO SERVED ON
KIDS WHO ARE NEAR DROWNING
CLIENTS.
KIDS YOUR CAR ACCIDENTS.
A WE TAKE INSURANCE BUT THE
PROBLEM WITH THEM.
WITH.
THE INSURANCE SYSTEM IS AFTER A
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS IF YOU HAVE
GOOD INSURANCE EVERYTHING GOES
TO MEDI CAL.
SO WE ARE ON OUR MEDICAL FUND.
AND OUR RATE IS WE'RE LOOKING AT
A RATE THAT'S WHAT BROUGHT US
HERE IS TRYING TO STRUGGLE WITH
WE'RE ACTION IN OUR AREA THAT
HOW. ARE THE FIRE IN THE FLOOD
AND SO WE'RE IN A ROOM WHERE THE
NEW YORK TIMES FOR FOR. NOT THE
REASONS WE WANT TO BE.
THAT WE DON'T HAVE FUNDS NOW TO
CLEAN UP THE PARKING LOT SIR
RATES BEEN FROZEN FOR TEN YEARS.
AND THERE'S ONLY FOR A.
FREE STANDING PEDIATRIC SUB
ACUTE THEIR.
.
AND WE ALL LOOKED AT OUR COST
REPORTS AND WE'RE GETTING PAID
UNDER WHAT THE COST REPORTS
WOULD SUGGEST.
SOME ASK WE ARE ASKING FOR FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS TO. HELP STOP
THE BLEEDING AND AT THIS POINT
WE'RE IN A SITUATION WHERE.
I'VE BEEN THERE SO LONG YOU GET
ATTACHED TO THESE KIDS WE SEE
THE DEVASTATION OF THESE
FAMILIES WHO COME IN. WHO WERE
HOPING FOR AT INTACT CHILD AND
DON'T HAVE ONE OR THEY HADN'T
TALKED CHILD ENOUGH CERTAIN?
THEY DON'T AND IN SO IT'S.
IT'S A HORRIFYING THING TO SEE
BUT THEN YOU SEE THE MIRACULOUS
HEALING THAT COMES WITH THAT.
AND WE'D I'D LIKE TO TELL PEOPLE
THAT WE HAVE A VERY FRIENDLY
PLACE IT'S THE PLACE WHERE WE
WANT THEM THE KIDS DIFFICULT
HOME FAMILIES TO FILL A HOME.
IT'S BRIGHT WE HAVE ACTIVITIES
TO TRY TO GET THE KIDS OUT AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE. WE WANT THEM
TO BE ARM.
EMOTIONALLY ENGAGED AND READY TO
ENTER THE WORLD AT WHATEVER
LEVEL THEY'RE READY TO GO ON.
BUT IT'S HARD TO DO WITH NOT
HAVING ANY INCREASES AND WE ALL
KNOW THAT.
HEALTHCARE IS RISING AND SO WE
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO.
INCREASE OUR STAFF ARE WEIRD A
POINT NOW WHERE WE'RE LOOKING
AT.
DO WE PAY FOR THE DRIVEWAY OR DO
WE PAY FOR.
.
AND THE THIS VENDOR HAD WE MEET
PAYROLL AND WE'RE FIVE STAR
FACILITY IN OUR PART MANY PFIZER
FACILITIES.
AND I THINK THAT.
.
I'M HERE BECAUSE I PHILIP WE ARE
AT A PLACE WHERE.
IF WE KEEP GOING IN THE RIGHT
THE ROAD WE'RE GOING WE'RE GONNA
BE ASKED TO I'M.
TO.
PROVIDE.
TO CUT DOWN THE CARE THAT WE
PROVIDE AND I THINK IT'S IMMORAL
AND I DON'T THINK THAT.
WE CAN'T DO THAT AND SO THAT
WOULD MEAN THAT THESE KIDS GO
BACK TO AN ICY YOU AND GET STUCK
THERE FOR.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE DEVELOPED
ACTUALLY IS TO GET KIDS OUT OF
THE ICU AND TO GIVE MY QUALITY
OF LIFE.
AND SO ON.
SO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
AND I AGAIN ASK FOR FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS TO HEL US.
BECOME WHOLE AGAIN AND TO TREAT
THESE KIDS ALL ACROSS THE STATE
ARM.
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM AND YOU DID
GREAT.
THANK YOU FOR LINE I PREFER.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE ISSUE NINE.
HE LATE ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED PEDIATRIC
SUBSPECIALTY PHYSICIAN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. DEPOSITION
THREE REPRESENT TREAT CRITICALLY
AND CHRONICALLY ILL CHILDREN IN
THE HOSPITAL SETTING BUT WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
PATIENT POPULATION HAVING A
PLACE TO GO UPON DISCHARGE THAT
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS RATE
INCREASE.
WE CAN.
GOOD EVENING MATT ROBINSON THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES THAT REPRESENTS
GOVERNOR SUBSIDES IN CALIFORNIA
AND THESE ARE GREAT MEMBERS THAT
WERE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
THIS.
THEY ARE A HUNDRED PERCENT MEDI
CAL FUNDED I'D IS VERY VERY
OBVIOUSLY DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
EVEN COVER THE COST WITH THAT
MEDI CAL REIMBURSEMENT.
ESPECIALLY WITH THAT RATE FREEZE
THAT THEY'VE HAD OVER THE YEARS
ON THE HOUSES HAD A VERY GOOD
JOB. IN DEPICTING THE PROBLEM
AND AGAIN WE ARE AT YOUR SPORT
THANK YOU.
WHERE MARTIN HERE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE FOR THE
REASONS ALREADY STATED? THE
COMMAND.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE NINE OPENING IT UP TO
THE DYESS.
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS.
SO SO YOU DID GREAT THANK YOU
ARM.
I I AM THE FATHER OF ONE OF THE
PATIENTS AND MY NAY A TO A TYPE
OF ALL MY SON JEFFERSON ON THE
HERE AND THERE IS BORROWER SPINA
BIFIDA AND HE'S THREE AND A HALF
NOW.
SO I.
UNDERSTAND QUITE WELL AND.
.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING MOYER TRYING
TO DO HERE ALL THE WAY THROUGH
THINK.
.
THEY IT IF A FAMILY LIKE MINE
OF.
OF ARE STATURE SOMEBODY SITTING
HERE ON THE DIETS UNDERSTANDS
THE NEED IN AND.
WAS IT AND SEES IT AND
UNDERSTANDS AND UNDERSTANDS THE
STRUGGLE THEN.
IT'S MUCH WORSE FOR THOSE WHO
AREN'T PRIVILEGED.
ON IN THERE AND WE CAN DO MORE.
THANK YOU I THINK.
THANK YOU MISSED AN ITEM FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I WOULD
ASK A SIMILAR TO THE LAST ISSUE.
THAT YOU WORK WITH OUR COMMITTEE
STAFF TO SEE IF THIS IS A
POTENTIAL USE OF PROP FIFTY SIX.
FUNDS AND WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
ISSUE NINE OPEN. I'M GOING TO
DINNER WITH YOU LATER TONIGHT IF
YOU.
MANY BOND ISSUE TEN
.
GOOD EVENING I'M MICHAEL DAY
WITH CHILDREN NOW REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HEALTH
COVERAGE COALITION AND SEVERAL
WRAPPED THE PARTNERS.
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY TO TALK
ABOUT PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX AND
AN OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST IN
CHILDREN'S HEALTH. IN MEDI CAL.
WITH AVAILABILITY OF MILLIONS
OF OF DOLLARS OF ADDITIONAL PROP
FIFTY SIX FUNDS AND BUILDING ON
THE DEPARTMENT'S CURRENT
APPROACH TO THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS. WE PUT FORTH A
TARGETED CHILDREN'S HEALTH
INVESTMENT APPROACH TO IT
ADDRESS ACCESS ISSUES AFFECTING
CHILDREN IN THREE AREAS TO WHICH
HAVE ALREADY BEEN HURT BY THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. TO JUST QUICKLY TO
RECAP.
THE THREE DISTINCT COMPONENTS
ARE FIRST WE RECOMMEND USING A
PORTION OF THE PROP FIFTY SIX
FUNDS UP FOR TARGETED
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT RATE
INCREASES. IN PEDIATRIC
PREVENTIVE SERVICES WHICH MAKE
UP THE VAST MAJORITY OF SERVICES
THAT MOST KIDS NEED. AND THESE
ARE THINGS LIKE WELL CHILD
VISITS DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENINGS
AND OTHER SERVICES A RECOMMENDED
BY THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS.
THIS ITEM WAS HEARD AT THE MARCH
FIFTH SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING.
SECOND OH WE RECOMMEND USING A
PORTION THE PROP FIFTY SIX FUNDS
TO A TARGET SUPPLEMENTAL DENTAL
RATE INCREASES THINGS LIKE
FLUORIDE VARNISH APPLICATION.
ARM AND REMOVAL OF ORTHODOX A
PERFORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND THIS
WAS HEARD JUST LAST WEEK ON
APRIL THIRTIETH.
AND THEN FINALLY WE RECOMMEND
USING A PORTION.
OF THE PROP FIFTY SIX FUNDS FOR
MODEST INCREASE TO THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S SERVICES
CCS RATE OF TEN PERCENT UPPER
OUTPATIENT POSITION SERVICES AND
MY COLLEAGUE WILL SAY MORE ABOUT
THAT.
I AARON KELLY WITH THE ABOUT
CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
BUDGET REQUEST.
OUR MISSION IS TO ENSURE ACCESS
TO QUALITY AND TIMELY CARE FOR
CHILDREN WITH COMPLEX HEALTH
CARE NEEDS.
IT IS WELL DOCUMENTED IN MANY
SURVEYS AND REPORTS INCLUDING
CSE SIS MEMBER ACCESS SURVEY
THAT FAMILIES CONTINUE TO FACE
CHALLENGES ACCESSING SPECIALTY
CARE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
TIMELY ACCESS TO PEDIATRIC
SPECIALTY AND SUB SPECIALTY
PROVIDERS IS ESSENTIAL.
DELAYS IN CARE COULD NOT ONLY
RESULT IN POOR OUTCOMES BUT ALSO
GREATER COST TO THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM AS A WHOLE.
THE DEMAND FOR PEDIATRIC
SPECIALTY CARE SERVICES IS ALSO
ON THE RISE WHICH CHILDREN WITH
MEDICAL COMPLEXITY LIVING
LONGER.
AND AN INCREASING NUMBER OF
CHILDREN DIAGNOSED WITH
CONDITIONS LIKE DIABETES.
DEPENDING ON THE REGION ANYWHERE
FROM FIFTY PERCENT UP TO EIGHTY
PERCENT OF PEDIATRIC SPECIALTY
CARE MEDICAL GROUPS.
PATIENTS ARE ON MEDI CAL WITH
MANY AND ROLLED IN THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S SERVICES
PROGRAM WHICH IS STILL LARGELY A
FEE FOR SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM
IN THE STATE.
THERE ARE A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
NINE THOUSAND CHILDREN ENROLLED
IN CCS
THESE CHILDREN HAVE LIFE
THREATENING COMPLEX AND CHRONIC
DISEASES WHERE ACCESS TO CARE IS
PARTICULARLY VITAL.
AS MY COLLEAGUE MISTER A DAY
NOTED IN HIS REMARKS WE PROPOSE
USING PROP FIFTY SIX FUNDING TO
PROVIDE A MEANINGFUL AND
TARGETED INCREASE OF TEN PERCENT
TO THE CCS RATE FOR OUTPATIENT
POSITION SERVICES.
THERE'S NOT BEEN AN INCREASE IN
THE CCS RATE FOR NEARLY TWO
DECADES THAT WOULD BRING RATES
CLOSER TO MEDICARE AND MOST
NOTABLY HELPED PEDIATRIC
SPECIALTY MEDICAL GROUPS RECRUIT
QUALIFIED PHYSICIANS. VETERAN
SHORT SUPPLY AS WELL AS RETAIN
TOP TALENT.
STAY AND PRACTICE HERE IN OUR
GOLDEN STATE.
LASTLY THIS FUNDING WILL NOT
ONLY BENEFIT CHILDREN IN CCS BUT
WILL BENEFIT ALL CHILDREN IN
FAMILIES THAT ARE IN NEED OF
SPECIALTY CARE.
I WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND THANK YOU AGAIN.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
A MERE MORE.
DEAR MARTIN HERE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE WE ACTUALLY SUPPORT
OF ALL THREE COMPONENTS OF IT. A
BUT JUST ONE EMPHASIZE THAT
PREVENTIVE CARE IS NOT JUST
ABOUT PRIMARY CARE IT'S ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT WHEN KIDS LEAVE
THE HOSPITAL. AND THEY HAVE
COMPLEX MEDICAL CONDITIONS THAT
CAN GET IN TO SEE THE SPECIALIST
OTHERWISE THEY JUST END UP BACK
IN OUR ER'S THAN BACK IN OUR
ROOMS AND WE'D MUCH RATHER HAVE
THAT NOT HAPPEN SO WE'RE PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY. INHUMAN.
ON THE HOUSE ABOUT WITH UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL THE COMMAND.
WHICH ALSO PREVENTS HE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OWN
LOOKING BACK IN THE TWO THOUSAND
AND SIXTEEN ELECTION ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT.
WAS PROMISED UNDER PROP FIFTY
SIX WAS AT AN IMPROVEMENT IN
CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND WE THINK
THAT ALL THREE.
COMPONENTS OF THIS PROPOSAL ARE
REALLY CRITICAL TO ENSURING THAT
CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS TO THE.
CRITICAL SERVICES THEY NEED
THANK YOU THINK YOU.
HI KRISTIN GOLDEN TEST WITH THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GIVE.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUED I'LL BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS.
SEEING NO COMMENTS I JUST HAVE
ONE QUESTION.
A TEN PERCENT INCREASE IS THERE
A DOLLAR AMOUNT THAT WERE
LOOKING OUT FOR A GIVEN YEAR DO
WE HAVE ANY.
APPROXIMATIONS FOR WHAT THAT
ROAD EQUATES TO.
NO NOT CURRENTLY BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND FINANCE ON THAT
HOT AND WE A CERTAIN REPORT BACK
TO TO COMMITTEE STAFF GRID.
WITH THAT WILL HOLD ISSUE TEN
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE ELEVEN
THANK YOU. IF YOU
.
ISSUE ELEVEN.
I.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS ANA
ACTON THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
MANY MISS ON ACT AND I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FREED WERE AN
AGING AND DISABILITY RESOURCE
CENTER. YOU'VE PROBABLY AWARE OF
THE STATE AUDITOR.
JUST RELEASED A REPORT ON THE
CALIFORNIA SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. SHOWING CHALLENGES
WERE CAUGHT QUALITY OF CARE AND
OVERSIGHT.
NOW MORE THAN EVER IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE HOW THE
OPTION TO LIVE IN THE COMMUNITY.
I'M HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF THE BUDGET REQUEST FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY TRANSITION
OR CCT WHICH HELPS INDIVIDUALS
TRANSITION FROM LONG TERM.
INSTITUTIONAL SETTINGS BACK INTO
COMMUNITY LIVING. THE FUNDING
FOR THIS CRITICAL PROGRAM IS
PHASING OUT AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
AND THE STATE HAS NOT PROPOSED
ITS CONTINUATION BEYOND THIS
CALENDAR YEAR. WE'RE ASKING FOR
THE STATE TO CONTINUE FUNDING
CCT AT NINETEEN POINT ONE
MILLION AN ON GOING GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS. TO REFLECT BOTH THE
STATE CONTRIBUTIONS AND THE
DISCONTINUED FEDERAL FUNDS
THE UP FRONT INVESTMENT IS
ESTIMATED TO RESULT IN A TOTAL
SAVINGS OF APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA CCT HELPS
INDIVIDUALS WHO DESIRE TO LIVE
IN THE COMMUNITY BUT WHO ARE
CONFINED TO INSTITUTIONAL
SETTINGS AND WHO OTHERWISE WOULD
NOT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RETURN TO THE COMMUNITY. TAKE
FOR EXAMPLE KATIE
WHO LOS EVERYTHING AFTER AN
ACCIDENT BEFORE SHE FOUND CCT
SHE HAD NO HOPE OF LIVING
OUTSIDE AND NURSING HOME.
CTT MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR HER TO
APPLY FOR AND SECURE AN
APARTMENT PURCHASE HOUSEHOLD
ITEMS MAKE HOME MODIFICATIONS.
INCREASE INDEPENDENCE THE RECESS
OF TECHNOLOGY AND SUPPLY THE
SUPPORT TO HELP HER PUT TOGETHER
CARE TEAM AND SECURE THE ONGOING
SUPPORT SHE NEEDS TO LIVE SAFELY
IN THE COMMUNITY.
FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS SHE NOW
LIVES INDEPENDENTLY AND
CONTRIBUTES TO OUR COMMUNITY
ASSESS THAT BOTH ON THE STATE
AND LOCAL.
YES WITH EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS.
SILICATES A TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY SUPPORT GROUP MENTORS
YOUTH AND IS ENGAGED WITH A
CHURCH.
AS YOU CAN SEE FROM KITTY STORY
CCT TRANSITION TEAMS WORK WITH
INDIVIDUALS THAT THE BALLOT.
SAFE TRANSITION PLAN THAT
IDENTIFIES AND CONNECT THEM WITH
THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS NECESSARY. FOR
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION THERE IS
NO OTHER PROGRAM OR SERVICE LIKE
THIS.
THIS PROGRAM IS BOTH COST
EFFECTIVE AND IN LINE WITH THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO UPHOLD THE US
SUPREME COURT'S OLMSTEAD
DECISION WHICH FOUND THAT UNDER
THE ADA INDIVIDUALS HAVE THE
RIGHT TO LIVE AND THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE SETTING.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT THE
CCT PROGRAM HAS HELPED OVER
THIRTY FIVE INDIVIDUALS LIKE
KATIE MOVE FROM INSTITUTIONAL
SETTINGS THAT THE COMMUNITY.
THESE TRANSITIONS RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS THE STATE
AVERAGING SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER PARTICIPANT PER YEAR.
UNFORTUNATELY AT THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IS PLANNING
ON PHASING OUT THIS VALUABLE
PROGRAM.
THE STATE INDICATES THAT THE
TRANSITION SERVICES CAN
CONTINUE.
UNDER THE HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED ALTERNATIVES WAIVER. YET
THIS DOESN'T COMPORT AS THE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS AND
SERVICES OFFERED UNDER THE
WAIVER PROGRAM ARE DIFFERENT AND
THE TRANSITION COSTS ARE NOT
REIMBURSED.
WITHOUT FUNDING DESIGNATED
SPECIFICALLY FOR CTT PROGRAMS
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS LIKE KATIE MOVE OUT
OF INSTITUTIONAL SETTINGS.
SO FINALLY IMAGINE FOR A MOMENT.
THAT BY CIRCUMSTANCE OR THAT
YOU'RE AGING INTO AN
INSTITUTION.
SITUATION A YEAR AGING INTO A
SITUATION WHERE YOU NO LONGER
COULD CHOOSE WHEN YOU EAT WHAT
YOU E..
WHEN YOU SHOWERED WHEN YOU USE
THE BATHROOM OR EVEN WHAT
TELEVISION SHOW YOU WATCHED AND
THAT YOU WERE SHARING A ROOM
WHICH IS NOW YOUR HOME WITH
SOMEONE YOU NEVER KNEW AND
IMAGINE THIS COST YOUR STATE
MILLIONS MORE DOLLARS THAN DOING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT. AND BETTER
LIKE CCT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND AYE
ABBOTT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
BUT WE HAVE ONE COMMENT BEFORE
WE TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT A WE HAD
A QUESTION ON THE STAFF COMMENT
SECTION FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WHETHER
DIPLOMATIC AS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WITH
RESPECT TO THE SAVINGS ATTHE
NET SAVINGS TO THE STATE WERE
STILL EVALUATING THIS COMPONENT
AND WILL FOLLOW UP WITH THEIR
STAFF.
WHEN THAT IS AVAILABLE CREEK
THANK YOU. WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE ELEVEN HI MY
NAME IS KATIE AM I JUST WANTED
TO.
LET IT BE KNOWN THAT I WAS
THIRTY FOUR YEARS OLD AT THE
TIME OF MY ACCIDENT IT WAS THAT
GENERAL ACCIDENT NOTHING IN THAT
AT BALL. I WAS PLACED INTO A
FACILITY. LAUGHED PARALYZED
COMPLETELY HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR
THE CCT PROGRAM TO GIVE ME A
CHANCE TO GET OUT I WOULD HAVE
BEEN LEFT COMPLETELY PARALYZED.
UPON THREE MONTHS AFTER COMING
HOME I STARTED INTENSIVE
PHYSICAL THERAPY THAT FACILITY
WOULD NOT PROVIDE IT.
I STARTED FOUR DAYS A WEEK AND
WITHIN THREE MONTHS I WAS ABLE
TO STAND UP I AM NOW USING A
PLATFORM WALKER. AT FOR THE
MAJORITY OF MY JOAQUIN AND A
WHEELCHAIR JUSTICE THAT
CAUTIONARY THING THIS WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN AN OPTION HAD I BEEN
LEFT I WAS LEFT IN THE BED.
UNATTENDED WITH NO PHYSICAL
THERAPY THEY CHARGED MY
INSURANCE FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
A MONTH
I HAVE MY OWN APARTMENT MY OWN
CARE GIVERS AND. IT'S NINE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH
WITH THIS PROGRAM I WAS ABLE TO
COME HOME AND.
BE A NORMAL HUMAN BEING AGAIN AT
AT MY AGE.
EVEN AT YOUR AGE YOU CAN NEVER
MATCH AND WHAT IT WAS LIKE MY
FORMER CAREER WAS ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND EMERGENCY
MEDICAL I NEVER IMAGINED THAT
THIS WOULD BE THE ASIDE THAT I
WOULD HAVE BEEN ON. BUT HAD IT
NOT BEEN FOR THIS PROGRAM I
STILL WOULD HAVE BEEN ENOUGH
FACILITY AND NOT KNOWING I WAS
ABLE TO WALK I CAN EVEN LEFT MY
HANDS IN MY ARMS.
ORIGINALLY DIAGNOSED WITH NO NO
PARENT NO FUTURE OF JOAQUIN ARE
USING YOUR ARMS.
ALL IT TOOK WAS GUIDE AND FOR
SOMEBODY THE ELSE THAT HELP THEM
BELIEVE IN ME.
THANK YOU I HOPE YOU REALLY
CONSIDER THIS PROGRAM THANK YOU
MA'AM.
A FAIR.
WONDERFUL WONDERFUL TESTIFY OR
THANK YOU DE ON AARON ON BEHALF
OF EAST BAY INNOVATIONS WERE ONE
OF THE COMMUNITY BASED COMPOUND
PROVIDERS THAT DOES CCT IN OUR
OWN COMMUNITY. I WANTED TO
CORRECT ONE THING THAT ON A SAID
IT WAS AROUND THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE HAVE BEEN PLACED
THROUGH CCT NOT THIRTY FIVE.
WE'VE PLACE HUNDREDS OURSELVES
IN THE EAST BAY WHAT'S BEEN
AMAZING ABOUT THIS IS THAT THE
INTEREST IN OUR COMMUNITY NOW
HAS GROWN SO SIGNIFICANTLY THAT
WE ARE WORKING WITH A VARIETY OF
DEVELOPERS. WHO ARE NOW SHOWING
AN INTEREST IN PROVIDING
APARTMENTS TO PEOPLE UP THROUGH
CCT RIGHT AND FORMING THESE
KINDS OF PARTNERSHIPS WHICH HAS
TAKEN YEARS TO DEVELOP? IT WOULD
BE A SHAME NOW TO TERMINATE THIS
PROGRAM NOW THAT WE'VE GOT
DEVELOPERS AND BUILDERS
INTERESTED IN PROVIDING THE KIND
OF APARTMENTS AND LIVING SPACES
THAT.
PARTICIPANTS CAN PARTICIPATE
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES
AS WELL AS AND SENIORS ARM WHO
ARE INAPPROPRIATELY PLACED IN
NURSING HOMES.
AND IT'S AT THE COST SAVINGS OF
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR
PER PATIENT THIS IS A DEAL
EVERYBODY WHY WOULD WE PASS IT
UP BANKS THANK YOU.
HELLO AKSHARA CUT SIGN AM BEHALF
OF STATE INDEPENDENT LIVING
COUNCIL.
O. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL NOT ONLY BECAUSE.
IT BENEFITS CONSUMERS LIKE
KATIE AND MANY OTHERS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. YOU YOUNG
ADULTS ARE YOUNG PEOPLE OLDER
ADULTS.
AND EVERYONE IN BETWEEN HOME OUR
DEPARTMENT SUPPORTS TWENTY EIGHT
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
ACROSS THE STATE WHICH PROVIDE
THESE TYPES OF SERVICES ALREADY.
HOME WITH HIM WITHOUT THE HELP
OF THE SIXTY PROGRAM BUT.
THERE'S A DEFINITE CONCRETE COST
BENEFIT TO THIS PROGRAM SO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE CONTINUANCE
OF LOS.
THE HUMAN.
HI MY NAME IS PATTY GRABS WITH
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTER OF
KERN COUNTY FROM BAKERSFIELD AND
I'M A CCT COORDINATOR AND I
STRONGLY OF.
HOUSE THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM.
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WHERE ONE OF THE
SPONSORS OF THIS PROPOSAL AND
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE UNIQUE
TIMES THAT WE ACTUALLY GET TO
SEE. IN THE ESTIMATES PAGES THE
SAVINGS THAT THIS PROGRAM
PRODUCES AND HAS PRODUCED A OVER
THE YEARS SO THE NUMBERS THAT
YOU'VE SEEN IN THE.
ANALYSIS BY THE.
COMMITTEE STAFF REFLECT THOSE
THAT HAVE BEEN IN THE ESTIMATES
PAGES WHAT IS CRITICAL I THINK
FOR THIS PROGRAM IS THAT. THE
THE PROGRAM DOESN'T ACTUALLY THE
FEDERAL FUNDING DOES NOT EXPIRE
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY BUT WHAT THE
THE SERVICES ARE PROVIDED OVER A
COURSE OF A YEAR ONCE
INDIVIDUALS ARE IN THE PROGRAM.
SO THEY'RE STARTING THE GLIDE
PATH OUT WHICH WOULD BE IN THE
CALENDAR YEAR.
IT AT THE END OF THE CALENDAR
YEAR SO IT'S A CRUCIAL TO KEEP
THE STRUCTURE IN PLACE AND THERE
IS SOME HOPE THAT THIS IS A
PROGRAM THROUGH THE EMPOWER ACT
THAT WILL GET RE AUTHORIZED BY
CONGRESS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO MY
COMMENTS IN THAT COMMENCEMENT
OTHER FOLKS HAVE SPOKEN BEHIND
ME AYE MY NAME'S JIMMY SOTO I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. FOR THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTER KERN
COUNTY HAVE ACTUALLY STARTED
THIS PROGRAM AND FRESNO.
HAVE BACK IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
IN NINETY STARTED THE SAME
PROGRAM IN BAKERSFIELD ABOUT
FOUR YEARS AGO BUT. I CAN TELL
YOU THAT THIS IS A VERY VERY
POWERFUL PROGRAM THAT I THINK
EVERYBODY WHETHER YOU'RE IN THIS
FIELD ARE NOT WOULD UNDERSTAND.
AND IT'S WHEN YOU SEE A PERSON
LIKE KATIE GET OUT OF A NURSING
HOME AND GOING TO THE HER HER
OWN APARTMENT.
AND THEY HAVE TEARS IN THEIR
EYES TELLING YOU. THINKING YOU.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO DIE
IN THAT NURSING HOME AND I
THINK.
THOSE TYPES OF EXPERIENCES GET
ME MOTIVATED A LOT THERE A LOT
OF OTHER FOLKS ARE MOTIVATED.
IT'S ALSO A WIN WIN JUST LIKE
WHAT KURT SAID IT'S IT'S IT'S
IT'S GONNA SAVE TAXPAYER DOLLARS
AND AYE IF YOU DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THESE PEOPLE
ARE I'M MEDI CAL.
SO IF THEY'RE IN THE NURSING
HOME. EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM WAS
PAYING FOR THEM TO STAY IN THAT
ROOM.
AND OF COURSE THE BIGGEST
REASONS FOR GETTING PEOPLE
DISABILITIES AND SENIORS OUT OF
NURSING HOMES TITUS ASSET YOU.
REALLY CONSIDER THAT THE WIN WIN
SOLUTION ON THIS THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND I THINK YOU CAN FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SIR.
I WORK.
MY NEXT CALIFORNIA'S DISABILITY
RIGHTS SHE DID A GREAT JOB SHE
UNDERSTANDS THAT THE PRACTICE
THAT.
INDEPENDENCE IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO OUR CLIENTS VERY IMPORTANT TO
OUR MEMBERS WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO
THAT.
BENEFITTED FROM THIS PROGRAM AND
IT'S ALSO FROM MENTAL HEALTH
EFFECTS OF PHYSICAL ALL KNOWING
THAT YOU CAN LIVE ON YOUR OWN.
BE INDEPENDENT.
AND
SELF SUFFICIENT VERY WORKED WITH
ABOUT AND BACK TO TO FINANCE.
INDEPENDENT SELF SUFFICIENT
PEOPLE COST STATE A LOT LESS
MONEY.
INK ABOUT THAT.
THE OFFICER.
HI I'M VALERIE SHARP WITH FREED
AND I HOPE YOU SUPPORT THIS
PROGRAM AND GIVE PEOPLE A CHOICE
CAN SAVE THE STATE MONEY.
KIM.
I WAS WITH MASON A CCT
COORDINATOR AT RESOURCES FOR
INDEPENDENT CENTRAL VALLEY AND
FRESNO AND I HOPE YOU SUPPORT
THIS ITEM RESTORING DIGNITY AND
CHOICE FOR. A LOT OF PEOPLE RAY
OF HOPE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM.
HI SAVANNAH AT ARMS OF THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTER OF
KERN COUNTY AND FULL SUPPORT.
THE COMMAND.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHARITY TOOK
CASH ON THE SYSTEMS CHANGE
AVOCAT RESOURCES FOR INDEPENDENT
CENTRAL VALLEY. AND WE ARE VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THE THANK
YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT
A COMMAND.
LISA COLEMAN WITH A CALIFORNIA
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
ASSOCIATION WHATEVER HALLMARKS
IS OUT VOTE THE ABILITY TO LIVE
IN THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT. WE PARTNER WITH
THIS CCT AND WE BELIEVE THAT.
THERE ARE OF GREAT VALUE AND WE
HELP YOU SUPPORT TO ASK.
WELCOME.
HI I'M LYNETTE DRAWS ON KATIE
WILL OF SMALL SPEAK TO YOU GUYS.
THANK YOU MA'AM AND HOW PROUD
YOU MUST BE THAT SHE'S SUCH A
WONDERFUL ADVOCATE.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE ELEVEN I'LL BRING IT UP
TO THE DYESS FOR ANY COMMENTS WE
MAY HAVE.
.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN BUT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY IN YOUR VOICE HERE ON
THIS ISSUE IS QUITE IMPORTANT.
WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE TWELFTH I THINK.
YOU KNOW.
YEAH.
I DON'T THINK I.
NOT.
REPUBLICAN.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS DOCTOR
FLOWS ON CO FURTHER AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF STATE POLICY AND
RESEARCH FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES.
IN. ON TWENTY SEVENTEEN THIS.
DESPITE THE ACTUALLY APPROVED
THE DIABETES PREVENTION PROGRAM
WHICH IS A PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
PREVENTIVE SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
WHO HAVE PRE DIABETES WHICH IS A
RISK FACTOR FOR DIABETES.
SINCE THE TIME THAT THAT WAS
APPROVED OF THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND THAT'S MATCHED WITH
FUNDS FROM CMS.
AND SINCE THAT TIME ON THERE HAS
BEEN A COALITION WHICH WAS
CONVENED TO DISCUSS THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND PREPARE THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES.
AS WELL AS.
THROUGH THE PUBLIC FOCUS
SERVICES TO THINK ABOUT WHAT IS
NECESSARY FOR PROPER
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM.
IN THE PROCESS OF DOING THAT WE
DETERMINED THAT THERE WERE
SEVERAL THINGS THAT WOULD HELP
THE PROGRAM BE IMPLEMENTED
APPROPRIATELY.
THE FIRST OF WHICH IS ADDRESSING
BE LINGUISTIC REQUIREMENTS FOR
MEDICAID AND FOR MEDI CAL TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE PROGRAM
AVAILABLE AT ALL OF THE
THRESHOLD LANGUAGES. THEIR
THIRTEEN THRESHOLD LANGUAGES IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE CURRENT
CURRICULUM IS ONLY AVAILABLE
INTO ENGLISH AND SPANISH.
AND SO IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT SERVICES ARE AVAILABLE TO
EVERYONE AND THAT THEIR
STANDARDIZED IN A WAY THAT MAKES
SENSE.
AND THAT WAS NOT DUPLICATIVE WE
ARE REQUESTING FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO
TRANSLATE THE OTHER INTO THE
OTHER ELEVEN LANGUAGES.
THIS WOULD ALLOW FOR EVERYONE
WHO IS IMPLEMENTING THE DIABETES
PREVENTION PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO A
STANDARDIZED CURRICULUM THAT HAS
BEEN APPROVED TRANSLATION.
IN ADDITION WE ALSO FOUND TWO
FIXES THAT NEEDED TO TAKE PLACE
IN HOME IN THE CURRENT
LEGISLATION ONE IS AROUND.
THE FIVE PERCENT WEIGHT LOSS
REQUIREMENT FOR ONGOING SERVICES
THE CDC HAS.
HEADS OF ROBUST AMOUNT OF DATA
SHOWING THAT WEIGHT LOSS AT
LOWER AMOUNTS LOWER THRESHOLDS
ON IS ACTUALLY ASSOCIATED WITH
SOME OF THE OUTCOMES WERE
INTERESTED IN INCLUDING
PREVENTING THE ONSET OF
DIABETES.
AND SO ON THEY ARE IN THE
PROCESS RIGHT NOW CONSIDERING
WHETHER A LOWER THRESHOLD WILL
ACTUALLY BE USED AND SO WE WOULD
RATHER RATHER THAN STATE.
A SPECIFIC THRESHOLD THE
BACKROOM MATCH OURSELVES WITH
WHAT THE CDC HAS AND SO WE ARE
ASKING THAT THAT BE TAKEN OUT OF
THE CURRENT.
WELFARE INSTITUTIONS CODE I'M
IN ADDITION WERE ALSO ASKING
THAT.
THE ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA THAT
ARE SPECIFICALLY STATED HARM IN
THE CURRENT LEGISLATION BE
REMOVED AS WELL BECAUSE THEY
DIFFER FROM THE CDC AND THAT
WOULD RENDER MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY ELIGIBLE FOR THE
PROGRAM BASED ON CDC STANDARDS.
THAT WOULD RENDER THEM ILL
INELIGIBLE AND THE GOAL OF THE
PROGRAM IS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE AS
MANY PEOPLE WHO HAVE PRE
DIABETES AS POSSIBLE
PARTICIPATE.
NOW FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT.
KIMBERLY CHANNEL BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
THAT WORK IN SUPPORT.
MARY VALDEZ HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEN NON BACK TO THE DICE.
I JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR THE
PROPOSAL IT'S QUITE WELL
RECEIVED.
WAS ECSTATIC WHEN WE AS A STATE
LAST YEAR WERE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
THIS AND.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU SHORTLY.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
ISSUE TWELVE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE THIRTEEN.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS ANA
HOUSE ABOUT WITH UNITED WAYS OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU TO THE
DOCTOR ARAMBULA MEMBERS AND
STAFF YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THE
INTEGRATION. OF HEALTH AND
EDUCATION OUTCOMES AND WELL
BEING OF CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
NOW MORE THAN EVER THE
COMMITMENT TO A SCHOOL CLIMATE
THAT RECOGNIZES HEALTH AS BEING
INTIMATELY LINKED TO LEARNING.
IS CRUCIAL TO THE SUCCESS OF
STUDENTS.
THAT IS WHY UNITED WAYS ALONG
WITH THE CHILDREN'S HEALTH
COVERAGE COALITION AND MANY
OTHERS ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE
BUDGET REQUEST FOR THE HEALTHY
START INITIATIVE. TO PROVIDE
PLANNING GRANTS TO LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES TO BETTER
COORDINATE THE ARRAY OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES THAT CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
AND NEED.
I'M GONNA FOCUS MY BRIEF
COMMENTS
ON THE ROLL THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES WOULD PLAY
WITHIN THE HEALTHY START
PROPOSAL. WE KNOW THAT A
COLLABORATION ACROSS THE ARRAY
OF SERVICES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
IS ONE OF THE CORNERSTONES OF
SUCCESS
AND THIS HOLDS TRUE AT THE STATE
LEVEL AS WELL WITH SO MANY
SERVICES AND FUNDING SOURCES NOW
FURTHER DEVOLVED. AND SILENT AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL THE LACK OF
COORDINATION MEANS CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES ARE FALLING THROUGH THE
GAPS AND THAT SHOULD BE
PREVENTED.
WHAT IS NEEDED?
IN THIS RE ENVISIONED HEALTHY
START IS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FROM THE H. CS ON HOW LOCAL
COLLABORATIVE'S CAN MOST
EFFICIENTLY LEVERAGE THE
VARIOUS.
VARIOUS HEALTH SERVICE STREAMS
AND EFFECTIVELY DRAWDOWN ON
MATCHING FEDERAL FUNDS LIKE LTA.
BILLING OPTION AND MA.
ADDITIONALLY THERE IS A PRESSING
NEED FOR DH CS TO WORK TOGETHER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
IN IMPLEMENTING SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH POLICY IN SERVICES.
HEALTHY START WOULD ESTABLISH
THIS INTER AGENCY COORDINATION
IN A TANGIBLE WAY THROUGH THE
VERY MODEST INVESTMENT AS LISTED
IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE AGENDA
TODAY.
PROMOTING CHILDREN'S HEALTH IS
HIGHLY COST EFFECTIVE FOR
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES FUND THE
COLLECTING IT MEANS SPIRALING
COSTS FOR HEALTHCARE AND SOCIAL
SERVICES.
A FOCUS ON PREVENTION AND
COLLABORATION TO ENSURE ADEQUATE
ACCESS TO SERVICES WHILE
AVOIDING DUPLICATING A
DUPLICATION OF THOSE SERVICES IS
A CORE TENANT OF HEALTH CARE
REFORM.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS ISSUE OF I WOULD NOTE
THAT WE ARE NOW WORKING ON THE
SENATE SIDE AND WILL BE HEARD IN
THE EDUCATION SUBCOMMITTEE. I
WILL BE WORKING WITH THE
EDUCATION SUBCOMMITTEE ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE AS WELL MOVING
FORWARD ON THIS PROPOSAL
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE MAJORITY
OF THE PROPOSAL WOULD BE.
AND THAT SORT OF FINANCIAL
JURISDICTION BUT APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME LISTENING TO THIS UP.
PROPOSAL TODAY THE THANK YOU ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT WHEN THE AT
TIMES RIGHT THANK YOU MA'AM.
BOB NOW FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE THIRTEEN.
HI I'M CHRIS SINGLETON TEST WITH
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
YOU CAN.
MY GOOD WITH CHILDREN AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
MICHELLE SOBRE MINSKY CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THE COMMAND.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS.
SEEING NO COMMENTS.
THE PROPOSAL IS WELL RECEIVED
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH YOU. TO HOLD ISSUE
THIRTEEN OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE FOURTEEN.
HELLO AGAIN. FEET HIGH I'M
CHRISTIAN GOLDEN TESTED WITH THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S HEALTH
COALITION.
OF CALIFORNIA WE WOULD PUT
FORWARD THIS PROPOSAL TO HELP
THEM CONTINUE THE RECEIVING.
VALUABLE DATA.
OF FINE CHILDREN'S HEALTH CARE
UTILIZATION AND HEALTH COVERAGE
IN CALIFORNIA. AS YOU KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH INTERVIEW
SURVEY OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CHESS
HAS BEEN A VALUABLE SOURCE OF
INFORMATION ON.
ALL SORTS OF ISSUES AROUND
HEALTH CARE AND HEALTH COVERAGE
NAMELY HOW MANY TO UNINSURED
CHILDREN HOW MANY UNINSURED
INDIVIDUALS THERE ARE IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN PARTICULAR. I
CAN GET TOWN TO DISTRICT LEVEL
AND SO MOST THE DATA YOU
PROBABLY HAVE ABOUT PEOPLE IN
YOUR COMMUNITY PROBABLY OF COME
FROM THE CHEST STATUS LAST SET.
NOW WHAT DUMB WE'VE HEARD FROM
THE RESEARCHERS IS THAT.
THEY ARE NOT GETTING ENOUGH
SAMPLES AND RESPONDERS ON
CHILDREN'S INFORMATION SO IF
UNLESS THEY MAKE SOME CHANGES
THEY WILL NO LONGER BE ABLE TO
REPORT. ON ANYTHING LESS AND
STATE LEVEL DATA.
ON THESE CHILDREN MEASURES AND
THIS IS OF COURSE REALLY
TROUBLING. AND THAT WE WON'T BE
ABLE TO GET SOME REALLY VALUABLE
INFORMATION SO THERE RIGHT NOW
DOING A LOT OF.
.
WORK ON TRYING TO CHANGE THEIR
METHODOLOGY SO AS TO GET MORE
RESPONDER STE ON I'VE FOR
CHILDREN'S INFORMATION SO AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE IT'S GETTING A CALL
ON THE PHONE. ABOUT A FORTY FIVE
MINUTE INTERVIEW ON YOUR HEALTH
INFORMATION THEN SAYING HAITI OF
ANOTHER FORTY FIVE MINUTES TO
ASK ABOUT YOUR CHILD. YOU CAN
SEE HOW A LOT OF PEOPLE MAY NOT
BE FOLLOWING THROUGH ON THAT
SECOND PART TO GET THE
INFORMATION ON THE CHILD SO
THEY'RE TRYING TO. LOOK AT
DIFFERENT WAYS OF DOING THIS
METHODOLOGY THEREIN AT STAGE ONE
OF IT RIGHT NOW WHICH THE
FOUNDATIONS HAVE SUPPORTED AND
PAID FOR AND STAGE TWO IS TO
WORK ON SOME OF THE OTHER
FEATURES FOR EXAMPLE THEY'RE
DOING AN ONLINE. AN INTERVIEW AS
A WAY TO ENCOURAGE MAYBE SOME
ADOLESCENTS TO RESPOND ON THEIR
OWN AND RIGHT NOW IT IS NOT IN A
SPANISH SO THEY'D LIKE TO MAKE
IT IN SPANISH AND THEY'RE ALSO
TESTING METHODOLOGICAL CHANGES
WHERE THEY MAY ASK FIRST ABOUT
THE CHILD RATHER THAN ABOUT. THE
ADULT TO CHILD UP THAT.
A RESPONSE ON THE CHILDREN'S
INFORMATION THIS BUDGET REQUEST
IS FOR SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND I'M DOLLARS IT'S ONE
TIME IT'S FOR. THAT SECOND PHASE
OF THEIR TESTING AND HOPEFULLY
THIS WILL BE THE TO BE RUN IN.
THE END OF THIS YEAR TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IN THE FALL
HOPEFULLY SO THAT WE COULD HAVE
A REALLY GOOD ROBUST TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN.
SURVEY WITH THE INFORMATION
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO
BE PROVIDED AT THE LOCAL AND.
NONCE AT THE LOWER LEVELS OTHER
THAN STATE LEVEL SO WE ASK FOR
YOUR STRONG SUPPORT.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE FOURTEEN.
ON A HASSLE BUT WITH UNITED WAYS
OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS PROPOSAL WE WOULD KNOW
THAT WITH NINETY SEVEN PERCENT
OF CHILDREN.
COVERED UNDER HEALTH INSURANCE
IN CALIFORNIA IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT WE KNOW WHAT THAT COVERAGE
LOOKS LIKE AND MEANS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS.
AND THAT THE THE DATA THAT WE
RECEIVE FROM THIS KIND OF SURVEY
UP ALLOWS US TO MAKE GOOD POLICY
DECISIONS HERE IN THIS BUILDING
THANK YOU THINK MEN.
MICHAEL DAY WITH CHILDREN NOW IN
STRONG SUPPORT I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
STATE IS TO REALLY UNDERSTANDING
CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND THEIR
COVERAGE. ARMS OF THINGS LIKE
ASTHMA WE WOULDN'T KNOW AT ADD
MORE GRANULAR LEVEL BESIDE THE
STATE LEVEL WITHOUT THE STATE
THANK YOU.
MICHELLE SOBRE VENTS HIS
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT THE
COMMAND.
KATIE LADEN CHILDREN SPECIALTY
CARE COALITION OFTEN SUPPORT.
COMMAND.
LUCY QUESTIONED OLIVER MATERNAL
AND CHILD HEALTH ACCESS IN
SUPPORT RECOMEND.
SINGLE FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE FOURTEEN I'LL BRING IT UP
TO THE DYESS FOR ANY COMMENTS WE
HAVE.
JUST WILL SAY THIS IS WELL
RECEIVED IN THE PART OF WORKING
WITH YOU HERE SHORTLY.
ISSUE FOURTEEN WILL BE HELD OPEN
AS WE MOVE ON TO ISSUE FIFTEEN.
GOOD EVENING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND MY NAME IS PAULA WILL HOME
I'M A SENIOR POLICY ANALYST
REPRESENTING THAT COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE MEDI CAL
ALCOHOL SCREENING BENEFIT TO
INCLUDE SCREENING FOR OPIATES
AND OTHER ILLICIT DRUGS.
SO AS I KNOW YOU'RE ALL WELL
AWARE WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
OPIATE CRISIS THAT CLAIMED THE
LIVES OF MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS AND TWENTY SIXTEEN.
AND TO FULLY CONFRONT THIS
CRISIS ONE OF THE THINGS WE NEED
TO DO IS IDENTIFY MORE PEOPLE
ACROSS THE STATE WHO ARE
MISUSING OPIOIDS AND CONNECT
THEM TO TREATMENT.
EXPANDING DRUG SCREENING IN MEDI
CAL PRIMARY CARE IS A LOW COST
BUT POTENTIALLY HIGH IMPACT
STRATEGY THAT CAN HELP MORE
PEOPLE ACCESS LIFESAVING CARE
FOR THEIR SUBSTANCE USE.
AND TO BRIEFLY SUMMARIZE WHAT
WOULD CHANGE UNDER THIS PROPOSAL
AND MEDI CAL PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS AT PRESENT. CAN SCREEN
ADULT BENEFICIARIES FOR A RANGE
OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS
INCLUDING ALCOHOL MISUSE AND IF
A CLIENT REPORTS ALCOHOL MISUSE
THE PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER CAN BE
REIMBURSED FOR ADMINISTERING
ADDITIONAL SCREENING TO ASSESS
ALCOHOL USE. AND FOR CONDUCTING
A BRIEF COUNSELING OR EDUCATION
SESSION AND THEN REFERRING THE
PERSON TO TREATMENT AS NEEDED.
RIGHT NOW PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS OR A MEDICAID MANAGED
CARE PLANS COULD CHOOSE TO
SCREEN CLIENTS FOR ILLICIT DRUG
USE TIME BUT IF A CLIENT WERE TO
DISCLOSE DRUG MISUSE THE PRIDE
PROVIDER CANNOT RECEIVE MEDICAL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR ANY FURTHER
TIME THEY SPEND. WITH THAT
PERSON ADDRESSING THEIR DRUG USE
SO UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S A
FINANCIAL DISINCENTIVE TO I'M
OFFER THE SCREENING IN THIS
CARE.
SO UNDER THIS PROPOSAL. A
MEDICAL PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS
WOULD CONDUCT ROUTINE DRUG
SCREENING ALONGSIDE THE ALCOHOL
SCREENING THAT THEY'RE ALREADY
OFFERINGAND THEY COULD THEN
RECEIVE REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE
EDUCATION COUNSELING AND
REFERRALS THAT THEY DELIVER FOR
DRUG MISUSE.
AND IDEALLY THIS JAMES WELL AND
SO SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUCCESSFULLY REFERRED FROM
PRIMARY CARE TWO SPECIALTIES
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT.
AND ON AT THAT AND DO YOU SEE US
HAS ESTIMATED THAT THIS EXPANDED
SCREENING FOR THE ADULT MEDICAL
POPULATION WOULD COST ABOUT
EIGHT POINT FOUR MILLION
ANNUALLY. BUT THAT'S ACTUALLY
ONLY TWO POINT FIVE EIGHT
MILLION IN STATE GENERAL FUNDS
THAT WOULD BE USED TO DRIVE DOWN
FIVE POINT EIGHT MILLION IN
FEDERAL FINANCIAL PARTICIPATION
UNDER MEDICAID.
SO WE WOULD UNDERSCORE THAT THIS
IS A RELATIVELY LOW COST
INTERVENTION IT CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED USING EXISTING
PROCEDURES AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND IT HAS A GREAT POTENTIAL TO
SAVE LIVES AND I'M AND EVEN SAVE
MONEY.
TO THE EXTENT THAT EXPANDED
SCREENING WILL HELP MORE PEOPLE
ACCESS TREATMENT AND COST
BENEFIT ANALYSES HAVE REPEATEDLY
SHOWN THAT AS YOU DO TREATMENT.
CAN REDUCE EXPENDITURES ON OTHER
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND ON DRUG
RELATED CRIMINAL JUSTICE COSTS.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT THIS MODEL
OF SCREENING BRIEF INTERVENTION
AND REFERRAL TO TREATMENT. IS
ASSOCIATED WITH AND REDUCTIONS
IN A PERSON SUBSTANCE USE OVER
TIME.
SO TO CONCLUDE EXPANDING DRUG
SCREENING IN PRIMARY CARE
SETTINGS IS JUST ONE MORE
CRITICAL TO ALL THAT WE CAN ADD
TO OUR TOOLBOX TO ADDRESS THE
OPIATE CRISIS.
A A NUMBER OF OTHER STATES
INCLUDING OUR NORTHERN NEIGHBOR
OR AGAIN ANDS AND THE VERY
POPULOUS NEW YORK STATE ARE
ALREADY OFFERING.
ROUTINE DRUG SCREENING TO ALL
MEDICAID BENEFICIARIES
AND CALIFORNIA'S SHOULD BE DOING
THIS AS WELL SO. AND WE REALLY
COMMEND THE STAY IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR A NUMBER OF
OTHER INITIATIVES WE'VE
COLLECTIVELY UNDERTAKEN TO
ADDRESS THE OPIATE CRISIS. WE
REALLY HOPE YOU'LL APPROPRIATE
THESE FUNDS TO IMPROVE SCREENING
AND REFERRALS AS WELL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
WE WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE FIFTEEN.
SEEING NOT ALL BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS.
I'D FEEL INCLINED TO ASK WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IN YOUR SCENARIO
WITH THE PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR
WHO.
HAD A PATIENT WHO DID ADMIT TO
SUBSTANCE USE.
WHAT RECOURSE IS TO THEY
CURRENTLY HAVE AND WHAT HAPPENS
TO THOSE PATIENTS
YEAH?
I'M.
SO YOU KNOW THE IDEAS THAT THEY
WERE COULD DO THE SAME THING FOR
A CLIENT TO DISCLOSE A SUBSTANCE
USE AS THEY DO FOR ALCOHOL USE
WHICH IS OFFER THEM. KIND OF
ADDITIONAL SCREENING TO ASSESS
THE PROBLEM AND THEN CONDUCT A
BRIEF INTERVENTION WHICH IS YOU
KNOW COUNSELING OR EDUCATION
DEPENDING ON AND. THE NATURE OF
THE USE THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
AND AND CULMINATING IN A
REFERRAL TO TREATMENT. AND AND
THE KICKER NOW IS THAT IF THEY
DO THIS THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
REIMBURSED AND IF IT'S DRUG USE
RATHER THAN ALCOHOL THEY'RE NOT
GONNA BE REIMBURSED FOR THAT
THROUGH ON MEDI CAL SO THEY. YOU
KNOW WE BELIEVE SOME PEOPLE ARE
DOING IT BUT THEY'RE COVERING
THOSE COSTS IN ANOTHER WAY.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
FIFTEEN OPEN AND THANK YOU FOR.
THINKING OF.
ISSUE SIXTEEN.
PLEADING CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE MY
NAME IS SAM HOLLISTER AND I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR VISION TO
LEARNING. REASON TO LEARN ISN'T
MOBILE A NONPROFIT MOBILE VISION
PROVIDER WE CURRENTLY HAVE
ELEVEN MOBILE VISION CLINICS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT PROVIDE FREE
EXAMS IN CLASSES TO KIDS IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES.
VISION TO LEARN WAS FOUNDED SIX
YEARS AGO WHERE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP AND WE'VE PROVIDED
OVER NINETY SIX THOUSAND AYE
EXAMS AND SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND
PAIRS OF GLASSES THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. IN K. THROUGH TWELVE
IN THREE THOUSAND SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA.
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND AND THIRTY
FIVE OF THOSE EXAMS AND FIFTY
EIGHT THOUSAND AND TWENTY ONE OF
THOSE PAIRS OF GLASSES HAVE BEEN
THE KIDS IN LA COUNTY.
VISION TO LEARN DOCTORS AND
CLINICS GO WHERE KIDS ARE ALL
DAY EVERY DAY.
AT SCHOOLS
WE HELP EVERY CHILD REGARDLESS
OF CITIZENSHIP OR INSURANCE
STATUS.
ACCORDING TO A JOURNAL OF PUBLIC
HEALTH STUDY NINETY FIVE PERCENT
OF FIRST GRADERS IN CALIFORNIA
IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES DON'T
HAVE THE CLASSES THEY NEED TO
SEE THE BORG.
OUR OWN SAMPLE OF OVER NINETY
THOUSAND SIX THOUSAND KIDS IN
THE STATE HAS FOUND THAT TWO
THIRDS OF THEM WHO GOT CLASSES
FROM VISION AND LEARN. NEVER HAD
GLASSES BEFORE.
ANOTHER TWENTY THREE PERCENT OF
THOSE CHILDREN HAD CLASSES WITH
INCORRECT PRESCRIPTION.
IN OTHER WORDS EIGHTY NINE
PERCENT OF THE STUDENTS THAT WE
PROVIDE THE GLASSES TO DID NOT
HAVE A WORKING PARENT CLASSES.
A UCLA MATTEL CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL STUDY OF LA UNIFIED
SCHOOL KIDS HELP BY VISION TO
LEARN.
SHOWED THAT GRADES IMPROVED IN
JUST A YEAR IN FACT AMONG THIRD
GRADE BOYS MATH SCORES WENT UP
NEARLY TEN PERCENT.
THAT SEEMS STUDY FOUND THAT
NINETY POOP PERCENT OF TEACHERS
FELT THAT MOST CHILDREN IN THEIR
SCHOOLS WOULD HAVE NOT HAD
ACCESS TO CLASSES WITHOUT VISION
TO LEARN.
VISION TO LEARN SIR CURRENTLY
SERVES LA COUNTY THE EIGHT BAY
AREA COUNTIES IN SACRAMENTO.
THIS APPROPRIATION WILL ALLOW US
TO EXPAND OUR SERVICES NAY
STATEWIDE WHILE THE DEPARTMENT
CONTINUES TO WORK WITH US TO
IDENTIFY A LONG TERM OPTION FOR
MEDI CAL REIMBURSEMENT.
THE DEPARTMENT IS CURRENTLY
LEANING TOWARDS THE ALLEY A
FUNDING BACK IS AN ISM AS A
SOLUTION AND WE ARE OPENING WE
ARE OPEN TO UNDERSTANDING THAT
OPTION.
IT'S NOT ONE WE KNOW SINCE AND
OTHER STATE THREE SEWER WE SERVE
REESE RECEIVE MEDICAID
REIMBURSEMENT WE UNDERSTAND THAT
CALIFORNIA'S MORE COMPLEX AND WE
TRULY APPRECIATE THE
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS IN THIS
AREA.
THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM.
WE WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE SIXTEEN.
BUT IT ONE REPRESENT CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL NURSES ORGANIZATION.
OSCAR WINNERS EVER WORKED VERY
CLOSELY WITH VISION TO LEARN AND
IN MANY CASES IF IT WERE NOT FOR
THEM TO BE THERE TO DO THE
FOLLOW UP SCREENING. AND TO
PROVIDE THE GLASSES MOSQUE
CHILDREN WOULD GO WITHOUT.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
FEEL PALE SERBS AND HEALTH NET.
WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT WITH
VISION LEARN DOWN IN THE LA
COUNTY PILOT AREA VERY HAPPY
WITH THE RESULTS WE THINK
OVERALL.
IT'S BEEN GOOD NOT ONLY FOR THE
PLAN BUT FOR SCHOOL CHILDREN OF
ALL AGES. ABLE TO AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF THE SERVICES OF
VISION TO LEARN FOR THOSE
REASONS WE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR ISSUE SIXTEEN OR BRING IT UP
TO THE DYESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS.
EACH ONE OF THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
.
I I HAVE A.
YOUNG ONE WHO IS STRUGGLING
WITH READING AT HOME AND WE
COULDN'T FIGURE OUT WHAT WAS
GOING ON WITH THEM OTHER THAN
HIS NICKNAME IS MOOSE.
ARE IT IT. A AND FINALLY DAD
WENT IN TO GET HIS.
AYE AYE ONE IN TO GIVE MY
READERS.
AND WE GOT HIM TESTED AS WELL
AND FOUND IT OUT THAT HE NEEDED
GLASSES TO USE.
.
HIS HIS READING WHAT FROM WAY
BEHIND GRADE LEVELS OF THREES
FINALLY CAUGHT UP SO IT IT'S
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN FOR EVERYBODY SO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISS HOLLISTER FOR
BRINGING THIS VERY. WELL THOUGHT
OUT PROPOSAL FORWARD AND.
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THAT WILL
HOLD ISSUE SIXTEEN OPEN. AND
WANT ISSUE SEVENTEEN.
HI I'M HELEN ROTH SELDON AYE
WITH TEACHERS FOR HEALTHY KIDS.
AND AND I HAVE SOME MUSIC TEARS
THIS IS A NO COST ITEM.
SO WHAT THIS IS IS IT'S A IT'S A
LANGUAGE REQUEST
AND WE HAVE ANOTHER PROPOSAL
THAT'S IN THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WHICH IS FOR START UP
FUNDS IT'S GOING TO BE HEARD.
SO WHAT THIS WOULD DO IS THAT
WOULD ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
TRANSFER AYE CAPTAIN OUT
ANNUALLY A FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
WHICH IS THREE TENTHS OF ONE
PERCENT OF THE AMOUNT THAT THEY
RECEIVED BACK FOR UP FROM
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT WHICH IS
AROUND A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE LAST YEAR BUT
IT'S BEEN GOING UP.
THEY RECEIVE BACK FOR HEALTH
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED IN
THE SCHOOLS THROUGH THE ALLEY A
BILLING OPTION PROGRAM.
SO THE PA COST PER SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS NINE HUNDRED THIRTY
THREE DOLLARS.
THERE'S RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO
CENTRAL LOCATION WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOR SCHOOL BASED
SERVICES.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
ALMOST EVERY STATE THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO TALK TO ACT PASSED
SO CALIFORNIA'S REALLY BEHIND IN
THIS.
I'M THERE ARE SINCE THESE FUNDS
ARE ACTUALLY IN STATUTE IN WHAT
I PASSED OUT HAS A COPY OF THE
LANGUAGE. A YOU HAVE TO CHANGE
THE STATUTE TO ALLOW THIS FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS AND TO
SET UP THE TRANSFER MECHANISM.
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WHICH IS WHAT THE LANGUAGE DOES.
AND I'M THE OTHER SUBCOMMITTEE
WILL BE HEARING THE ITEM OR I
THINK HAS ALREADY AGREED ON TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND AND
ONE TIME FUNDS. THAT FOR THIS
YEAR TO GET IT STARTED WITH THIS
IS ONGOING AND THERE WILL BE
OTHER FUNDS THAT WOULD ALSO BE
ABLE TO GO TO THIS OFFICE.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE WILLING TO
UNDERWRITE THIS.
IT'S NOT GENERAL FUND AND WE
JUST NEED THE MECHANISM FOR THE
TRANSFER.
OTHERWISE CD WOULD HAVE TO
INVOICE ALL OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
FOUR NINE HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
DOLLARS APIECE AND THAT SEEMS TO
BE A REALLY INEFFICIENT WAY TO
MAKE THIS HAPPEN INSTEAD A
DIRECT TRANSFER BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENTS SEEMS TO BE THE
BETTER AVENUE. AND SO WE WOULD
ASK UP FOR YOU TO PUT THIS IS
PART OF YOUR PROPOSAL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
WE WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE ISSUE SEVENTEENTH.
AB ONE REPRESENTING OUR
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
SENATE ADMINISTRATIVE APPROACH
TO THE LA BILLING PROGRAM. I
THINK YOU MAY BE AWARE THAT TO A
RECENTLY CMS ARE ESSENTIALLY
REMOVE THE FREE CARE RULE. AND
BECAUSE OF THAT NOW THEY WILL BE
A HUGE INCREASE IN TERMS OF.
ARE.
CHILDREN WHO WOULD BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE SERVICES AS WELL AS A
LARGE NUMBER OF. EXTRA PROVIDERS
WHO WILL PROVIDE THE SERVICES
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY THE LA A
REIMBURSEMENT WELL. WE BELIEVE
EXPAND IN TERMS OF COMING BACK
TO CALIFORNIA.
ARE IN THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN ONLY A REPORT.
IT SHOW THAT OVER FIVE HUNRED
LAUP ARE PROVIDERS
BOB WE HAVE IN PAST YEARS HAD
ALL AT LEAST SEVEN HUNDRED OR
SO.
HOWEVER FIFTY PERCENT OF OUR
KIDS ARE MET ON MELTED MEDICO
AND WE HAVE OVER A THOUSAND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SO WE'RE
EXPECTING TO SEE ARE. A HUGE
INCREASE.
WITH THE OFFICE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY AND
COOPERATIVELY WITH DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
WE EXPECT TO SEE NOT ONLY
INCREASING REIMBURSEMENT
INCREASING PROVIDERS BUT ALSO
MORE SERVICES PROVIDED TO US
STUDENTS.
SO WE THINK THAT THIS IS A VERY
CRITICAL ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED AT THIS POINT IN ORDER
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
EXPANSION OF LA A BUILDING
PROGRAM. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR TONY TOOK CARE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. THIS IS.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT THERE BE A
BETTER COLOR COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE. RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN CD  IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IN CHILDREN'S HEALTH IS
AT STAKE. THE LACK OF IT MO YOU
BETWEEN THE TWO AGENCIES AND THE
ABSENCE OF REGULAR AN ON GOING
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS IS
DETRIMENTAL TO THE.
TO THE HEALTH OF CHILDREN AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND TO THE AND TO
TEACHERS WHO KNOW THAT A HEALTHY
THAT HELP A CHILD IS DIRECTLY
REALLY RELATED TO THEIR ABILITY
TO LEARN. THIS IS A SMALL AMOUNT
OF MONEY WITH THE POTENTIAL FOR
SIGNIFICANT AND POSITIVE
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS AS MANY
PERCENT PER PREVIOUS PRESENTERS
HAVE STATED BEFORE ME. M.
PREVENTION IS LESS EXPENSIVE
THAN A REACTION AFTER THE FACT
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS BEFORE THERE
ARE PROBLEMS NOT AFTER IS COST
EFFECTIVE AND A POSITIVE USE OF
THESE RESOURCES WE SINCERELY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. BECAME.
ON A HAS SUPPLIED WITH UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIA AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL WE BELIEVE THIS IS
A SMART GUY INVESTMENT IN WHAT
WE KNOW.
WORKS FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
EVERYBODY HAVE A STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM PARKS AND WE
THINK THE M. THAT NURSES IN THE
TEACHERS AND AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND OTHER.
ADVOCATES WERE REALLY I'M
HELPING PATIENTS PROPOSAL THAT'S
WHAT ALLOW THE AT DEPARTMENT TO
BUILD GREATER CAPACITY WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT TO HAVE A BETTER
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES. SO THAT
WE CAN HELP SUPPORT ELEAZAR AS
THEY TRY TO EXPAND HEALTHCARE
ACCESS SO IT REALLY ALLOW HAS.
TO BE AT A BETTER SUPPORT SYSTEM
FOR DISTRICTS THAT THEY COULD
ULTIMATELY HAVE A BETTER HEALTH
CARE SERVICES ON SCHOOLS AND GET
MORE HEALTHCARE SERVICES TO TO
STUDENTS AND CHILDREN THANK. AND
COMMEND.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE SEVENTEEN I'LL BRING IT
UP TO THE DYESS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS.
THIS IS A GRAVE BOZANICH ONE OF
THE THINGS WE COMPLAIN ABOUT THE
MOST IS THAT THE.
DIFFERENT AGENCIES DON'T TALK.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE TOM SUPPORT
AS WELL SNOW.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
SEVENTEEN OPEN.
THANK YOU AND TO MOVE ON TO
ISSUE A TEN
.
PITY HER WITH THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT ALSO KNOWN AS SUCH
THAT.
HOSPITALS RESPONSIBLE FOR
PLANNING AND PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT
TO ADVANCE CALIFORNIANS ACCESS
TO SAFE QUALITY HEALTHCARE.
OUR WORK IS FOCUSED IN THREE
PRIMARY AREAS.
FIRST HEALTH CARE FACILITY
CONSTRUCTION AND FINANCE
SECOND HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND THIRD HEALTHCARE
DATA COLLECTION ANALYSIS AND
REPORTING.
ASPECTS PROPOSED BUDGET FOR TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IS A
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE MILLION.
HOSPITAL'S FUNDED PRIMARILY BY
SPECIAL FUNDS MANY OF THEM
SUPPORTED. HER BUDGET LOOT THE
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND. AND A
SMALL AMOUNT OF FEDERAL FUNDING
ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE MILLION FOR
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE PROGRAMS.
OUR FIRST PROGRAM AREA IS HEALTH
CARE CONSTRUCTION AND FINANCING.
WHERE THE BUILDING DEPARTMENT
FOR CALIFORNIA'S HOSPITALS AND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES?
OUR TECHNICAL STAFF REVIEW AND
APPROVE DESIGN PLANS FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND UPGRADES OF
FACILITIES.
HOSPITAL ADMINISTERS THE SEISMIC
SAFETY PROGRAM WHICH IS FOCUSED
ON STRENGTHENING CALIFORNIA'S
HOSPITAL BUILDINGS SO THEY CAN
REMAIN STANDING AND OPERATIONAL.
IN THE EVENT OF AN EARTHQUAKE OR
OTHER DISASTER.
TWENTY THOUSAND ONE FORTY
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA'S HOSPITAL
BUILDING INVENTORY WAS
CLASSIFIED.
AS BEING AT RISK OF COLLAPSE IN
A MAJOR EARTHQUAKE.
THIS REPRESENTED OVER ONE
THOUSAND BUILDINGS
TODAY IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETY FOUR PERCENT.
CUTE CARE HOSPITAL BUILDINGS IN
THE STATE NOW COMPLY WITH THE
SEISMIC SAFETY ACTS TWENTY
TWENTY STANDARDS.
US BUT HAS ALSO PROMULGATED A
NEW SEISMIC PERFORMANCE
CATEGORY.
CALLED SBC FORTY.
THAT WILL ALLOW OLDER HOSPITAL
BUILDINGS TO UPGRADE TO A
STANDARD. THAT WILL KEEP THEM
SEISMICALLY COMPLIANT PASSED THE
TWENTY THIRTY DEADLINE.
TO DATE FORTY TWO HOSPITAL
BUILDINGS IN TWENTY TWO
HOSPITALS HAVE APPLIED FOR S. B.
C. FORTY UPGRADES.
THIS IS AN EXCELLENT OPTION
PARTICULARLY FOR HOSPITALS AND
AREAS OF LOW SEISMICITY. THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE HAVE TO BE
REPLACED OR REMOVED FROM ACUTE
CARE SERVICES.
US BUT CONTINUES TO LOOK FOR
WAYS TO IMPROVE OUR SERVICE
DELIVERY. AND ENSURE
CONSTRUCTION PLANS ARE APPROVED
TIMELY AND EFFICIENTLY. IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN NINETY FIVE
PERCENT OF ALL PROJECT
APPLICATIONS TOSSED BED. WERE
SUBMITTED ELECTRONICALLY INTO A
HARSH PEDS E. SERVICES PORTAL.
ALSO IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
NINETY SEVEN PERCENT A PROJECT
REVIEWS WERE COMPLETED ON
SCHEDULE.
IN THE AREA OF HEALTHCARE
FINANCING ASPECT ADMINISTERS THE
CAL MORTGAGE PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES
CALIFORNIA'S NONPROFIT AND
PUBLIC HEALTH FACILITIES.
ACCESS TO LOW COST FINANCING FOR
THEIR CAPITAL CONSTRUCTION NEEDS
BY OFFERING LOAN INSURANCE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN. CAL
MORTGAGE HAS ENSURED FORTY SIX
LOANS TOTALING OVER ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION. FOR THESE
FACILITIES AT NO COST TO THE
GENERAL FUND.
OUR NEXT MAJOR PROGRAM AREA IS
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT.
AJ BUT HAS TO ORGANIZATIONS
RESPONSIBLE FOR HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
THE FIRST IS OUR HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT DIVISION
IN THE SECOND IS OUR HEALTH
PROFESSIONS EDUCATION
FOUNDATION.
OUR HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
INCREASED ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE
FOR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
POPULATIONS BY PROMOTING A
DIVERSE. AND CULTURALLY
COMPETENT HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE.
THEY FOCUS ON RECRUITING AND
RETAINING VARIOUS HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND AREAS OF UNMET
NEED.
THE INCREASE THE GEOGRAPHIC
DISTRIBUTION OF CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE.
AND EXPLORE NEW SERVICE DELIVERY
MODELS THREE PILOT PROJECTS.
ONE OF OUR PRIMARY HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS IS THE FONG
BROWN PROGRAM.
SONG BROWN ADMINISTERS GRANTS TO
PRIMARY CARE TEACHING AND
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS
THE MEL DISTRIBUTION OF
PROVIDERS. THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ENCOURAGE UNDERREPRESENTED
GROUPS
TO PURSUE HEALTHCARE CAREERS.
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN INCLUDED A ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION OF A HUNDRED
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO BE
DISTRIBUTED OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD.
PORT PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCIES IN
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
I SHOULD RECEIVE THE FIRST
THIRTY THREE POINT THREE MILLION
APPROPRIATION IN THE CURRENT
YEAR.
DURING THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN SONG BROWN PRIMARY
CARE RESIDENCIA WORD CYCLE
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND WAS
AWARDED.
THE STATE HAS AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
YEARS TO SPEND THE REMAINING
MONEY.
THE PROPOSED TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
INCLUDES THE SECOND INSTALLMENT
OF THIRTY THREE POINT THREE
MILLION.
THE HEALTH PROFESSIONS EDUCATION
FOUNDATION IS A NONPROFIT FIVE
BUT ONCE THREE HOUSE WITH AN
AWESOME HEAD.
THIS FOUNDATION ADMINISTERS
THIRTEEN LOAN REPAYMENT AND
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS.
THAT PROVIDE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES TO HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS IN EXCHANGE FOR
SERVICE OBLIGATION. IN MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS.
SINCE ITS INCEPTION IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THE FOUNDATION HAS
AWARDED APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN
THOUSAND SCHOLARSHIPS AND LOAN
REPAYMENTS. TOTALING ALMOST ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MILLION TO
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
SERVING IN AREAS OF UNMET NEED
IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE.
OUR THIRD PROGRAM AREA IS
HEALTHCARE DATA COLLECTION AND
REPORTING.
ASPECTS INFORMATION SERVICES
DIVISION SERVICES THE HEALTH
CARE DATA COLLECTION AND
REPORTING HOT.
WE COLLECT HEALTHCARE DATA FROM
NEARLY SIX THOUSAND HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES LICENSED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS DATA INCLUDES HOSPITAL
PATIENT RECORDS AS WELL AS
PUBLIC AGGREGATE UTILIZATION AND
FINANCIAL DATA.
WE PRODUCE MEASURES ANALYSES AND
REPORTS ON HEALTH CARE OUTCOMES
AND QUALITY. AND OTHER RELATED
HEALTH TOPICS.
WE MAKE MUCH OF OUR DATA
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
RESEARCHERS POLICYMAKERS THE
MEDIA AND OTHERS.
WE ALSO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS AND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC.
SEEKING TO USE POSH BUT DATA AND
WE CAN PRODUCE CUSTOMIZED DATA
SETS OR ANALYSES UPON REQUEST.
MUCH OF IT IS CURRENTLY
IMPLEMENTING A NEW PROGRAM IN
OUR DATA AREA PURSUANT TO SENATE
BILL SEVENTEEN. WHICH WAS
ENACTED LAST FALL.
S. B. SEVENTEEN ESTABLISHEDA
NEW DATA REPORTING PROGRAM.
WHICH SEEKS TO INCREASE
PRESCRIPTION DRUG COSTS
TRANSPARENCY. BY REQUIRING
ADVANCE NOTIFICATION OF
SPECIFIED PRICE INCREASES
THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
PURCHASERS ME STOP YOU THERE
GUESTS THAT'S ISSUE NINETEEN OF
YEAH I'M GOING OUT SO. I'M WILL
STOP NOW WITH ISSUE EIGHTEEN AND
THAT'S DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA
NO ANY COMMENTS.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE
EIGHTEEN.
SEEING NONE.
WE WILL HOLD ISSUE EIGHTEEN OPEN
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE NINETEEN.
HIGHER SCOTT CHRISTMANN A W.
DIRECTOR AND CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICER WITH THE OFF STATEWIDE
OPENING DEVELOPMENT US BUT.
WITH THE BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR S.
B. SEVENTEEN.
FOR A S. B. SEVENTEEN
REPRESENTS SO WHAT THE NEW DATA
COLLECTION PROGRAM FOR.
FROSH BID.
PROMOTING BECAUSE TRANSPARENCY
OF FOR BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
PURCHASERS.
DRUGS IN CALIFORNIA.
.
GOOD AS REQUIRED BY LAW OF THIS
FOUR OSCARS ACTUALLY MADE
AVAILABLE REGISTRY OF PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE PURCHASERS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADVANCE NOTIFICATION.
OF FOR MANUFACTURERS AS OF
JANUARY ONE THIS YEAR A DRUG
MANUFACTURERS ARE REQUIRED TO
NOTIFY REGISTERED PURCHASERS OF
SPECIFIED THAT INCREASES IN THE
WHOLESALE ACQUISITION COST. OF A
PRESCRIPTION DRUG.
IT'S NOT PRESENT WE CONTINUE TO
WORK ON REGULATIONS DEVELOPMENT.
FOCUSING SPECIFICALLY ON
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AS OF THE
PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY IS A
NEW.
OF GROUP STAKEHOLDERS AT AS AS
YOU MIGHT BE AWARE AUSTIN HAS
FOCUSED MOSTLY.
ON HEALTH OF HOSPITALS AND
HEALTHCARE.
FACILITIES WITH IT'S A CURRENT
DATA COLLECTION PROGRAM SO.
WE'VE ACTUALLY CONDUCTED TO
PUBLIC WORKSHOPS NOT IN THE LAST
TWO MONTHS ONE IN MARCH FOCUSED
ON DATA USERS AND THESE WOULD BE
ESSENTIALLY PURCHASERS. OF
INCLUDING STATE PURCHASERS OF
ALL HEALTH PLANS OF AS WELL AS
PHARMACY BENEFIT MANAGERS.
OTHER WE FOLLOWED IN APRIL OR
WITH THE SECOND PUBLIC WORKSHOP
IN THIS IS FOCUSED ON DATA
SUBMITTERS AND THIS WOULD BE THE
MANUFACTURERS THEMSELVES. THAT
ARE WE REQUIRED TO TO OF SUBMIT
THIS BUDGET OF COST INCREASE
THOUGHT INFORMATION STARTING
AND.
TWENTY NINETEEN.
ALTHOUGH BOTH WORKSHOPS WERE
VERY WELL ATTENDED.
BUT WE WE WE WE TOOK A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF FEEDBACK
BOTH AT THE WORKSHOPS AND THEN
YOU KNOW IN WRITTEN.
SUBMISSIONS AFTER WE'VE WE'VE
BEEN ESSENTIALLY COMPILING THAT.
AT PRESENT.
TO TO INCORPORATE INTO THE
DRAFT REGULATIONS.
ALRIGHT NOW WE'RE WE'RE
TARGETING A OF A FORMAL
SUBMISSION.
OF THE.
REGULATIONS FOR S. B. SEVENTEEN
IN JULY.
TO BEGIN THE THE THE RULE MAKING
PROCESS THOUGHT AND TO HAVE
THOSE OF A ADOPTED BY JANUARY
ONE. OF TWENTY NINETEEN.
TO BEGIN ESSENTIALLY THE THE OF
DATA COLLECTION OF BOTH.
A NEW PRESCRIPTION DRUGS WHICH
IS ESSENTIALLY WILL WILL PROVIDE
A SET OF DATA ELEMENTS.
TO TO WASH BUT FROM EACH
MANUFACTURER OF BASED ON A.
THRESHOLD AMOUNT SET THE LAW.
MEDICARE SPECIALTY RIGHT OUT
SIX SEVENTY.
AND THEN OF COURSE THE ON GOING.
INCREASES THAT REACH THE
SPECIFIED THRESHOLD WHICH IS
THAT IT SIXTEEN PERCENT OVER.
PRIOR TO YEARS AND AND AND KILL
IT SO.
THAT WE BEEN.
YOU KNOW. WORKING DILIGENTLY AT
AT AT THAT PACKAGE IN AND THEN
LIKEWISE RAMPING UP OUR EFFORTS
FOR THE.
TECHNOLOGY.
REQUIRED TO COLLECT THOSE WHICH
WERE LEVERAGING BASED OFF
EXISTING OF HEALTH CARE OF THE
DATA COLLECTION PROGRAMS.
SOME IN THE PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY WERE REQUESTING
THREE POSITIONS OF IN FISCAL
YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. ARE IN
THIS IS TO DEVELOP REGULATIONS
SYSTEMS PROPHECIES
OF FOR COLLECTION REVIEW. AND
PUBLICATION.
OF PRESCRIPTION DRUG COST
INFORMATION OF BEGINNING IN NEXT
CALENDAR YEAR THERE'S RESOURCES
ALSO BE USED
TO DEVELOP A PENALTY APPEALS
PROCESS AS AS IDENTIFIED IN THE
LAW.
YES SIR.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ILIO.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MATTER GET
SICK OF ON THE PART OF FINANCE
WE AGREE WITH THIS PROPOSAL IT'S
RESPONSIVE TO THE REQUIREMENTS
OF S. B. SEVENTEEN.
THE COMMAND.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
NINETEEN.
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS AM MARY
VALDEZ OF HEALTHAXIS CALIFORNIA
WE WERE A PROUD CO SPONSOR OF S.
B. SEVENTEEN.
TO HELP INCREASE COST
TRANSPARENCY IN PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS AND WE WANT TO THANK GOSH
PAD ON THE.
VERY.
COLLABORATIVE IMPLEMENTATION
PROCESS WE'VE BEEN VERY PLEASED
WITH THE WORKSHOPS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO I'M WORKING WITH YOU
AS IMPLEMENTATION LOOKS FORWARD.
AND ALSO I SUPPORT THE BCP
THINKING.
WE GIVE THEM.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE ISSUE NINETEEN. SAY NO
COMMENTS FROM THE DYESS WILL
HOLD ISSUE NINETEEN OPEN TO MOVE
ON TO ISSUE TWENTY.
THANK YOU
.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS FOR ASKING A WITH KP
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF
MOSQUITO AND VECTOR CONTROL
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. WE
ARE PLEASED TO SPONSOR THIS
PROPOSAL WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
CRITICAL SUSTAIN FUNDING OF FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
THE CALIFORNIA VECTOR BORNE
DISEASE SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CAL SERVE.
CAL SERVICE A PROGRAM THAT IS
JOINTLY MANAGED BY UC DAVIS THE
MOSQUITO AND VECTOR CONTROL
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
IT PROVIDES CENTRALIZED DATA
COLLECTION ANALYSIS AND STORAGE
RELATED THE PRESENCE OF
MOSQUITOES AND MOSQUITO BORNE
DISEASES AROUND THE STATE.
IT ALSO PROVIDES LOCAL MOSQUITO
CONTROL AGENCIES WITH REAL TIME
INFORMATION ON WHERE MOSQUITOES
MIGHT EMERGE THAT VACANT BEST
COMBAT THEIR SPREAD.
THE STATE HAS SUPPORTED MOSQUITO
RESEARCH IN THE PAST FROM
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO TO TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT.
WHEN THAT FUNDING WAS ABSORBED
DURING THE MANY CUTS FOR THE
RECESSION.
WE'VE BEEN OUT WITHOUT SUPPORT
SINCE THEN AND THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE NOW BEING THAT WERE
FACING NEW NON NATIVE SPECIES OF
MOSQUITOES THAT TRANSMIT THE
ZECA VIRUS DENGUE CHIKUNGUNYA
AND YELLOW FEVER.
THIS IS IN ADDITION THE WORK
THAT OUR MEMBER AGENCIES STILL
DO IN PROTECTING AGAINST WEST
NILE VIRUS WHICH IS STILL
PRESENT IN CALIFORNIA AND
DEVASTATING TO THOSE WHO ARE
AFFECTED EVERY YEAR.
WEST NILE CONTINUES TO BE COSTLY
TO TREAT WITH AN ESTIMATED
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF OVER EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER HUMAN CASE
ANNUALLY. AND A SORRY AND THAT'S
PER HUMAN CASE OVER THE COURSE
OF THAT CASE PERIOD.
I IN SMALLER NORTHERN COUNTIES
LAKE VIEW YOU BEEN COLUSA THAT
HAVE A HIGHER INCIDENCE OF WEST
NILE AND THE SMALL HEALTH CARE
BUDGETS THOSE COSTS ARE PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT.
BEING ABLE TO TRACK DISEASE
TRANSMITTING MOSQUITOES AND
VIRUS INFECTION RISK IS A KEY
COMPONENT PREVENTING DISEASE
OUTBREAKS AND CONTROLLING
MOSQUITO POPULATIONS.
THE CULTURE OF PROGRAMS OF THE
MOST CUTTING EDGE SYSTEMS
AVAILABLE TO DO THIS.
INVASIVE MOSQUITOES HAVE BEEN
DETECTED IN OVER TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY CITIES AND LOCALITIES AND
TWELVE COUNTIES INCLUDING
POPULOUS URBAN AREAS WHERE THE
RISK FOR LOCAL TRANSMISSION OF
DAN GAINES YOU GO OR NO VERY
REAL THREAT.
THIS PROPOSAL IS A SMALL
INVESTMENT PREVENTION THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY SAVE THE STATE MONEY
FROM THE COST MOSQUITO BORNE
ILLNESSES AND PUT THE STATE ON
CUTTING EDGE OF THE SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH SUPPORT. WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME AND I'D
LIKE TO INTRODUCE DR CHRIS
PARKER WITH UC DAVIS.
HI MY NAME IS CHRIS PARKER AND
I'M AN ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF
EPIDEMIOLOGY UC DAVIS I'M ALSO
THE DIRECTOR OF THE PACIFIC
SOUTHWEST CENTER OF EXCELLENCE
IN VECTOR BORNE DISEASES THAT'S
AT UC DAVIS AND UC RIVERSIDE.
AND.
AYE ALSO OVERSEE THE CALLOUS OR
SYSTEM WHICH IS WHY I'M HERE.
IN THAT SYSTEM IS HOUSE AT UC
DAVIS AND REPRESENTS THE
COLLABORATION OF THE NASA HAS
DESCRIBED.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I KNOW
IT'S GETTING LATE SO I'LL JUST
GIVE YOU A VERY BRIEF SUMMARY OF
THE SUCCESSES IN THE
OPPORTUNITIES OF BEING ABLE BY
SUPPORT OF THE SYSTEM.
I'M COUNSELOR BEGAN IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX AS AN ONLINE
PLATFORM FOR DATA MANAGEMENT
REPORTING FOR MOSQUITOES AND THE
VIRUSES THEY TRANSMIT AT THE
TIME IT WAS PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON
WEST NILE VIRUS IN AND
MOSQUITOES. RELEVANT TO THAT
SYSTEM. ON SINCE THEN WITH ALL
OF THE NEW CHALLENGES THAT
VANESSA DESCRIBE WE'VE EXPANDED
THE SYSTEM'S CAPABILITIES TO I'M
ADDRESS ESPECIALLY THE SPREAD OF
INVASIVE MOSQUITOES IN OUR
CITIES.
THE EMERGENCE OF THE GOV IRIS
VERY RECENTLY.
AS WELL AS THE RETURN OF ST
LOUIS ENCEPHALITIS VIRUS HERE
WHICH WAS GONE FOR TWELVE YEARS
ON. AND RETURNED IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AND HAS RECURRED EVERY
YEAR SENSE.
KELSO HAS RECOGNIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AS OUR STATE'S OFFICIAL
DATABASE FOR OF THE SURVEILLANCE
OF MOSQUITOES IN THE VIRUSES
THEY TRANSMIT WHICH I THINK. IS
A LARGE PART OF HIS SUCCESS WHEN
YOU OF THE OFFICIAL SEAL OF
APPROVAL OF THE STATE THAT. THAT
REALLY ADVANCES THE USE BY LOCAL
AGENCIES.
IN ALL OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS
ACROSS THE STATE RELY ON A DAILY
FOR REPORTING IN DECISION
MAKING.
TODAY WE'VE REALLY SUPPORTED
THE SYSTEM BY LEVERAGING A
PATCHWORK OF RESEARCH FUNDING
WHICH IS ALWAYS DIFFICULT.
ON RESEARCH GRANTS TO JUSTIFY A
PROGRAMMER SALARY IT'S GOT TO BE
A CERTAIN TYPE OF GRANT THAT
DOESN'T ALWAYS SELL A CERTAIN
AGENCIES.
BUT WE'VE BEEN REASONABLY
SUCCESSFUL AT THAT SO FAR.
MANY OF THOSE HAVE BEEN FROM
FEDERAL SOURCES INCLUDING NO
ANNOUNCE AND CDC.
I'M AND FOR A BRIEF PERIOD WE
ALSO RECEIVE SUPPORT FROM
MOSQUITO AND VECTOR CONTROL
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA ON
WHICH FOR NASA REPRESENTS.
THESE FUNDS OF LEFT OUR STATE
IN A GREAT POSITION ON THE
SYSTEM'S WELL ESTABLISHED BEEN
USED TO SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX
AS I MENTION.
WHERE OFTEN HELD UP BY OTHER
STATES AND EVEN THE U. S. CDC IS
ONE OF THE BEST EXAMPLES OF A
FUNCTIONAL PARTNERSHIP?
AMONG STAKEHOLDERS IN ACADEMIA
WHICH IS US AND THEN PUBLIC
HEALTH AND VECTOR CONTROL.
SO THEY THEY LOVE US COME A
WHAT'S STARTING TO BE RECOGNIZED
IS THAT THE SYSTEM'S HANGING BY
A THREAD SO TO SPEAK BECAUSE. IT
ALWAYS DEPENDS ON THE NEXT GRANT
COMING IN AND THAT.
REALLY NEEDS A LITTLE BIT MORE
STABLE FUNDING.
SO DESPITE THE SUCCESSES WE CAN
DO A LOT MORE.
WERE CONSTANTLY AT RISK OF THE
ABS INFLOWS OF FEDERAL FUNDING
AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW.
SO WE WERE LOOKING FOR MORE
STABILITY CALM THE MODEST
FEDERAL SUPPORT WE'VE RECEIVED
IS SUPPORTED ONLY A SINGLE
POSITION AT ANY GIVEN TIME WHICH
IS ALSO. PRETTY UNDERPOWERED IN
TERMS OF HUMAN RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT OUR GROWING LIST OF
NEEDS.
EFFECTIVE MOSQUITO CONTROL
REALLY DEPENDS ON THE QUALITY OF
THE EVIDENCE AVAILABLE TO INFORM
THEIR CONTROL DECISIONS SO. ON
YOUR SUPPORT WOULD PROVIDE FOR
NEW DEVELOPMENT SEVERAL AREAS
AND THREE OF THE SPECIFIC ONES
THAT I JUST WANT TO MENTION THE
INTEREST OF TIME OUR. NEW DATA
VISUALIZATION TOOLS THAT
ACTUALLY ALLOWS TO DIRECTLY LINK
SURVEILLANCE AND CONTROL DATA TO
SEE HOW WE'RE DOING
REAL TIME.
MAPS OF INSECTICIDE RESISTANCE
WHICH IS A BEEN A BIG CHALLENGE
ACROSS OUR STATE.
THAT COULD HELP MOSQUITO
CONTROL AGENCIES DECIDE WHICH
PRODUCTS ARE WILL BE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND THEN ALSO PUBLIC
FACING RISK MAPS WHICH GIVES ALL
OF US. OF YOU ANYTIME OF LIVE
DATA AND THE COUNSELOR SYSTEM
AND COULD BE POTENTIALLY
TAILORED AND EMBEDDED INTO
LOCAL.
AGENCIES WEBSITES WHICH GIVES
THEM A RESOURCE THAT THEY DON'T
YET HAVE. SO EXCITED ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF THE PROGRAM WE FEEL
LIKE IT'S IN A GOOD POSITION BUT
WE'RE REALLY LOOKING FOR THAT.
EXTRA BIT OF STATE SUPPORT TO
REALLY KNOW THAT IT WILL EXIST
FROM NOW ON AND I THINK THAT'S
WHERE WE ARE IS. AS IT'S BEEN
INCREASINGLY RELIED ON WE REALLY
WANT TO KNOW THAT. THERE IS THAT
SUPPORT AND WE WILL HAVE
PROGRAMMERS AND OTHERS DEDICATED
TO THIS FOR YEARS TO COME.
THANK YOU DOCTOR.
WE'LL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE ISSUE TWENTY.
SEEN NONO BRING IT UP TO THE
DYESS FOR ANY COMMENTS WE MAY
HAVE.
IN MY PRACTICE I KNOW WE WOULD
OFTENTIMES FOLLOW MATCH OF THE
WORK YOU DID PARTICULARLY AROUND
WEST NILE SO IT'S A. WELL
RECEIVED PROPOSAL ON WILL HOLD
ISSUE TWENTY OPEN FOR NOW
.
GOOD EVENING AGAIN.
I AM STILL DOCTORS WOULD ON
COOPER WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES.
AND I'M HERE AGAIN TO TALK TO
YOU ABOUT DIABETES ON BUT THIS
TIME A LITTLE DIFFERENT ON IT
WITH A MORE EXPANSIVE VIEW SO.
I'M GIVEN WILL BE VERY TALKED
ABOUT ABOUT THE DIABETES
PREVENTION PROGRAM THIS ACTUALLY
HELPS TO COUPLE THAT PROGRAM
WITH SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO BE
ABLE TO DO OUTREACH.
AND ENROLLMENT ON ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE KNOW IT IN TERMS
OF BARRIERS IS.
WE PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW THAT
THERE'S ACTUALLY A PROBLEM I
MEAN CALIFORNIA FIFTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE POPULATION HAS
PRE DIABETES. OP OR DIABETES BUT
MANY PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE IT AND THEY ALSO NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THE PERSONAL RISK ON
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO THEN MOVE
TO THE THIRD STEP WITH IT WHICH
IS ACTUALLY REACHING OUT AND
ACCESSING RESOURCES AND SO SINCE
WE HAD THE DIABETES. PREVENTION
PROGRAM
THAT'S GOING TO BE WATCHING AND
MEDI CAL UP IN JANUARY AS WELL
AS ON DIABETES TREATMENT
PROGRAMS WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE AWARE OF
THE RISK. AND ALSO AWARE OF THE
RESOURCES AND SO THIS IS A ONE
TIME ALLOCATION OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
TO BE ABLE TO HIRE TWO FULL TIME
STAFF PEOPLE TO HELP WITH AN
OUTREACH AND ENROLLMENT.
OWE IT INITIATIVE ON THIS WOULD
BE A CAMPAIGN THAT WOULD
PUBLICIZE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
USING VARIOUS FORMS OF MEDIA SO
THIS WOULD BE WORKING WITH
PROMONTORY THE COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS TO BE ABLE TO GET THE
WORD OUT. AND AN AREA THAT ALSO
AND ENGAGE ON TRADITIONAL MEDIA
AND SOCIAL MEDIA AND THE IDEA
WOULD BE THAT THERE WOULD BE AN
OVERSIGHT AND ADVISORY COMMITTEE
THAT WOULD CONVENE AND TOM
WOULD.
INCLUDE A LOT OF PEOPLE FROM
VARIOUS.
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS SO YOU WOULD
HAVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE EXPERTISE
IN MEDIA YOU'D ALSO HAVE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE EXPERTISE ON IN IN
SERVICE DELIVERY COMING TOGETHER
AND TALKING ABOUT WHAT'S NEEDED
WHERE THE GAPS AND WHAT WOULD
THIS LOOK LIKE THE BILL WOULD BE
A TAILORED CAMPAIGN FOR
DIFFERENT CAN.
AND THAT'S BUT GENERALLY THE THE
PROPOSAL FOR TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR A ONE TIME ALLOCATION TO BE
ABLE TO DO THIS WORK AND THIS IS
THIS WOULD FEED INTO BOTH THE
DIABETES PREVENTION PROGRAM AS
WELL DIABETES TREATMENT PROGRAMS
TO BE ABLE TO.
GARNER COST SAVINGS FOR THE
STATE.
HUMAN.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS
ON ISSUE TWENTY ONE.
LIBERALS ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
TIM REID TIM MADDEN REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY
INFER CARDIOLOGISTS MANY TIMES
WHEN WE SEE PATIENTS HAVE
DIABETES IT'S AT THE POINT WHERE
IT'S TRANSITION INTO HEART
DISEASE.
AND WHERE THE TOUGH
CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE IS IF THEY
HAD A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
THE RISKS AND DANGERS
ASSOCIATED.
WITH HAVING DIABETES THEY MAY
HAVE DONE SOMETHING EARLIER SO
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO INCREASE
EDUCATION NOT REACHES GREAT.
FOR THESE REASONS PRINCIPLE
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU DAVID IS ALSO BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN DIABETES
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS AMERICA'S
POSITION GROUPS HAPPEN HERE IN
SUPPORT IS VERY REASONABLE
INVESTMENT. ON GROWING
HEALTHCARE CRISIS THANK YOU.
SIR.
SING NO MORE PUBLIC COMMENT
OPENING IT UP TO THE DYESS FUNNY
COMMENTS WE HAVE.
SEEING NONE WE WILL HOLD SHOULD
TWENTY ONE OPEN FOR NOW AND MOVE
ON TO ISSUE TWENTY TWO.
STILL HERE.
WILL BE THE LAST TIME YOU HAVE
TO HEAR FROM YOU THIS EVENING
APART WITH.
READY.
AS AS I'M SURE YOU ARE AWARE
BECAUSE WE HAVE JUST RECENTLY
HAD A HEARING ABOUT IT
ADVERTISED EXPERIENCES AS A
MAJOR PROBLEM IN.
FOR YOUTH IN PARTICULAR.
THERE THE ORIGINAL IS A STUDY
WAS DONE AND FOUND THAT TWO
THIRDS OF ADULTS HAD AT LEAST
ONE ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCE
IN ONE IN EIGHT HAD FOR MORE.
THAN THAT THERE'S A DOSE
RESPONSE BETWEEN HAVING ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES AT A
NUMBER OF CHRONIC CONDITIONS UP
AS WELL AS BEHAVIORAL OUTCOMES
THAT WE DON'T THINK
TRADITIONALLY ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH THINGS THAT HAPPEN IN OUR
CHILDHOOD THINGS LIKE DIABETES.
AND CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE BUT
ALSO THINGS LIKE SMOKING.
ENGAGING IN IN VIOLENT BEHAVIOR
AND EVEN I'M BEING ARRESTED AND
BEING CONVICTED OF FELONIES
AND SO FOR THAT REASON THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF ATTENTION HAS
THERE'S BEEN A GROWING BODY OF
EVIDENCE AROUND ADVERSE TODD
EXPERIENCES. AND THE POSSIBILITY
OF BEING ABLE TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THEM TO PREVENT THE HARM
THAT IS CAUSED BY TALK FIXTURES
AS WELL AS BY BEING ABLE TO
PREVENT. OP TRAUMA IN THE FIRST
PLACE AND SO WHAT WE HAVE
PROPOSED HERE.
IS A CAMPAIGN THAT WOULD
INCLUDE BRING TOGETHER
STAKEHOLDERS ON THAT UNDERSTAND
SOME OF THIS WORK AND ALLOW THEM
TO BE ABLE TO WORK THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF PILOTING FROM SO
INITIALLY THERE WOULD BE.
AN INTERNATIONAL LITERATURE
REVIEW TO BE ABLE TO DETERMINE
WHERE WE ARE IN TERMS OF SOME OF
THE THE PROTOCOLS AROUND ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES.
AND THEN MOVING ON TO FINDING
BEST PRACTICES SO WHAT HAS BEEN
DONE ON THE HAS BEEN EFFECTIVE
THAT COULD BE TRIED IN PLACES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND THE DEVELOPING A TOOL KIT
THAT COULD BE USED.
TO BE ABLE FOR A CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO BE ABLE TO.
TO IMPLEMENT SOME OF THE
STRATEGIES AND THEN PILOTING IN
AT LEAST TWELVE CITIES OR
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
FOCUSING IN PARTICULAR ON
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE LOW ARE OF
LOWER INCOME BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S A COMBINATION OF
INDIVIDUAL TRAUMAS AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY TRAUMAS
THERE ARE CONCENTRATED IN THOSE
AREAS. AND THEN PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WOULD
INCLUDE A LOCAL ADVISORY ON
BOARD AS WELL AS.
LISTENING SESSIONS AND ALSO THE
ABILITY FOR THAT.
FOR THOSE BOARDS TO BE ABLE TO
PRIORITIZE WHAT IS DONE IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES SO REALLY IS A
COMMUNITY INFORMED INITIATIVE.
AND SO THE IDEA WOULD BE THAT
THAT.
THE REQUEST IS FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR AS A ONE TIME
ALLOCATION TO BE ABLE TO UP TO
DO THIS WORK AND BE ABLE TO THEN
COME BACK WITH FORMAL
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT WHAT COULD
BE DONE AND WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO.
IMPLEMENT IN CALIFORNIA
AND THIS WOULD USE PROPS PROPS
SIXTY THREE.
RULES.
HELD GOLDSTINE PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES AS WELL.
.
YOU TAKE SOMETHING LIKE THE
STUFF ON CLARK'S SHOOTING HERE
IN SACRAMENTO IN THE.
.
THE.
TRAUMA THAT'S BEING EXPERIENCED
IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
COMMUTERS A COLOR RIGHT HERE. IS
JUST AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT'S GOING
ON.
IN COMMUNITIES ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA THERE'S.
.
PHYSICAL ABUSE.
CHILD ABUSE EMOTIONAL ABUSE
SEXUAL ABUSE.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE GOING ON IN
FAMILIES THAT'S HARMFUL TO
CHILDREN.
EXAMPLES OF ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES AND THEN THERE'S ALL
OF THE DRAMA GOING ON IN
COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
ACTUALLY JUST GOT A COPY OF A
REPORT FROM THE UNITED NATIONS
LE THEY'VE MADE.
ADDRESSING TRAUMA A TOP
PRIORITY.
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
AB BASED ON THIS UNDERSTANDING
NOW IS DOCTOR CO FOR WAS
DESCRIBING THAT WHAT HAPPENS TO
US AS KIDS. HAS THIS ENORMOUS
LONG TERM IMPACT.
AND GIVEN THAT WE NOW KNOW THE
US WE ACTUALLY IS CONCILIUM M.
OUR EYES WHAT THAT. CHANGES IN
BRAIN STRUCTURE ARE.
.
WE HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO GO
UPSTREAM AND START ADDRESSING
THESE UNDERLYING CAUSES USING.
STRATEGIES THAT ARE NOW.
PROVEN TO BE EFFECTIVE
AND LIKE I SAY ALL OVER THE
WORLD LET'S MAKE CALIFORNIA.
BE ONE OF THE LEADERS IN THE S.
AND LITERALLY IN THE PROCESS
SAVE MONEY IN TERMS OF
HEALTHCARE COSTS.
TWO BILLION TERMS OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE COSTS.
AND THE THE RECENT AND NUMBERS I
THOUGHT I'M.
KIDS WHO HAVE.
BUT FOUR OR MORE OF THESE
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
THEIR MOST THIRTEEN TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO BE.
ARRESTED.
AS KIDS THESE ARE THE KIDS THAT
END UP IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM THE THE KIDS END UP IN
THE SOCIAL SERVICE SYSTEM.
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO HAVE
DIFFICULTY.
IN SCHOOLS.
WE KNOW WHAT TO DO ABOUT IT NOW
HERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO TO
PILOT TEST.
IN SOME COMMUNITIES WITH THE
GREATEST NEED AND THEN.
AGAIN USING IN THIS CASE PROP
SIXTY THREE ADMIN FUNDING
POTENTIALLY THEN.
SPREADING THIS USING A OTHER
PROP SIXTY THREE FUNDS.
TO DO WHAT PROP SIXTY THREE IS
REALLY MEANT TO DO WHICH IS
ADDRESS AND PREVENT. MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEMS
THANK YOU DOCTOR WILSON.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE TWENTY TWO.
SEEING NONE I WILL BRING IT UP
TO THE DYESS FOR ANY COMMENTS.
I WILL SAY HOW.
INTERESTED I AM IN THE SUBJECT
MATTER AND OFFLINE WILL HAVE
CONVERSATIONS AS THIS IS GOING
FORWARD.
WILL HOLD ISSUE TWENTY TO OPEN
A MOVE ON TO ISSUE TWENTY THREE
KICKING HERE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
WAS IMMEDIATE THE CALVINISTIC
COUNCIL LABORS.
ARE.
WE R. ENGAGE QUITE A BIT INDEED
LEAD ABATEMENT.
BECAUSE SUCH INDUSTRY.
AND WE ARE SEEKING ARE SIMPLY
YOUR CONCURRENCE.
AND YOUR SUPPORT TO BE ABLE TO.
PACIFIC WAY.
ARE.
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF WE
COULD SEEK YOUR CONCURRENCE REAL
TO INCREASE THE FEES CURRENT
BEING CHARGED FOR ALL THOSE THAT
APPLY. TO BE CERTIFIED.
WHETHER CHIU TRADE INITIALLY OR
TO RE JAAP THEIR ANNUAL
TRAINING.
FOR LEAD ABATEMENT TRACTS OF
OCCASION.
CURRENT DEPARTMENT OF.
PUBLIC HEALTH IS A WANTED
OVERSEAS THIS.
AND QUITE FRANKLY THE FEE IS NOT
BE INCREASED
HAS BEEN INCREASE FOR OVER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE YEARS.
AND WE ARE SEEKING A SLIGHT
INCREASE OF TEN TO TWELVE
DOLLARS WOULD FEEL THAT WOULD
COVER. THOSE STAFF PERSON.
I WOULD PROBABLY DEFER MORE
CHEER COMMITTEE CONSULTS TO BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY WHETHER NOT
THIS BE SUFFICIENT UP TO BE ABLE
TO.
A COVER AND EXPEDITE THE
PROCESSING OF THESE
APPLICATIONS.
WE'RE CURRENTLY.
MOST RECENT DO TO THE FIRES
HAPPENED HERE IN THE STATE.
BOTH NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WING THINKER
OBVIOUSLY HIGHER VOLUME PEOPLE
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROCESS.
MORE WORK IS REQUIRED TO HAVE
THE TRAINING TO BE ABLE TO.
FULFILL THE NEEDS FOR ALL THIS
KIND OF OPERATION.
AND WE ARE COMPLETELY BACKED UP
WE FEEL THAT THE DEPARTMENT.
.
SHOULD BE ABLE TO EXPEDITE THIS
AND BE ABLE FROM COMING DOWN
FROM THE BRIDGE A HUNDRED TWENTY
DAY REQUIREMENT.
THAT'S ORDERED STATUE DOWN THE
SIXTY DAYS
IT WAS CERTAINLY THE ISSUE THAT
WE HAVE IS AT NO IMPORTANT
WORKER. WHETHER OUR PEOPLE WERE
OTHERWISE ARE ABLE TO REPORT TO
WORK WITHOUT THE PROPER
CERTIFICATION CARD. AND IT'S NOT
ON THE EMPLOYER BUT ON THE
EMPLOYEES.
SO RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
SIR.
WE WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE TWENTY THREE.
SEEING NANA BRING IT UP TO THE
DYESS.
MAYOR OF.
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THIS
PROPOSAL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND COMMITTEE
STAFF AS THIS PROPOSAL GOES
FORWARD. WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
ISSUE TWENTY THREE OPEN AND MOVE
ON TO ISSUE TWENTY FOUR WITH
THAT.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS BARBARA
GLAZER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION. I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE SUBCOMMITTEE
FOR CONSIDERING OUR REQUEST ON
TO ADOPT BUDGET TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO PUBLICLY POST
INFORMATION ON THE CENTRALIZED
APPLICATION UNITS. WORKLOAD
VOLUME AND TIMELINESS OF
PROCESSING HEALTH FACILITY
APPLICATIONS WE LEARNED LATE
LAST WEEK THAT THE DEPARTMENT ON
IT HAS NOW PUT THOSE METRICS UP
ON THEIR WEBSITE IT'S VERY GOOD
NEWS WERE VERY PLEASED. TO SEE
THAT.
ARE THE ONLY THING I THINK WE'D
LIKE TO ADD IS THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO BE SURE THAT THIS IS
DONE ON A QUARTERLY BASIS.
ON WHICH I THINK IT'S THEIR PLAN
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO THEM ABOUT
THIS FOR OVER A YEAR AND WE'RE
VERY PLEASED TO SEE THAT IT IS
NOW HAVE.
SO I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK ON THAT'S THANK
YOU.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE TWENTY FOUR.
SEEING NONE BRING IT TO THE
DYESS HA LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THIS AND. WE HOLD
ISSUE TWENTY FOUR OF.
THANK.
ISSUE TWENTY FIVE
.
MISTER MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE TAYLOR
JACKSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION.
THINK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ON
THIS PROPOSAL WHICH WILL IMPROVE
THE INTEGRITY OF HOSPITAL
INSPECTIONS. AS CURRENTLY
CONDUCTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
UNDER CURRENT LAW SEE PEACHES
MANDATED TO DEPLOY A HOSPITAL
INSPECTORS TO CONDUCT THE
INSPECTION OF HOSPITALS FOR
SPECIFIED PURPOSES UNDER
CALIFORNIA STATUTES AND
REGULATIONS.
GENERALLY THESE INSPECTIONS ARE
INTENDED FOR INSPECTORS TO MAKE
FINDINGS AS WELL AS RESPOND
TIMELY INAPPROPRIATELY TO ISSUES
IDENTIFIED DURING THE
INSPECTIONS PROCESS.
HOWEVER WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR
NURSES THE PRESENTS OF
MANAGEMENT DURING THESE
INSPECTIONS HAVE HAD A STIFLING
EFFECT. ON HOSPITAL WORKERS AND
OFTENTIMES INTIMIDATING
PERSONNEL SO MUCH
BUT THEY ARE DETERRED FROM
PROVIDING MEANINGFUL FEEDBACK
ABOUT PATIENT SAFETY ISSUES. AND
POTENTIAL REGULATORY VIOLATIONS.
THEREFORE AS NOTED IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S AGENDA WE WOULD
LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT THE SUB COMMITTEE ADOPT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
TO AMEND A SECTION OF THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE TO ALLOW
EMPLOYEES OF HEALTH FACILITIES
INSPECTED BY DPH. TO HAVE THE
RIGHT TO DISCUSS POSSIBLE
REGULATORY VIOLATIONS OR PATIENT
SAFETY CONCERNS WITH AN
INSPECTOR PRIVATELY DURING THE
COURSE OF AN INVESTIGATION OR
INSPECTION.
I ALSO NOTED THIS PROVISION
WOULD BE CONSISTENT WITH LABOR
SECTIONS WHICH ALLOW EMPLOYEES
TO SPEAK FREELY WITH INSPECTORS
AT THE DIVISION OF OCCUPATIONAL
HEALTH AND SAFETY.
UNDER EXISTING LAW IF A CAL OSHA
INSPECTOR COMES INTO THE
HOSPITAL TO CONDUCT AN
INVESTIGATION INSPECTION.
THE NURSES AND OTHER WORKERS
HAVE A RIGHT TO SPEAK PRIVATELY
WITH INSPECTOR.
BUT IF A DPH INSPECTOR COMES
INTO THAT SAME HOSPITAL FOR AN
INSPECTION THE SAME EMPLOYEE
DOES NOT HAVE THAT SAME RIGHT TO
SPEAK PRIVATELY.
SEEKING PARITY INCONSISTENCY
UNDER THE LAW.
THE PRESENCE OF MANAGEMENT TRADE
THESE INSPECTIONS HAS NO
CORRELATION TO IMPROVE QUALITY
OR OUTCOMES.
HOUSING HAS A CHILLING EFFECT ON
WORKERS AND HAS ONLY RESULTED IN
THE EMISSION OF IMPORTANT ISSUES
WORKERS NO NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
ADOPTING THESE PROVISIONS WILL
IMPROVE EFFICIENCY AS INSPECTORS
GET A MORE ACCURATE DEPICTION OF
WHAT THE STATE OF AFFAIRS IS AT
ANY GIVEN HOSPITAL. WHICH WILL
LIKELY RESULT IN CURBING THE
NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL OR FOLLOW
UP INSPECTIONS BEING CONDUCTED
BY DPH.
WHICH ARE OFTEN PROMPTED BY
ANONYMOUS CALLS FROM HOSPITAL
PERSONNEL.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS IMPORTANT PROPOSAL AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN ADOPTING
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. WHICH
WILL IMPROVE THE INTEGRITY AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF INSPECTIONS AT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH BY ENSURING THAT
HOSPITAL EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE
SPEAK PRIVATELY WITH THEIR CD
PEACH INVEST INSPECTORS.
JUST LIKE WORKERS ARE ALLOWED TO
SPEAK PRIVATELY WITH CAL OSHA
INSPECTORS NOW.
HUMAN.
WE WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE TWENTY FIVE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK
WINDOWS WITH US HERE YOU
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF OUR
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND NURSES
WOULD JUST LIKE TO.
ECHO THE POINTS MADE BY MS
JACKSON.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
WE WILL BRING IT TO THE DYESS
AND.
CORD TO WORKING WITH YOU AS
WELL.
WHO HOLD ISSUE TWENTY FIVE OPEN?
ISSUE TWENTY SIX
.
BUT AFTER GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
I'M SHE NICENO THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER FOR
HEALTH CARE QUALITY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. TO PRESENT OUR TRAILER
BILL PROPOSAL TO CONTINUE TO USE
FEDERAL STANDARDS IN LIEU OF
DEVELOPING STATE LICENSING
STANDARDS.
FOR AMBULATORY SURGERY CENTERS
COMPREHENSIVE OUTPATIENT
REHABILITATION FACILITIES AN END
STAGE RENAL DISEASE FACILITIES.
WE.
WE WERE GIVEN TEMPORARY
AUTHORITY TO USE THE FEDERAL
STANDARDS WHILE WE CONDUCTED A
STUDY. OF WHETHER THE FEDERAL
STANDARDS WERE SUFFICIENT AND WE
CONTRACTED WITH THE UC DAVIS
INSTITUTE FOR POPULATION HEALTH
IMPROVEMENT.
TWO DO THAT EVALUATION THEIR
EVALUATION FOUND THAT THEY DID
BELIEVE THAT THE FEDERAL
STANDARDS WERE ADEQUATE. TO BE
USED IN LIEU OF THE DEPARTMENT
DEVELOPING STATE LICENSING
STANDARDS WE PRESENTED THE.
UC DAVIS STUDY AT A PUBLIC
STAKEHOLDER MEETING AND ALSO HAD
OPEN.
FORM FOR PUBLIC COMMENT WE
RECEIVED NO OPPOSING COMMENTS
AND SO WE JUST WISH TO MAKE THIS
PROVISION PERMANENT.
COMMAND.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE EARLIER.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE TWENTY
SIX.
SEEING NONE WILL HOLD ISSUE
TWENTY SIX OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN.
AND A GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
SCOTT OF ALL AND THE SYSTEM THAT
THE DIRECTOR FOR THE CENTER FOR
HEALTH CARE QUALITY. C. P. H..
OTHER TOMORROW PUBLIC HEALTH
REQUEST THREE TWO POSITIONS AN
EXPONENTIAL AUTHORITY OF TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE LICENSE REVOCATION PROGRAM
FUND. AND TO DENY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE INTERNAL
DEPARTMENT QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
ACCOUNT. IN FISCAL YEARS TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN AND I'M
GOING TO IMPROVE. OUR
CORPORATIONS AND EFFECTIVENESS
FOSTER QUALITY IMPROVE PROJECTS
AND ADDRESS WORKFORCE ON NEEDS.
SAFE SECURE ACTIVELY EXAMINING A
RESIGNED HIS BUSINESS PROCESSES
TO MORE EFFECTIVELY PERFORM THE
MYSTERY OF FIELD WORK LOAD. IN A
TIME TIME A CONSISTENT MANNER
AND USES THE SUFFICIENT TO
IMPROVE OUR EFFICIENCY.
THE PROPOSAL ALSO PROVIDES
RESOURCES TO CONDUCT A MANAGE
CONTROL QUALITY PROVE PROJECTS
AUGMENTS HIS WITHIN OUR CENTERS
OF PERSONAL SERVER KITCHEN
BRANCH TO ADDRESS ANTICIPATED
INCREASES IN THE NUMBER
INDIVIDUALS SEEKING TO BE
LICENSED AND CERTIFIED NURSE
ASSISTANTS. AND PROVIDES
RESOURCES TO PROCESS ENVIRON
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE AND THE
TREATY WAIVERS AS A RESULT OF
CHANGES MADE VICE SENATE BILL
NINETY SEVEN LAST YEAR.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OLYMPIC.
THE LAW DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AWARE SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL WE
BELIEVE THAT THE RESOURCES ARE
WILL BETTER POSITION THE
DEPARTMENT TO ADDRESS THE
EXISTING A WORKLOAD NEEDS.
MITIGATE BACKLOG AND ALSO A
POSITION THEM AWHILE TO AND. TO
ADDRESS THE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH IMPLEMENTING AND A NEW
STAFFING STANDARDS.
PLAYER.
SONYA PARA KALLIO.
WE'VE REVIEWED THE REQUEST FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
FOR ADDITIONAL POSITIONS IN THE
CENTER FOR HEALTH CARE QUALITY.
FIFTEEN OF THESE POSITIONS ARE
REALLY IN RESPONSE TO THESE NEW
STAFFING REQUIREMENTS AT SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AND IN.
A RESPONSE TO THE ANTICIPATED
INCREASE IN DEMAND FOR CERTIFIED
NURSE ASSISTANTS AS WELL AS
CERTIFIED NURSE ASSISTANT
TRAINING PROGRAMS.
WE WANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS ONE PROPOSAL IN A
PACKAGE OF PROPOSALS THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PUT FORWARD.
THERE ARE PROPOSALS IN THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOP
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
SO ARE OVER OUR OFFICE JUST
RELEASED.
ANALYSIS OF THIS PACKAGE OF
PROPOSALS THE THUNDER WEBSITE
BUTTER OVERARCHING
RECOMMENDATION IS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO. CONSIDER THE
PACKAGE OF PROPOSALS AS A WHOLE
RATHER THAN CONSIDERING EACH OF
THESE COMPONENTS.
IN A SILO TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY WORK WELL TOGETHER AND
THAT.
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE CONSIDERING
FOR EXAMPLE STAFFING POSITIONS
OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THAT IT'S THE RIGHT NUMBER BASED
ON SOME OF THE OTHER.
PROPOSALS THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED.
I'M IN ADDITION WE HAVE A FEW
CONCERNS ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH'S
A SPECIFIC PROPOSAL.
ONE OF THE IS ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT FIFTEEN POSITIONS ARE REALLY
NEEDED SO IN THE COURSE OF.
ANALYZING THIS A PROPOSAL WE
LEARNED THAT FOR EXAMPLE THE
DEPARTMENT WILL BE. LAUNCHING AN
ONLINE AN ONLINE SYSTEM.
THIS HOPEFULLY THIS CALENDAR
YEAR.
THAT WILL ALLOW.
NURSE NURSES TO.
THEIR SUBSISTENCE RATHER TO
SUBMIT THEIR APPLICATIONS
ONLINE.
PRESUMABLY.
THIS WOULD REDUCE THE NEED FOR
AS MANY POSITIONS.
AT DPH TO REVIEW THOSE
APPLICATIONS.
.
IN ADDITION WERE NOT CONVINCED
THAT ALL OF ALL FIFTEEN
POSITIONS NEED TO BE PERMANENT.
SO FOR EXAMPLE AS SOME OF THE
WAIVER APPLICATIONS THAT SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES MY REQUEST.
AS WELL AS.
NEW APPLICATIONS FOR CERTIFIED
NURSE ASSISTANTS WE EXPECT THAT
THOSE MAY.
.
CERTAIN PEAK IN THE FIRST FEW
YEARS AND THEN TAPER OFF AND IN
FACT IF. IF MANY OF THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES ARE STILL
REQUESTING.
WAIVERS AFTER THREE YEARS WHEAT
YOU KNOW WE MIGHT HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT'S
NOT WORKING.
AND FINALLY WE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT IF.
IF THESE POSITIONS OUR OR SOME
A NUMBER OF POSITIONS ARE
IMPROVED.
WE WOULD ALSO RECOMMEND GREATER
TRANSPARENCY ABOUT PROCESSING
TIMES ON TO SEE IF THESE
POSITIONS ARE REALLY IMPROVING
THE PROCESSING TIMES FORGETTING
CERTIFIED NURSE ASSISTANTS.
OUT IN THE WORKFORCE.
THANK YOU.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE TWENTY
SEVEN.
XENON ALL BRING IT UP TO THE
DYESS COMING UP THE DEPARTMENT'S
RESPONSE REGARDING TEMPORARY
VERSES PERMANENT NEED FOR.
THE POSITIONS AS WELL AS THE
METRICS TO FOLLOW UP ON AND
WHETHER PROCESSING TIME WOULD BE
AN APPROPRIATE METRICS CHERYL
ALL START MAYBE MY COLLEAGUES
WILL JOIN AND. SO WE HAVE NO
IDEA REALLY WHAT THE ONGOING
NEEDS WILL BE WE WE SUSPECT THAT
THERE WILL BE A GREAT DEMAND OF
FROM OVER HERE FOR THE INDUSTRY
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE LOS
FELIZ WANTING TO. HAVE A WAIVER
REQUESTS SO THAT REGARD WE
ANTICIPATE A A HIGH DEMAND THE
IN THE CAREER AS WELL AS THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS TO COME. AS
PEOPLE BEGIN TO TRY TO CHURN AND
AND AND WRAP UP THEIR OWN
INDIVIDUAL AND STAFFING IS IN
THE DEPARTMENT ARE IN THE OF
SLEAZE COMMENTS BUT WE BELIEVE
THAT THEY'LL BE AN ONGOING A
REQUEST FOR WAIVER APPLICATIONS.
AND WITH REGARD TO OUR
PROCESSING OF OUR SCENE NAY OF
SEEING THE APPLICATIONS
THEMSELVES.
AGAIN WE DO ANTICIPATE TRYING TO
BRING ONLINE A A SYSTEM FOR A
HELPING THAT THE PROCESS BE MORE
AUTOMATED A BUT WE HAVEN'T EVEN
YET OF BEGIN TO EVEN THINK ABOUT
WHAT THAT WAS GONNA LOOK LIKE
LET ALONE. A CONTRACT AND SO THE
DEVELOPMENT THAT IS STILL SOME
SOME WAYS OUT BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THAT WE HAVEN'T VERY AGING
POPULATION A WE HAVE A. A HIGH
DEMAND IN OUR FACILITIES WE HAVE
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THIS WORKFORCE
IS A WORKFORCE THAT TURNS A LOT
AND SO THIS CAN BE A LOT OF
ACTIVITIES.
PICKING OF THIS YEAR AND NEXT
YEAR THE NEXT TEN YEARS AS
PEOPLE CYCLE IN AND OUT OF OF
THE PROCESS.
AND I WOULD JUST ADD WORTH
RELATIONSHIP TO THE METRICS.
WE ARE NOW LOOKING AT WE WE ARE
COMMITTED TO TRANSPARENCY M.
ANYWAY JUST AS YOU HEARD ADDED
METRICS FOR CA YOU AND SO WE ARE
WORKING WE'VE WE'VE JUST BEGUN.
WORKING TO DEVELOP METRICS TO
POSE FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
CERTIFICATION BRANCH
SO WE NEED TO DEVELOP THE
MEASUREMENTS OF WE HAVE SOME
INTERNALLY BUT WE NEED TO.
DEVELOPMENT A TRACKABLE WAY AND
THEN THERE'S THE ISSUE OF
WORKING WITH THE CONTRACTOR TO
BE ABLE TO GET THEM ONLINE IN
THE FORMAT THAT WE PUT THE OTHER
METRICS OF THAT THEY'RE EASILY
SEARCHABLE AND PEOPLE CAN DO ALL
THE FILTERING SO. WE ARE WORKING
ON THAT BUT IT IS SOME NOISE
OUT.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
TWENTY SEVEN OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE TWENTY.
GERMAN PROBLEM SOME A METAL
MATHIS DREW JOHNSON THE BEST
PART IN A PUBLIC HEALTH. THIS
PROPOSAL REQUESTS BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
INCREASE OUR EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY IN THE BUDGET YEAR IN
THE EVENT THAT THE MANUFACTURING
CYCLE FOR.
TREATMENT FOR INFANT BOTULISM
BABY BIG IS MOVED UP AND LEAKS
INTO THE INTO THE BUDGET YEAR.
WE'VE BEEN IN CONTACT MORE
RECENTLY WITH THE ONLY FDA
APPROVED.
.
PHARMACEUTICAL BIOTECH
PHARMACEUTICAL THAT
MANUFACTURES.
BABY BIG AND THEY'VE GIVEN US
SOME SEVERAL OPTIONS TO WORK
WITH THIS A BABY BIG
MANUFACTURING COMPETES WITH MANY
OF THEIR COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS.
SO WERE TOTAL BIT BEHOLDEN TO
KIND OF THEIR SCHEDULING AND
SOME IT COULD BE MOVED UP AS THE
BUDGET WHICH WOULD REQUIRE SOME
ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY ON OUR END.
BERMAN FINANCE ELIA.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE TWENTY
EIGHT.
SEEING NONE WE WILL BRING IT TO
THE DYESS AND WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
TWENTY EIGHT OPEN.
ISSUE TWENTY MONTH.
ROBERT TAYLOR EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS OFFICE OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC.
I AM SO I'M HERE TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THE.
.
PROVISIONAL ENGLISH OR
REQUESTING FOURTH BE A CRISIS
GRANT THAT'S NOW BEING ISSUED BY
THE. US CDC SERVICE GRANT IS.
SORT OF A NEW APPROACH FOR THE
CDC FOR EMERGENCY FUNDING. ARM
AND IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH IN
THE PAST THEY'VE. IT ISSUED OF
MERCHANTS HE FUNDING LIKE.
AFFORDABLE AND SIKA.
A SORT OF EARMARKED FUNDS THAT
CAME A LITTLE BIT LATE IN THE
ACTUAL EMERGENCY SO THEY ARE
NOW.
PUTTING OUT A GRANT THAT IS.
SOARED AND IDENTIFIED.
IN EACH STATE APPLIES A.
KIND OF ONCE A YEAR AND WE'VE
APPLIED AN WE ARE NOW ON WHAT TO
CON APPROVED BUT UNFUNDED
STATUS.
SO IF THERE'S AN EMERGENCY.
AND THE RISES TO THE LEVEL OF
THE. CDC DESIGNATED EMERGENCY
THEN WE WOULD BE ABLE TO RECEIVE
FUNDING SELECT RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
USING THIS CRAP TO FUND
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO THE
HURRICANES.
AND.
.
THE FUNNY WOULD BE AVAILABLE
MORE QUICKLY THAN HAVING TO WAIT
FOR SPECIALIZED EARMARKED GRANT.
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR THE GRANT
THOUGH IT ALSO THAT THE STATE BE
AVAILABLE TO SPEND THE MONEY
QUICKLY.
SO THE PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
WOULD ALLOW FOR THE NOTIFICATION
TO THE LEGISLATURE BUT THE
AUGMENTATION OF OUR BUDGETS I'M
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN
ORDER TO ALLOW US TO BUILD THE
SPEND THE MONEY.
FOR EMERGENCY ACTIVITIES IN THE
STATE AND FOR THE LOCALS TO
RESPOND TO EMERGENCY I'M IN A
MUCH FASTER WAY THAN WE DO NOW.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A LIVE.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE TWENTY
NINE.
SEEING NONE OF BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS A.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THIS BUT HOLD IT OPEN FOR
NOW.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL CONCLUDE
TODAY'S HEARING THANK YOU BUT.
ROLL CALL.
FAIR ENOUGH.
CAN WE CALL ROLL ON ISSUE ONE.
MATHIS.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT. WILL WILL CLOSED
TODAY'S HERE THANK YOU